HEARING IN THE YEAR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE I LIKE TO THINK OUR
EDUCATORS FOR SHOWING UP ON TIME
OVER HERE TO MY RIGHT. MR MEDINA
AND MR O'DONNELL- AND MAJORITY
LEADER THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
AS WELL SO TODAY IS AN OVERVIEW
HEARING NO ACTION TODAY THIS IS
AN OVERVIEW OF THE- GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET- FOR EDUCATION
PROP NINETY EIGHT NTK. AND THIS
IS IT AGAIN THE PROPOSED BUDGET
IT'S NOW OUR TURN FOR THE NEXT
FOUR MONTHS TO LOOK AT THOSE
IDEAS AND- AND- TAKE A LOOK INTO
CURRENT AND EXPAND ACCORDINGLY-
WITH THE NIGHT WHAT WE KNOW WE
CAN POTENTIALLY DO MORE AS WE
GET INCREASE REVENUE INFORMATION
LATER IN THIS IN THE- IN THE
SPRING SO. WE DO KNOW THAT- THIS
IS BEEN A HISTORIC TIME FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC GET EDUCATION
SYSTEM THE GOOD THE BAD- THE
GOOD IS YOU KNOW WE'RE SPENDING-
HISTORIC LEVELS OF CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYER MONEY ON OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM. OVER TO TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT I
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO WE ARE
FORTY FIFTH OR SO IN THE NATION
FOR PEOPLE FUNDING OUR MIDDLE OF
THE PACK BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
WE'RE NOT- YOU KNOW ROSY AND
EVERYTHING IT'S BEEN A QUITE A
CHALLENGE FOR FAMILIES AND
EDUCATORS. GETTING THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC SO WE HAVE- SOME WORK
TO BE DONE BUT WE DON'T WANT TO
GET LOST UPON THE FACT THAT LAST
YEAR- LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WITH
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PRETTY MUCH
BUILT UPON AND FUNDS SOME OF OUR
COMMITMENTS. HAS AMAZING THINGS
THAT WE DID THAT WE HAD BEEN
TALKING ABOUT FOR DECADES-
THINGS LIKE UNIVERSAL PRE K. VIA
OUR UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM ADDING A
NEW GREAT TO OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
EDUCATION SYSTEM GIVING EVERY
KID A STRONGER START IN SCHOOL
AND LIFE- NOW UNIVERSAL AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. TO MAKE SURE
THAT STUDENTS HAVE A SAFE PLACE
AND ENRICHMENT AFTER SCHOOL
WHETHER PARENTS ARE AT WORK AND
BOTH THESE TWO THINGS REMIND YOU
ARE FOREVER. REGARDLESS OF THE
YEAR AND CUTS A TOO OFTEN.
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES ARE THE
ONES THAT GET SQUEEZED- WE
CERTAINLY- DID A LOT IN
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ONE TIME
WANTED TO LAUNCH A COMMUNITY
SCHOOL- PROGRAM WHICH I KNOW THE
SUPERINTENDENT. IS REALLY
SUPPORT OF CAN'T TALK TO US A
FEW MINUTES ABOUT BUT OUR WORK'S
NOT DONE WE STILL HAVE ISSUES
WERE FOCUSED ON AND- YOU KNOW
LEARNING LOSS AND HOW OUR KIDS
ARE DEALING WITH A PANDEMIC AND
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND-
EXHAUSTED TEACHERS AND- TRYING
TO GET SUBSTITUTES IN THE
CLASSROOM- WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
ISSUES WE NEED TO WORK ON BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
POSITIVE. TODAY'S HEARING WILL
KICK US OFF WITH AN OVERVIEW OF
THE GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSED PROP
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET. AND THE
DYNAMICS OF THE LARGEST ONE TIME
AND ONGOING FISCAL PROPOSALS. IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AGAIN FOR OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM- AND-
BEFORE WE GET GOING WITH OUR
SUPERINTENDENT JUST A FEW.
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS- THE PUBLIC
OF COURSE MAY PARTICIPATE
TODAY'S HEARING IN CENTER OR BY
PHONE. ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC-
WHO WANTS TO PARTICIPATE WE'LL
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK IF YOU WANT
TO TESTIFY IN PERSON- YOU CAN
ALSO GO- VIA OUR- LIVE STREAM.
AND FIND WAYS TO COMMENT ONLINE
OR ON THE PHONE FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE- THE NUMBER FOR
THAT IS IN THE AGENDA BUT JUST
TO REPEAT IT'S ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. ACCESS CODE. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR-
YEAH SO WITH THAT. WE WILL GET
GOING WITH OUR HEARING TODAY ANY
OPENING COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
ARE. EDUCATION SURE OF ANYTHING
GOING TO ADD. MISTER DONALD NO
AYE MR OF MR CHARGES APPRECIATE
THAT WE HAVING OPPORTUNITIES TO
START OFF TODAY WHAT'S GOING TO
BE A VERY HEALTHY CONVERSATION
I'M GONNA SAY FROM MYOWN
EXPERIENCE AS A PARENT RIGHT
WITH KIDS IN SCHOOL WELL
ACTUALLY ONE OF HIGH SCHOOL NO
ONE OUT- AS A TEACHER SOMEONE
WHO'S ACTUALLY BEEN IN THE
CLASSROOM OVER THE BREAK
ASSEMBLY BET- THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF YOU KNOW SCHOOLS UNDER UNDER
A LOT OF PRESSURE RIGHT.
STAFFING WISE HEALTHWISE EXEDRA
SO I HOPE WE KEEP THOSE THINGS
IN MIND AS WE HEAD INTO THE
BUDGET SEASON AND FOCUS ON
SUPPORTING OUR CLASSROOMS IT'S
NOT A YEAR FOR A LOT OF NEW
THINGS QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE
SCHOOLS DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO DO THOSE NEW THINGS THEY
DON'T HAVE THE STAFF. EXEDRA SO
THIS IS A YEAR TO KIND OF MAKE
SURE THAT WE TAKE CARE OF THE
BASICS. AND MAKE SURE THE
STUDENTS HAVE THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED- THE HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH WISE EXCITER AND AGAIN I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT YOU MISTER. OKAY THANK YOU-. OKAY WE WILL START WITH- OUR
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION HIS. WITH US THERE
YOU ARE OVER THERE- ON THE VIDEO
SCREEN LOOKING GOOD INTEREST
FEATHER STATE OFFICE BUILDING
OVER THERE MR THURMAN SO YES
PLEASE- BEGAN AND GIVE US OUR
OVERVIEW FROM THE LANDS OF OUR
CALIFORNIA SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION MISTER
THURMOND. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MATED- GIVE ME A THUMBS UP SO
THAT WE KNOW THAT- YOU ALL CAN
HEAR ME OKAY- I THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS. ABOUT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET AS YOU KNOW- MISTER
CHAIR- AS ALWAYS LIKE TO START
BY ACKNOWLEDGING- OUR STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES FOR THEIR
RESILIENCE IN THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES- ALL OF OUR EDUCATORS ARE.
TEACHERS AD CLASSIFIED STAFF
AND ADMINISTRATORS WHO HAVE BEEN
DOING EVERYTHING TO MAKE SURE
THAT SCHOOLS CAN STAY OPEN- THAT
OUR SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS TO BE
SAFE. AND THAT HIGH QUALITY
LEARNING INSTRUCTION CAN BE
PROVIDED THEY'RE DOING THAT
AGAINST THE BACKDROP OF YOU KNOW
LACK OF COPING MITIGATION
RESOURCES STAFFING SHORTAGES YOU
NAME IT- IT'S DIFFICULT TIMES
SEEMS LIKE IMPOSSIBLE- OBSTACLES
AT TIMES BUT- THEY CONTINUE TO
PERSEVERE AND I WANTED KNOWLEDGE
OUR OUR EDUCATORS AND- ALSO.
THANK OTHER FOLKS AT THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
PROVIDING. COPING MEDICATION
RESOURCES TO OUR SCHOOLS OF
COURSE  THINK I. C. E. STAFF
WORKING AT THE CHALLENGES WITH
J. THIRTEEN A WAIVER QUESTIONS
TO HELP OUR SCHOOLS AND STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION STAFF
EVERYONE COMING TOGETHER. TO TRY
AND SUPPORT- OUR STUDENTS AS YOU
NOTED MISTER CHAIR OF THIS
BUDGET AGAIN- PROJECTS A RECORD
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION AT THIS TIME BUT I
PROPOSED INCREASE WILL BE EIGHT
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS- FOUR
EIGHT WHICH WOULD BE THE HIGHEST
LEVEL. OF FUNDING- FOR A K.
FOURTEEN SCHOOLS THAT WE'VE EVER
SEE AND SO IN SPITE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE EXPERIENCE IT
RECORD A PROPOSED INVESTMENTS UP
FOR CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS- JUST
TOOK OFF A FEW OF THOSE THINGS
THEM. FIFTY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS- BUT TO SUPPORT
INVESTMENTS THAT HELP US ATTRACT
AND RETAIN QUALIFIED TEACHERS
AND SUBSTITUTES UP A CRITICAL
ISSUES FOR SHORT A NUMBER OF
INVESTMENTS THAT HELP US BE
CLOSING. THE OPPORTUNITY GAP
REPORT WERE BILLION DOLLARS- TO
SUPPORT- EXTENDED EXPANDED LEARN
IN OPPORTUNITY. A COLLEGE AND
CAREER PATH. ALONG WITH BILLION
DOLLARS TO SOME- OUR PATH. FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY DOLLARS SUPPORT-
RELATED LITERACY EFFORTS
INCLUDING- READING SPECIALISTS
AND COACHES AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
IT SEPTEMBER AND NAME DATE-
ADDITION TO ENSURE READING BY.
THIRD GRADE AND TO GET THAT DONE
OF THE COURT THE NEXT FOR FIVE
YEARS AND- WE ALIGNED WITH THESE
INVESTMENTS- WE HOPE TO SEE MORE
THINGS TO SUPPORT. CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS EVEN AS WE SPEAK NUMBER
PROVIDING BOOKS TO FAMILIES-
I'LL BE PROVIDED SOME ONLINE
BOOKS TO FAMILIES MORE THAN TWO
MILLION BOOKS READ ONLINE IN
JUST TWO MONTHS. A MILLION BOOKS
DOWNLOADED FOR FREE TO STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA. OF THIS BUT HE
PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT SPECIAL EDUCATION.
FUNDING FORMULA OF. A BILLION
BUCKS FIRST YEAR TRANSITIONAL
BURKE. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
CHAIR AND UP WITH ONE POINT.
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT- ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT THE FIRST YEAR AND OF
COURSE INVESTMENTS TO HELP AS IN
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN OVER
THE NEXT SEVERAL. YEARS I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DID NOT TALK
ABOUT THAT- INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT SCHOOL SAFETY AND COBIT
MEDICATION- A NOTING THAT THIRTY
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS- A
BOTH OR TESTING- ENERGY TESTING
TESTING ON SITE- PP YOU NAME IT
ALL THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW.
HAVE BECOME IMPORTANT THAT
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS- MS OUR
SCHOOL SITE YESTERDAY- WHERE THE
FOOD SERVICE STAFF HAD- RECENTLY
SERVE SOME FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
MEALS TO. OUR OUR STUDENTS AND
SO ON THAT NOTE I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS BUDGET- AS
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS INCLUDING
FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT- OUR
EFFORT TO CREATE UNIVERSAL
MEALS. UP FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS AND OF COURSE THE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT THAT IS
PROPOSED. UP FOR STUDENTS-
PROPOSALS TO SUPPORT OUR SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS AND-YOU
KNOW OF COURSE WE'RE ALL
THINKING ABOUT DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND THAT THIS BUDGET
WOULD. ALLOW THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
DISTRICTS THE USE THE HIGHEST
AVERAGE OF THREE YEARS- TO HELP
THEM SUSTAIN IT OFFSET- THE
CHALLENGES- THAT YOU'RE- SEEING.
IN DECLINE ENROLLMENT I LIKE TO
JUST MENTION THAT THIS BUDGET
REALLY DOES BUILD ON LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AND- IF WE COULD JUST
QUICKLY SHOW SCREENED OUT LIKE
THAT. I JUST SHOW YOU A SHORT
VISUAL THAT- HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF
THE WAYS THAT- THIS PROPOSED
BUDGET BILLS ON LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AND MANY OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE- THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATIONIST HELPING TO
IMPLEMENT. THAT WE CALL- THAT WE
RECOGNIZE HAVING THE ABILITY TO
TRANSFER- TO TRANSFORM
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AS YOU CAN
SEE AT THE TOP- UNIVERSAL MEALS-
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL PRO GRAM'S.
RE BILLION DOLLARS FOR COMMUTER
SCHOOL ALL KIND OF RAPPER
SUPPORT. HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH
SOCIAL SIR. AND ALSO PRO TO HELP
AND THIS TO PRISON. OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT ANTI
RACISM GRANTS A FOUR POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN MENTAL HEALTH
AND OF COURSE EXPANDED- LEARNING
PROGRAMS THAT UNIVERSAL EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAM SO. WE BELIEVE
THAT THESE PROGRAMS TO HELP OUR
SCHOOLS TO TRANSFORM BUT FIRST
WE HAVE TO KEEP IN STATE. AND SO
WE THINK OF IT IN THESE TERMS
THAT WE HELP OUR STUDENTS TO-
TO- RECOVER FROM THE TRAUMA OF
THE PANDEMIC- AND THEN TO
RECOVER ACADEMICALLY ONE THE
HEAL. FROM THE TRAUMA AND THEN
YOU WANT TO PUT THEM IN A
POSITION TO THRIVE AND SO YOU'LL
HEAR US TALK THIS YEAR ABOUT
LEGISLATION THAT WE ARE
SPONSORING. THAT CAN HELP US IN
THAT WAY- WE THINK THAT ONE OF
OUR TOP ORDERS BUSINESS HAS TO
BE SUPPORTING THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU HEAR US
TALKING ABOUT A NEW PROPOSAL-
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO-
ULTIMATELY RECRUIT TEN THOUSAND
ONE MENTAL HEALTH. CLINICIANS TO
SUPPORT THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS IT'S NO MYSTERY
WE HAVE. A SHORTAGE WE WILL WORK
WITH SHORTAGE IN EVERY SINGLE
PART OF THE EDUCATION SECTOR IN
THE WHOLE US THERE'S A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE IN EVERY EMPLOYMENT
SECTOR. AND SO WE WILL BE WE BOB
SPONSORING LEGISLATION- THAT
WOULD GENERATE REVENUE TO
PROVIDE ANOTHER TEN THOUSAND BUT
I HEALTH CONDITIONS WERE ALSO
SPONSORED LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO. RETAIN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND TEACHERS WHO ARE
TEACHING RIGHT NOW UNDER
EXECUTIVE ORDER- THEY NEED TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL INDUCTION- DONE
TO COMPLETE CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS. WE KNOW THAT OUR
TOP WATER BUSINESS HAS TO BE-
BUILDING OUT OUR STAFF. EVEN IF.
I'M HOSTING A PART OF THE MANY
MEETINGS THAT IS FOCUSED ON HOW
WE CLOSE OUR STAFF SHORTAGE
REVOKE A SINGLE WHERE DID THESE
FOLKS GO THOSE WHO HAVEN'T
RETURNED. TO THE EDUCATION FIELD
WHERE DID THEY GO WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IT EITHER. THESE
COMPENSATION BILL THE PATHWAY.
BUILT MORE TRAINING TO GET MORE
TEACHERS WHAT DRIVERS AND SO
WILL BE A WORKING ON ALL OF
THESE. WILL BE WORKING ON THINGS
THAT WE WILL HELP OUR STUDENTS
THRIVE. BUT OUR TOOL LANGUAGE.
IMMERSION PROGRAM. RESPONSIBLE
THIS YEAR THAT WILL ALLOW OUR
SCHOOLS TO CONVERT- INTO DUAL
LANGUAGE SCHOOLS YOU KNOW THAT
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT. IS SET UP.
TO HELP SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS TO
BE GLOBAL THINKERS S. SUPPORTS
THAT SHE'D MET. WE BELIEVE THAT
WILL BE IMPORTANT MANY FAMILIES
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST. IN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHEN
THEY SEE THAT MORE OF OUR
SCHOOLS ARE TOOL LANGUAGE
PROGRAM SO WE SUBMIT THESE- I
THOUGHT TO YOU- ABOUT THE
CURRENT BUDGET WE THINK THAT
THERE ARE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITIES. TO DO MORE- AND-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR IN THE MONTHS
TO COME. ON HOW THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL- GETS THAT DISCUSSED
AND DEBATED. AND HOW WE CANNOT
FINE TUNING. OUT TO HAVE A FINAL
BUDGET IN MAY- THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL HELP OUR STUDENTS. TO HEAL-
OF THE TRAUMA THE PANDEMIC. ALL
RIGHT TO BE COVERED IN TERMS OF
LEARNING GAPS IN LEARNING LOST.
IT TO THRIVE IN TERMS OF HOW WE
HELP TO ACCELERATE THEIR
LEARNING AND DEVELOPMENT ONE
FOUR. ALSO APPEARED AS THE CHAIR
AND DESK MAKE ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MAY. OKAY THANK. ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE CLASS FOR THIS
AND MISTER MY- DEGREE DEGREE TO
HAVE YOU WITH US THIS MORNING-
AND LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WE SAW
MONEY- ALLOCATED FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND- DOES THAT
MAKE. AND IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING. GLAZER FIRST TIME
- INSTALLMENT IS THERE ANY MONEY
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO HELP-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- IMPLEMENTED
AND TRAIN THEIR TEACHERS TO-
TEACH US THAT AND WHAT IS NEEDED. AND YOU'RE YOU'RE ON MUTE
THEIR- OWN. OKAY. HELLO. THERE
WE GO TRY AGAIN SIMILARLY WHEN
YOU ASK THE QUESTION AGAIN DID
ARE WERE YOU ABLE TO HEAR THE
QUESTION. NOW TWENTY YOU DIDN'T
HEAR THE QUESTION. I WAS BUT
BECAUSE OF TECHNOLOGY I'M NOT
SURE THAT ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HEARD THE
QUESTION- BUT- YOU GET TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT- ETHNIC STUDIES- OUR
OFFICE HAS ALREADY- IS AIRING A
RELEASE A REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS
TO- SOLICIT- COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THAT WILL SUPPORT THE
PROVIDING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ON HOW DISTRICTS
WILL BUILD UP THEIR- NECKS
STUDIES- CURRICULUM SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. ON THIS AND
NOTE THAT STEPS ARE IN THE WORKS
TO HELP OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BUILD OUT THEIR OWN VERSIONS OF
ETHICS THAT. I AND I THINK. THE
SECOND PART OF MY QUESTION- THAT
WAS MY UNDERSTANDING AGAIN THAT
THE LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WAS JUST
THE FIRST INSTALLMENT. OF I
WOULD THINK THAT MORE MONEY IS
NEEDED IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
FOR IMPLEMENTATION AND TRAINING
. I'M CHECKING MY NOTES AND I'LL
ASK MY STAFF TO DO THE SAME WITH
ME TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY-
DIRECTOR OF REFERENCES TO
INVESTMENTS AND SPECIAL AND AN
ETHNIC STUDIES THERE ARE
INVESTMENTS THAT WOULD SUPPORT
THE BUILDING OUT OF OTHER
CURRICULA- IN PARTICULAR- NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDIES- A CAMBODIAN
AND VIETNAMESE- STUDY CURRICULA-
I WILL CHECK MY NOTES HERE TO DO
ANYTHING SPECIFIC TO THE OVERALL
BROAD CATEGORIES ABOUT THAT OKAY
I WOULD THINK THAT DISTRICTS CAN
I HAVE A LONG WAYS TO GO AND
THEY'RE GONNA NEED HELP AND
SUPPORT SO. WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S SUCCESSFUL AT THE
DISTRICT LEVEL. IT IS LOCAL OF
THAT IS SORT OF IN ABSOLUTELY I
THINK THERE ARE STILL DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS TAKING PLACE
ABOUT. WHAT IS HAPPENING STUDIES
AGAIN AS WE'RE BUILDING ON LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET- I NOTICED I NOTED
THAT TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ADDRESSING ANTI RACISM. OF
PROGRAMS I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT-
DOLLARS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ALLOCATED TO EVERY SINGLE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. OR UP EDUCATED
WORKFORCE GRANTS THAT CAN BE
USED TO ADDRESS IMPLICIT BIAS-
YOU KNOW WE'RE PARTNERING. WITH
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING- THAT HAS- A FIVE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT SCHOLARSHIPS. THAT CAN
BE USED TO HELP DIVERSIFY THE
TEACHER WORKFORCE AT LEAST TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. AGAIN
THAT COULD BE USED TO HELP-
VERSIFI THE WORK FORCE AND SO-
WOULD CERTAINLY WORKING TO PUT
ALL THESE PIECES TOGETHER- TO
SUPPORT- MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS GET ACCESS. INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR HERITAGE IN THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE RANSOM
THURSDAY AS A RELAY SAY THAT
NEXT THAT. AND THAT WE HAVE WAYS
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF RACISM
THAT HAVE IMPACTED AND
PRESENTED. HERE'S TO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS OF COLOR I'M SO THAT
WE'RE GIVING EVERYONE A CHANCE
THAT. EXPERIENCE THAT WOULD BE
THE CHANCE YOU HAVE A CHANCE. TO
GET A GREAT EDUCATION A
MOVEMENT. THANK YOU TO BRING AND
THEN I WILL WILL FOLLOW UP WE
YOUR OFFICE. AS WELL. WELL MY
SURE TO CIRCLE BACK WITH THE
THANK YOU A MEMBER THANK YOU
OKAY SOMEONE RENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU-
STATE SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
TODAY AND YOUR COMMITMENTS AYE I
WILL TELL YOU THAT. IF IT WERE
REALLY ENCOURAGED BY THIS
HISTORIC INVESTMENT IN OUR
STUDENTS. MOST ESPECIALLY OUR
SPECIAL ED YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT
NUTRITION PER STATE PRESCHOOL
FOSTER YOUTH ARE ADULTS IN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES. THESE
ARE ALL POSITIVE THINGS THAT DID
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET AS A
RESULT OF THIS INVESTMENT. SOME
OF MY CONCERNS AND I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU HAVE ADDRESSED THEM
HERE AND I'VE HEARD YOU SPEAK
BEFORE. BUT DECLINING ENROLLMENT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS AFFECTING
MANY OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM. AND THE
LACK OF DATA AND COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS OF THESE TRENDS. THE
SOMETHING THAT YOU HAVE TALKED
ABOUT IN THE PAST AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THIS- THE BUT I THINK ANOTHER
AREA AND IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
GROWING OPPORTUNITY GAPS AND
THAT THE STUDENT DISENGAGEMENT
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT AGAIN
ARE AFFECTING OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY. K. THROUGH TWELVE.
HOURS WE KNOW TRUMP'S FROM THE
DATA THAT WE HAVE THAT WE HAVE
REVIEWED. THESE SORTS OF THINGS
AFFECT OUR- STUDENTS OF COLOR
AND OUR LOW INCOME STUDENTS MORE
THAN ANY ANYONE ELSE. SO I
APPRECIATE I WANT YOU TO KNOW
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT YOU DO TO UPLIFT. OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. AND MY
QUESTION HAS TO DO SPECIFICALLY
WITH THE WHAT WE HAVE SEEN AS
THIS LACK OF DATA AND
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF THE
TRENDS OF THE CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM AND THE CLERK
DECLINING ENROLLMENT. DO YOU
HAVE ANY UPDATES ON WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO TRY TO GATHER THIS DATA
AND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO ABOUT
IT. THANK YOU MAJORITY LEADER
FOR- WAR OF RAISING THESE ITEMS
AND I'M FINDING IT A LITTLE BIT
IS CERTAINLY ON THE MINDS. OF
ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS AND I KNOW
OUR LEGISLATIVE PARTNERS- FOR US
AND FOR THE GOVERNMENT. AND YOU
KNOW IN SOME PLACES WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER SOME SMALL
PILOTS TO DO SOME OUTREACH TO
FAMILIES THAT UP TO TRYING TO ME
AGE THEM. USING FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT STRATEGIES AND HOME
VISITING AND SOME OF US HAVE
BEEN GRANT SUPPORTED WE'VE BEEN
UNDER EXCUSE ME GRANTS THE
RECIPE FOUNDATION. ALLOWS TO
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH DISTRICTS
LIKE INGLEWOOD UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT- TO DO SOME
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT ON VISITING
SPECIFICALLY AROUND FAMILIES
THAT JUST WE'RE STUDENTS JUST
NEVER CHECKED IN- INTO WORK TO
OFFSET- THE HELP THOSE- IN
ROAMING ISSUES- OF COURSE.
WHAT'S PROPOSED IN THIS BUDGET
TO GIVE DISTRICTS THE ABILITY-
TO CHOOSE THE YOU KNOW- THAT ONE
EIGHTY YEARS OF THE HIGHEST
EIGHTY EIGHT- OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS. WILL HELP TO
BOLSTER DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS AS WE GO FORWARD- THIS
YEAR- BUT THERE WILL BE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT THAT IS PROJECTED.
FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS TO
COME AND I KNOW THAT YOU'LL HEAR
MORE ABOUT THIS FROM THE L. A.
O.'S OFFICE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS THERE HAVE BEEN
PROJECTIONS THAT. POPULATION
ISSUES AND GROWTH AND DECLINE-
THAT WE'LL BE SEEING MORE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT- THERE ARE
GREAT PROPOSALS- THAT WOULD
CHANGE THE WAY SCHOOLS IF
APPROVED THIS YEAR- THERE ARE
pTHE WAY SCHOOLS RECEIVE FUNDING-
FOUR FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT AND THAT
THE- OF A GREAT PROPOSAL- THAT
WOULD CONVERT CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
FROM EIGHTY EIGHT BASED SYSTEM-
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE BASED
SYSTEM. TO AN ENROLLMENT BASE
SYSTEM- AND THAT WOULD HAVE
DOLLARS SPECIFICALLY HAVE TO BE
COMMITTED OF THE PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL THAT I'M REFERENCING
WOULD REQUIRE. 50% OF THE
ADDITIONAL ON THAT DISTRICTS
RECEIVE. WOULD HAVE TO GO TO
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS- A CHRONIC
GAPS. A BIG FAN OF THIS
PROPOSAL- THE TALKING SCHOOL.
ASSOCIATION SENATOR PORTANTINO
OFF THIS LETTER- IT THEM WE
INTEND TO SUPPORTED AND
SPONSORING IN ANY WAY WE CAN. DO
THAT YOU KNOW- META MCCARTY I
SPENT QUITE A LOT TEN. TRYING TO
FIGURE WAYS HELP OUR- ADDRESS
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM BUT WE THINK
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS SELECTED.
WOULD PROVIDE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITH THE STEADY. REVENUE TO
OFFSET THE DECLINING ENROLLMENT
TRENDS THAT WE SEE AN IMPORTANT.
RESOURCES TO- HELP GET THOSE
FAMILIES BACK IN SCHOOL AND. TO
ADDRESS A CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM.
THANK YOU SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL I
THANK YOU MISTER CHARGES ONE OF
AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER THURMAN
FOR BEING HERE AND I THINK THAT-
THAT BILL WITH REGARD TO-
WHETHER WE GO EIGHTY A OR
ENROLLMENT- IS GOING TO REQUIRE
MORE CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT MAY
IN FACT BE CREATING ANOTHER
CATEGORICAL WHICH IS SOMETHING
WE ARE TRYING TO GET AWAY FROM
HER HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET AWAY
FROM- BUT I JUST. YOU KNOW I'M
HEARING A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY
HISTORICA STORE HISTORIC. IN A
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS WILL TO
FIVE POINT THREE THREE PERCENT.
ADDITION COLA UNDERBASE RIGHT.
IN AN ERA WHERE WE HAVE ABOUT
WHAT FOUR. PERCENT PLUS
INFLATION. RIGHT OR IN AN ERA
WHERE WE HAVE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND HIGHER STUDENT
NEEDS. THAN WE EVER HAVE AND
THAT GOES FOR ALL STUDENT
POPULATIONS IN OUR K. TWELVE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. SO I JUST
YOU KNOW AS PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
HISTORICAL STORIES STORK I JUST
WANT THEM TO REMEMBER THAT
THERE. IS ALSO SOME OTHER THINGS
SOME OTHER FACTORS IN HERE THAT
ARE IMPACTING OUR BUDGETS THAT
ARE VERY HISTORIC AS WELL. THANK
YOU SEVEN MEMBERS ON ALL AND WE
- YES WE HAVE WE GOT. WELL SAID
WE DO HAVE A- THE FINANCE DELEO
IN OTHERS IT'S AND MR THURMAN'S
DEPARTMENT TALK ABOUT THE ACTUAL
BUDGET PROPOSALS BUT- QUESTION
OR COMMENT FOR THE
SUPERINTENDENT MISTER GALLAGHER.
YEAH JUST A QUICK FOLLOW U ON-
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH IT
ONE THING I HAVE BEEN HEARING
QUITE A BIT FROM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. IS I MEAN CERTAINLY
THIS ADDITIONAL MONEY WAS VERY
HELPFUL- BUT THERE IS THIS
FEELING THAT WERE ALMOST
CREATING CATEGORICAL IS AGAIN.
AND THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS-
FOR EACH GRANT. ESPECIALLY ON
LIKE SMALLER DISTRICTS WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF IS REALLY
BURDENSOME. AND THEY AND WANT
ONE SUGGESTION THAT THEY'VE MADE
TO ME AND I THINK MAY MAKE SENSE
IS WHY NOT JUST HAVE THIS BE ALL
PART OF THE L. CAP- SO IT'S KIND
OF ALL INCLUSIVE AND THAT YOU'RE
DOING IT ONE TIME. AND YOU'RE
HAVING TO DO IT FOR SEVERAL.
DIFFERENT THINGS CERTAINLY WANT
ACCOUNTABILITY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE MONEY'S BEING. YOU KNOW
SPENT TO KEEP KIDS IN SCHOOL AND
DEAL WITH THE THINGS- THE OTHER
THING WE'VE IDENTIFIED BUT- YOU
KNOW WE COULD BE CREATED A WHOLE
NOTHER. ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
AND PROBLEM- THAT TAKES AWAY
FROM. PROVIDE EDUCATION TO KIDS-
SO I THINK. THAT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD MAYBE THINK ABOUT I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S SOMETHING YOU
GUYS HAVE DISCUSSED- MISTER
SUPERINTENDENT- BUT MAYBE YOU
COULD A GUY STYLE LITTLE BIT.
THANK IS A MEMBER GALLAGHER IT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE TALK ABOUT
ALL THE TIME AND WE'D LIKE TO
SEE MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS BE
IMPLEMENTED ON A FORMAL BASIS-
RATHER THAN- PUTTING DISHES IN A
PLACE WHERE THEY HAVE TO. APPLY
FOR GRANTS AND THAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW WITH THE EDUCATED
WORKFORCE GRANT WE LOVE TO SEE
THAT HAPPEN WITH FUTURE
ALLOCATIONS UP FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SO THERE'S NOT- THE
PRESSURE ON OUR SMALL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE RULE DISTRICTS. THAT
DON'T HAVE GRANT WRITING STAFF
THAT DON'T HAVE THAT CAPACITY-
TO BE. CHASING DOWN GRANTS YEAH
THAT DOES REQUIRE SOME
LEGISLATIVE ACTION BUT WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GRANTS TO BE IMPLEMENTED AWAY.
BASED ON FORMULAS BASED ON-
YOU'LL NEED BASED ON NEED
CATEGORIES LIKE- BUT THIS
PATIENT OR A PERCENTAGE OF MUCH
PROGRAM- YOU KNOW THE NUMBER OF
YOUTH- LIVING IN POVERTY WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE WAYS TO
DO THAT- WE THINK THAT THERE ARE. WAYS TO ALSO- THE ARE GREAT
INITIAL WE WANT TO FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE BEING WEIGHTED DOWN ON
DISTRICTS AND SO WE- KNOW IF YOU
TAKE. IT AS AN EXAMPLE THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS INITIATIVE.
YOU'VE REACHED OUT TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO SAY TALK WITH US
ABOUT HOW THESE CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED. IN A WAY THAT THEY
ARE OF BENEFIT TO YOU AND NOT
JUST. ONE MORE THINK WE USED TO
HAVE TO- HAVE TO CHECK OFF ON
THE BOX AND WE'VE HELD. MEETINGS
WITH DISTRICTS NEED GIVING US
FEEDBACK ABOUT HOW TO MAKE THESE
PROGRAMS. MANAGEABLE YOU KNOW
THE MCCARTY LEADER ASKED ABOUT
HOW DO E DO MOREFAMILY
ENGAGEMENT I CAN'T THINK OF ANY
PROGRAM MORE FOR ITS- COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS INITIATIVE TO HELP.
PROMOTE THAT FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
AND I'M WILL BE DOING A TOWN
HALLS WITH FAMILIES AND PARENTS
UP THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I WOULD
ALSO JUST- KNOWLEDGE THAT- WE
BELIEVE THAT- ARE DISTRICTS WANT
THESE PROGRAMS AND THEY WANT TO
BE THOUGHT ONLY ONCE YOU GET
FEEDBACK AND- I WILL DO ALL THAT
WE CAN TO. YOU KNOW. MAKE IT THE
GRANT PROCESS SEES MORE
EFFICIENT- TO GET MORE FEEDBACK
AND- BUT WE WITH THE FEEDBACK
THAT WE RECEIVED THAT THESE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DISTRICTS
WANT. WE HAVE TO BE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT HOW WE IMPLEMENT THEM. UP
SO THAT THEY MEET THEIR NEEDS
AND- WE'RE COMMITTED TO DOING
THAT AND WE'RE PARTNERING WITH
THAT. IT'S ALL ACROSS THE STATE
TO GET YOUR FEEDBACK ON HOW TO
MAKE IT. TATIAN ACHIEVABLE. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY DARK. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR THE
AGENDA REFLECTS THAT. ONE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE OF THE ONE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE ELIGIBLE
ALLEY AS CERTIFIED THAT THEIR
SCHOOLS OFFERED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION BY MAY FIFTEENTH AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THEREBY
QUALIFYING THEM FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION GRANTS PROVIDED
THROUGH EARLY BUDGET ACTION AND
THE SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
FOR THOSE THAT DID NOT OFFER IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION BY APRIL
FIRST 202-020-2020 ONE THERE I.
P. I. GRANTS WERE REDUCED BY 1%
FOR EACH ADDITIONAL.
INSTRUCTIONAL DAY UNTIL IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION WAS AVAILABLE
SO WELL STUDENT SUCCESS IN MY
MIND YOU THAT NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS WERE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THESE FUNDS UP WELL
STUDENTS ASSESSMENT DATA FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR IS
LIMITED WE SHOULD BE EVALUATING
STUDENT OUTCOMES ENGAGEMENT
BASED ON THE FUNDING AND
INSTRUCTIONAL OFFERINGS
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS AND THE
CITY HE SHOULD BE PREPARED TO
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION. FOR
THE MAY REVISE SO HOW MUCH I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS HOW HOW
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION PLAN TO
ENSURE THAT SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN FUNDING FOR THE T. T. K. AND
I LIKE ADDING THE T. K. NOT JUST
K. ANYMORE THE TWELVE EDUCATION
ACTUALLY RESULT IN EDUCATIONAL
GAMES ASSEMBLY MEMBER COREY I
YEAH THAT'S GREAT QUESTIONS BUT
WE PAUSE REAL QUICK BECAUSE THAT
THE SUPERINTENDENT AND HE'S JUST
GIVING OUR OVERVIEW. WE'RE GONNA
GET THE GOVERNOR'S- PEOPLE HERE
FROM DLF AND L. A. L. JUST A FEW
SECONDS SO- ANY PARTING
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THAT
SUPERINTENDENT. PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION MR FONG. I THANK YOU
MISTER- I Y. TO APPROVE YOU
ACKNOWLEDGING THE WORK FORCE AND
STAFFING CHALLENGES I THINK YOU.
KIND OF ALLUDED TO THAT WHEN YOU
SPOKE TO MY AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FROM- FROM THE NORTH STATE.
BUT AS YOU DEVELOP PATHWAYS AND
INITIATIVES- WILL IN DEALING
WITH THE TEACHER SHORTAGE IN
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES. I WONDER IF
YOU COULD ELABORATE ON THE
INITIATIVES THAT YOU'RE ROLLING
OUT ON HOW THEY APPLY OR WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING FROM RURAL
REGIONS RURAL COMMUNITIES. AND
RURAL- SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN TERMS
OF THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS AND TRYING
TO ATTRACT- TALENTED TEACHERS
INTO THEIR INTO THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. BUT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG I WOULD JUST
SAY- THAT THE- BUT USES A
PARALLEL OUR PROPOSAL TO RECRUIT
TEN THOUSAND MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICIANS. IS LARGELY BUILT
WITH SMALL GROUP DISTRICTS IN
MINE- AS YOU KNOW- NINETEEN OF
OUR COUNTIES EXPERIENCED BUYER.
LAST YEAR AND I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT AND TRY TO
BRING SUPPORT TOO MANY OF THEM.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC WAS ACCESS. THE
COUNSELORS AND- COUNSELORS YOU
CAN ADDRESS THE TRAUMA THAT MANY
OF EXPERIENCE WHEN THEY'VE LOST
THE HOME OFFICE SCHOOL MAYBE THE
LOSS OF LOVED ONES. IT'S SO THIS
PROPOSAL REALLY IS BUILT TO
RECOGNIZED THAT MANY OF OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE
HEALTHCARE- ACCESS ISSUES. AND
TO BUILD A PIPELINE OF
COUNSELORS WHO CAN WORK IN OUR
RURAL AREAS SO WE LIKE TO DO THE
SAME. AS WE THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW
TEACHERS AND BUS DRIVERS AND I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE PROPOSALS
AGAIN AND THAT WOULD. PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FOR
TRANSPORTATION THAT COULD HELP
US ADDRESS ISSUES AROUND
RECRUITING MORE BUT PRIVATELY
CLASSIFIED STAFF. BUT AGAIN AS I
POINT OUT THIS MENTAL HEALTH
PROPOSAL IT WAS LARGELY BUILT
WITH THE RECOGNITION. THAT OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES HAVE NOT HAD
THE ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND OTHER. STAFF
THAT OUR SCHOOLS NEED AND AS WE
LEAVE THIS PROPOSAL WILL BE
THINKING ABOUT A RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND URBAN AND
SUBURBAN. COMMUNITIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN ATTRACT THAT
RESIDENTS TO THESE AREAS BY THE
WAY THIS MIGHT HELP PROPOSAL I
WOULD PROVIDE SCHOLARSHIPS THAT
TO FOLKS. WHO COME MEDICAL
CONDITIONS AND IT WOULD REQUIRE
THEM TO SERVE TWO YEARS IN A
COMMUNITY OF HIGH NEED.
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE
THAT HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
REVITALIZED THAT DATA. AND IT'S
A PART OF HOW WE BUILT THESE
PROPOSALS HELP US ADDRESS OUR
WORK WHICH WOULD BE. WELL I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT- BUT
YOU KNOW WE YOU AND I HAVE
TALKED IN AND CERTAINLY THAT THE
NEED FOR COUNSELING AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. THE ROLE
REGION'S IS- IS DEFINITELY-
NECESSARY ESPECIALLY WITH BUS
DRIVERS. WITH A WE IS UP TO AND
ALL OF THOSE. NEED SO IT IS
CERTAINLY A BIG CHALLENGE- AS
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG
BEACH. HAS STATED OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT TODAY WITH A LOT BUT- I
. YOU AT. THE ROLE CAN. IN THE
TO WORKING WITH YOU. YET TODAY
WE'RE AS I MENTIONED TODAY.
HOLDING UP. OF SEVERAL MEETINGS
ON ADDRESSING WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES WILL HAVE A NUMBER OF.
OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM RURAL
DISTRICTS PRESENTING. THEIR
UNIQUE NEEDS. WARS TRYING TO
IDENTIFY STRATEGIES FOR HOW TO
HOW TO OFFSET THOSE TOWNS. OKAY
QUESTION FOR MR SUPERINTENDENT
MYSTIFIED RCS SORRY TO GO BACK
TO MY QUESTION ABOUT THE ONE
THOUSAND SEVENTY- SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE ELEAZAR RECEIVED IN
PERSON GRANTS WHO DO WE KNOW OR
WHAT ARE WE EXPECTING TO SEE.
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITY
GRANT REPORTING AND WHAT TYPES
OF INFORMATION ARE WE EXPECTING
RECEIVE I MEAN IS THERE GOING TO
BE REPORTING ON WHETHER. THEY
WERE JUST OPEN OR NOT OR OR
THEIR METRICS IDENTIFIED AND HOW
MANY STUDENTS WERE SERVED AND
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS OUR INELIGIBLE. FOR THE
I. P. I. GRANTFUNDS. TURNABOUT
IS A BE HAPPY TO GET THAT DATA
FOR YOU- I COULD NOT COME
PREPARED WITH NUMBERS OF- UP FOR
EXTENDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT OUR
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN. I SINCE
SEPTEMBER MYSELF I PROBABLY
VISITED FORTY FIVE DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS AND- TO SUPPORT THEIR
OPENING ACTIVITIES THAN OUR
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN. AND THEY ARE
SCHOOLS ARE USING THEIR EXPANDED
LEARNING GRANTS AND THEY'RE AB
EIGHTY SIX DOLLARS TO BUILD
EXPANDED LEARNING BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZED. THAT EDUCATION
HAPPENS NOT JUST DURING THE
CLASS DATE BUT BEFORE SCHOOL AND
AFTER SCHOOL THAT REACH OUT TO
OUR STAFF IN THE EXPANDED
LEARNING DIVISION AND- THOSE
WORKING ON UNIVERSAL MEALS
HELPING OUR SCHOOLS BUILD OUT
THESE IMPORTANT PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS. SO THEY
CAN LEARN WELL THEY HAVE TO
CIRCLE BACK WITH YOUR STAFF WITH
SPECIFIC NUMBERS THAT YOU BUT
IT. HERE TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S LET'S AYE MOVE
ON TO OUR- BECAUSE TO. TWENTY
TWO BUDGET AND HEAR FROM THE
PERMANENT FINANCE L. A. L. AND A
PART OF EDUCATION ISSUE ONE IS
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT OVERVIEW
AND PROPOSALS. BRENT HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TICKETS
OFF HERE IN HER AREA. YEAH GOOD
MORNING CARE MEMBERS SENATE AREA
OCCUPYING AND HOPEFULLY EVERYONE
CAN HEAR ME OKAY YEAH THEY ARE
PERFECT GO AHEAD AARON. GREAT
WELL GOOD MORNING AGAIN I'LL BE
PRESENTING YOU WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL FOR THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING PLAN AND
SPECIFICALLY TO K. TWELVE
SPENDING PROPOSAL. OUR BEGINNING
WTHOUT THE AFFECTED
MINISTRATION THOSE PROPOSED A
FIVE POINT 33% COLA JUST MEN ON
THE LP ABOUT BRINGING A TOTAL OF
THE EFFECT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND CHARTER. AND COMPARED TO
SPEAKING ABOUT THE- COMPLETE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE
COMPARED TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ENACTED LEVELS OF REVENUES ARE
INCREASED THIRTY SIX POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS ACROSS THAT
THREE YEAR PERIOD BUT TOTAL SELL
GENERAL FUND REVENUES ACROSS THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD THIRTY SIX
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS- WITH
TOUGH FOR OPERATIVE IN EACH YEAR
THEN. THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE
CALCULATION CALLS FROM NINETY TO
RECEIVE ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT CENTS
OF EVERY DOLLAR OF THIS INCREASE
IN REVENUE PLUS WHATEVER LOCAL
PROPERTY TAXES ARE ARE GENERATED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OF THE GUARANTEED
TOTAL IS NOW ESTIMATED TO BE AT
NINETY FIVE POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL A TWO AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
OVER THE ESTIMATE FOR THATYEAR
AT THE BUDGET ACT. IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE
IS UP FIVE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS ABOVE THE ENACTED LEVEL
FOR. A TOTAL OF NINETY NINE
POINT ONE BILLION THE INCREASE
IS IT NOT ME THE INCREASE IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. EIGHT
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS ABOVE
THE ENACT THE LEVEL FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR SO ABOVE THE NEXT
LEVEL FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
A TWO YEAR OVER YEAR INCREASE.
OF EIGHT POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AS WE WALK TWO TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE FOR A TOTAL
MINIMUM GUARANTEE CALCULATION IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. OF THE
ONE HUNDRED AND TWO. BILLION
DOLLARS- WITH THAT INVESTMENT OF
A HUNDRED TWENTY OR TWO HUNDRED
AND TWO BILLION DOLLARS OF THE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TOTAL
PROP NINETY EIGHT ESTIMATED PER
K. TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT OF HERPEOPLE FUNDING AMOUNT IS FIFTEEN
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE DOLLARS A HISTORIC AMOUNT AT
THAT I THINK ONE OF THE MEMBERS
MENTIONED A LOT OF HISTORIC
AMOUNTS- COMING AROUND THE LAST
COUPLE BUDGETS HERE-
ADDITIONALLY PURSUANT TO
PROPOSITION TWO- WHICH DOUBLES
THE PROBLEMS NINETY EIGHT
RESERVE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ESTIMATES THAT DEPOSITS WILL NOW
BE REQUIRED IN ALL THREE YEARS
WITHIN THE BUDGET WINDOW THREE
POINT ONE BILLION AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THREE POINT SIX
BILLION IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO- WHICH ARE INCREASES OF ONE
POINT TWO BILLION. AND NINE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION
RESPECTIVELY ABOVE THE ESTIMATED
DEPOSIT AMOUNTS AT THE. BUDGET
ACT WENT FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
A NEW DEPOSIT IS ALSO. IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE WORK ABOUT
THREE POINT ONE. BILLION DOLLARS
FOR A TOTAL RESERVE BALANCE OF
NINE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
ACROSS THAT THREE YEAR PERIOD-
AS I MENTIONED. IN THE BEGINNING
OF OUR PRESENTATION- WITH A
LARGE COLON LP ABOUT. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES
PRIORITIZE. THE LION'S SHARE OF
ONGOING FUNDING TOWARDS
EXISTING- PROGRAMS AND REALLY
SOLIDIFYING THOSE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT THAT WE NEED. TO CARRY
OUT THEIR THEIR CORE FUNCTIONS
AS WELL AS EXPAND- PRIORITIES
SUCH A PROGRAM SUCH AS THE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
PROGRAM WITH AN INCREASE OF
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
SEVEN O'CLOCK PROGRAM AN ONGOING
PROPAGATE FONG. BRING THE
PROGRAM'S TOTAL FUNDING NOW TO
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS-
OTHER INVESTMENTS FROM ONGOING
FUNDS FOCUSED ON. THINGS LIKE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
EXPANSION- INCREASING ACTIVE
JUNIPER SCHOOL MEALS- INCREASING
SPECIAL EDUCATION BASED FUNDING.
AS WELL AS INCREASING STATE
PRESCHOOL RIGHT- THE MAJOR. ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS ARE FOCUSED ON.
INFRASTRUCTURE BOTH IN
TRANSPORTATION AS WELL AS
KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT WE
WANT TO HAVE BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL. FOR GREETING SCHOOL
BUS FLEETS AND ADDRESSING- KIND
OF GENERAL TRANSPORTATION NEEDS
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE- AS WELL AS
IMPROVING OUR PROVIDING MORE.
CASH INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS
SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS PROPOSED IN
THE LAST BUDGET BUT WITH-
PROPOSAL OF. FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION- IN THIS BUDGET. THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET DOES PROPOSE. A
READ OF THE TEST ONE PUBLISHED
NINETY EIGHT PER. TO FOR THAT
INCREASE COSTS OF ADDITIONAL
STUDENT SERVED INTERNET
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE A PUBLIC FOR THE
MEDICATION FINISHING IN TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX. AND THAT'S
CURRENTLY ESTIMATED AT SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS NO IT WILL BE REVISED
THE ACTUAL TO BECOME AVAILABLE
SIMILAR TO THE REST ABOUT THE
ABOUT- ONE NOT CONSTANTLY
REQUIRED- THIS PROPOSAL TO BE
BENCH. IS CONSISTENT WITH PAST
PRACTICETO ADJUST THE PROBLEMS
NINETY CALCULATION TO ACCOUNT
FOR THE MOVEMENT AND FUNDING OF
PROGRAMS WITHIN OR OUTSIDE OF
THE CURRENCY RELATIVE TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN. LEVELS WITHOUT I'LL I'LL
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF AND I
KNOW THAT LEO HAS MUCH ASSURE AS
WELL BUT IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS LATER ON. IN THE
HEARING HAPPY TO ADDRESS UP.
OKAY THANK YOU LET'S NOT HERE
FOR MISTER COUPONS ALEJO. YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAN GET ON
WITH THE ANALYST OFFICE OUR
COMMENTS ARE SUMMARIZED IN THIS
RIGHT NOW SINCE WE PUBLISHED IN
HARD COPY AND ON OUR WEBSITE SO
I'LL JUST PROVIDE A FEW HIGHER
LEVEL COMMENTS- RELATE. ARE
REITERATING SOMETHING DEPARTMENT
OF. FINANCE SAID THE STORY THIS
YEAR ABOUT CHANGES IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE IT'S REALLY ABOUT- THE
IF YOU HAVE ANY ESTIMATES OF THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN GENERAL
FUND REVENUE COMPARED TO LAST
YEAR AND- ESTIMATE. IT'S DRIVEN
BY MANY FACTORS SURGING RETAIL
SALES RECORD HIGH CORPORATE
EARNINGS. GROWTH EMPLOYER
PAYROLLS AND THOSE ARE THE MAIN.
ECONOMIC DRIVER IS PUSHING UP
REVENUE AND THE ESTIMATES OF THE
GUARANTEED- THAT TURNING TO OUR
PAGE THREE OF OUR- ANALYSIS-
THAT I REVENUES AND HIGHER
GUARANTEED WE ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE INCREASES IN. DEPOSITS
IN THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RESERVE. THOSE ARE ALSO GOING TO
TRIGGER THE CAP ON SCHOOL
DISTRICT RESERVES TO MEDIUM AND
LARGE SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THAT CAP
LIMITS THE AMOUNT THAT DOES
DISTRICTS CAN HOLD FOR GENERAL
PURPOSES TO ABOUT 10% OF THEIR
BUDGETS. WE THINK THAT AT LEAST
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE DISTRICTS
WOULD BE EFFECTED IT UP BY THAT
. CAPEN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
OF THOSE DISTRICTS THAT HAVE THE
OPTION OF SPENDING DOWN THOSE
WITH SERVICE DESIGNATE AND
DESIGNATING THEM CONSPECIFIC
PURPOSES OR SEEKING AN EXEMPTION
FROM THEIR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. TRYING TO PITCH FOR
WE THINK THE REVENUE ESTIMATES
UNDERLYING TO GUARANTEE IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR GENERALLY
REASONABLE. OFFER TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- THE ESTIMATES THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS FOR GENERAL
FUND REVENUE ARE ABOUT OUR
LITTLE OVER NINE BILLION BELOW
ARE NOVEMBER ESTIMATES. THOUGH
THAT'S ESTIMATES THE BUDGET FOR
THAT YEAR STEPHEN PLAUSIBLE-
MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT LOWER I
DECENT CHANCE WITH THE HIGHER
ESTIMATES- BY MAY. I FOR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AS REVENUE ESTIMATES THAT
ARE NEARLY TEN MILLION BELOW ARE
NOVEMBER NOVEMBER OUTLOOK
ESTIMATES BUT MOST OF THAT
DIFFERENCE IS DUE TO SOME OF THE
TAX PROPOSALS THAT ARE IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. IF WE WERE TO
ADJUST THOSE AND SCORE THOSE- IN
OUR NOVEMBER OUTLOOK WE DON'T UP
WITH A VERY SIMILAR REVENUE
ESTIMATE. TO THE ONE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS. I TO THE X.
THAT RAP CHANGE. ARE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE WOULD INCREASE OR
DECREASE NEARLY FORTY CENTS FOR
EACH DOLLAR OF HIGHER LOWER
REVENUE. THAT'S DRIVEN BY A TEST
TEST ONE FORMULA IN THE STATE
CONSTITUTION THAT GUARANTEES
SCHOOLS AND COMMITTEE COLLEGES
RECEIVE ABOUT 40% OF GENERAL
FUND REVENUE. UP ANOTHER KEY
POINT HERE IS THAT WE KNOW THAT
A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY EXISTS
AROUND ATTENDANCE STUDENT
ATTENDANCE LEVELS BOTH IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. AS WELL AS WHAT
MIGHT LIE AHEAD IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW THAT EVEN IF ATTENDANCE
DECLINED SIGNIFICANTLY IN EITHER
OR BOTH OF THOSE HERE IS. THAT
WOULD NOT RESULT IN A DROP IN
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE YOU THOSE
CONSTITUTIONAL FORMULAS. ARE
STILL REQUIRED THE STATE TO
PROVIDE THE SAME 40% OF TOTAL
REVENUE THAT IT PROVIDES- UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S CURRENT. BUDGET
ESTIMATES. I SHIFTING TO PAGE
FIVE AND SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
SPENDING PROPOSALS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS NEARLY
EIGHTEEN BILLION IN NEW
SPENDING. BY NEARLY ELEVEN
BILLION OF THAT IS ONGOING AND
MORE THAN SEVEN BILLION IS ONE
TIME. WE THINK OF THOSE
PROPOSALS AS REALLY FALLING INTO
FOUR BUCKETS. THAT THERE'S FIVE
POINT THREE BILLION RELATED THE
PREVIOUS BUDGET COMMITMENTS THIS
IS FUNDING EXPANSIONS ARE
PROGRAM AUGMENTATIONS THAT WERE
AGREED UPON IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. OF THE PROJECT HAS FOUR
POINT ONE BILLION FOR COVERING
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS AND
THE TENANTS CHANGES. THAT
INCLUDES THAT CHANGE IN HOW THE
STATE ADDRESSES DECLINING
ATTENDANCE AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WILL COVER THAT IN YOUR- NEXT
PANEL. BUDGET HAS TWO POINT
BILLION FOR INFRASTRUCTURE THE
LARGEST COMPONENT OF THAT IS
RAMPS FOR SCHOOL BUSES THERE'S
ALSO SOME MODIFICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EQUIPMENT AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND
FINALLY THE WE HAVE ABOUT SIX
BILLION- IN OTHER PROPOSALS THAT
DON'T FALL INTO ONE OF THOSE
OTHER CATEGORIES. FIVE PAGE SIX
IS JUST THE LIST OF THE MAJOR
KICKOFF PROPOSALS IN THE BUDGET
ONE TIME AND I'M GOING. TO
PROVIDE THE SAME LIST FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ON PAGE
SEVEN. YOUR AGENDA COVERS ALL
THAT IN A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL
AND YOU'LL COVER THOSE SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS EITHER LATER IN THIS
HEARING. AND SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS
ARE ONCE IN A LOT OF TIME ON
THAT NOW. BY TURNING TO PAGE
EIGHT. THE STATE HAS REACHED
IMPORTANT. MILESTONE WHERE IT
COULD LIKELY WHETHER A MILD
RECESSION. I WITHOUT RESORTING
TO REDUCTIONS IN K. FOURTEEN
PROGRAMS ARE PAYMENT DEFERRALS.
THAT BUDGET RESILIENCE REFLECTS
THE NINE POINT SEVEN BILLION IN
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RESERVE NEARLY 10% OF THE
GUARANTEED. IT ALSO REFLECTS THE
BUDGET NOT COMMITTING ALL OF THE
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING TO ONGOING PROGRAMS
WHICH GIVES THE SALE OF A
QUESTION. I COULD GUESS
POTENTIAL DROPS IN THE GUARANTEE
IN THE FUTURE. AND TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF THE KIND OF. SCENARIO
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT. IF I
PATHETICALLY STATE REVENUES WERE
TO EXPERIENCE A YEAR OVER YEAR
DROP ABOUT TWENTY BILLION IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. THEN
REMAIN AT THAT LOWER LEVEL IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AND
THEN RECOVER AT TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX. OF THE STATE COULD
LIKELY FIND AT THE GUARANTEE AND
GET THROUGH THOSE TWO DOWN
YEARS. I WITHOUT RESORTING. TO
REDUCTIONS IN PROGRAMS. WE THINK
IT'S OF THE ON GOING. ARE
REASONABLE ESPECIALLY FOR K.
TWELVE A LOT OF THOSE PROPOSALS
RELATE TO THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. OR FUNDING PREVIOUS
COMMITMENTS. SOME OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OPPOSE THOSE
RAISE NEW ISSUES THAT YOU MIGHT
WANT TO THINK ABOUT. OF MY
COLLEAGUES WILL BE COVERING
THOSE AND SOME SUBSEQUENT
HEARING THIS. UNLIKE PREVIOUS
BUDGETS ARE THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT TO THE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE THIS YEAR- THE
STATE UNDER THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATES IS TWO POINT SIX
BILLION ABOVE ITS APPROPRIATION
LIMIT ACROSS TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
AS YOU KNOW IN THE STATE IS
ABOVE THELIMIT IT HAS THREE
BASIC OPTIONS FOR ADDRESSING
THOSE EXCESS REVENUES. IT CAN
USE THAT AMOUNT TO LOWER TAX
REVENUES. IT CAN INCREASE
SPENDING ON X. ON IT ON PURPOSES
THAT ARE EXEMPT FROM THE LIMIT
LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE OR STATE
EMERGENCY IS. OREGON'S BOOK CAME
UT BETWEEN ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
PAYMENTS TO SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND TAX
REBATES. AND WE BRING THIS UP
BECAUSE THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
AFFECTS THE KINDS OF TRADE OFFS
AND ADJUSTMENTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE THE BUDGET.
FOR EXAMPLE IF THE STATE TAKES
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS AND JUST THAT WOULD
NOT INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING SOME
NON EXEMPT PURPOSE- THAT
INCREASES THE AMOUNT OF THE
STATE'S OVER THE LIMIT. AND
REQUIRES MORE. OF THOSE OTHER
TYPES OF CHOICES. TURNING TO
PAGE NINE I BE UP TO OVER
RECOMMENDATIONS TO GUIDE SOME OF
THE UPCOMING BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS. THE FIRST TO BE
DEFINED IF YOU WERE NEW
INITIATIVES THAN WHAT THE BUDGET
PROPOSES. DISTRICTS FACE SOME
SIGNIFICANT CONSTRAINTS ON THEIR
CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS. THOSE INCLUDE STAFFING
DISRUPTIONS RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC AS WELL AS UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT FUTURE INVOLVEMENT AND
INTEREST IN DISTRICT PROGRAMS.
THAT DISTRICTS ARE ALSO WORKING
ON PLANS TO SPEND MORE THAN
TWENTY BILLION IN ONE TIME
FEDERAL FUNDS. AND IMPLEMENT
MANY OF THE NEW PROGRAMS THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WOULD ADD EVEN MORE PROGRAMS TO
THAT. MIX SO MUCH SO THAT WE
THINK DISTRICTS WOULD STRUGGLE
TO IMPLEMENT. ALL OF THOSE
PROPOSALS EFFECTIVELY. SOME
RELATED TO FACTORS WE'D
RECOMMEND USING UPCOMING
HEARINGS TO IDENTIFY AND
PRIORITIZE THE PROPOSALS. THAT
ADDRESSED MOST REALLY DEFINED
PROBLEMS. AND THAT ENTAILS
ASKING THE ADMINISTRATION BOTH
TO EXPLAIN THE UNDERLYING ISSUE.
AND TO EXPLAIN WHY ADDITIONAL.
FUNDING IS THE BEST BECAUSE
THAT'S THE ISSUE. AND WHETHER IT
WOULD FRAGMENTS- OR DISRUPT
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THAT STATE IS ALREADY. FUNDING
FOR EXAMPLE FOR THE WORK FIRST
PROPOSALS WE SUGGEST. NOT
CREATING ANY NEW PROGRAMS IN
THAT AREA UNTIL YOU HAVE A
GREATER UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE
CONCERNS WITH THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS. CONCLUDES OUR LITTLE
COME HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY BY.
OKAY THANK YOU WERE GOING TO
HOLD OFF UNTIL WE HEAR ALL THREE
PANELISTS NEXT WE HAVE A VERY
NICELY WHO IS STEPPING IN TODAY
IN HER NEW POSITION. AS CHIEF.
SOMETHING OR OTHER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. MARY
GRADUATION WELCOME. A GOOD
MORNING A TEAR MCCARTY RHODE
ISLAND COMMITTEE THANKS FOR
HAVING ME HERE- I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION THURMAN I
AM THE CHIEF CHIEF DEPUTY OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. HAS THE S. P. I.
SHARED IN HIS OVERVIEW WE ARE
THANKFUL THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS KEEPING EDUCATION AS A KEY
PRIORITY IN THE BUDGET DEAL F.
IN THE L. A. O. OF ALREADY
COVERED PROP NINETY EIGHT
THOROUGHLY SO WE'LL JUST NOTE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THE ESTIMATED GUARANTEE
RAINY DAY FUND OR REINVENTION
PROPOSALS. REGARDING FEDERAL
FUNDING ELEAZAR RECEIVED
MULTIPLE ROUNDS OF STIMULUS
FUNDING STARTING WITH THE CARES
ACTED MARCH TWENTY TWENTY WHICH
WAS THEN FOLLOWED BY CHRIS SAID
IN DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY AND
HARPER IN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE BULK OF THE FUNDING HAS
GONE OUT UNDER THE ELEMENTARY
AND SECONDARY SCHOOL EMERGENCY
RELIEF FUND OR S. OR FUND.
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS 90% OF THE
FUNDING FROM EACH ROUND OF ESR
IS REQUIRED TO GO DIRECTLY TO
THE L. A.'S BASED ON THEIR SHARE
OF TITLE ONE. THE REMAINING 10%
OF EACH ROUND OF ESSAR HAS
GENERALLY BEEN BUNDLED WITH
OTHER FEDERAL FUNDS MAINLY THE
GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY EDUCATION
RELIEF HERE FUNDS AND
CORONAVIRUS REALLY FUNDS THIS
YEAR EFFORTS. AS WELL AS STATE
GENERAL FUND INTO VARIOUS RELIEF
PACKAGES. THESE PACKAGES INCLUDE
THE LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION
FUND FROM TWENTY TWENTY AND AB
EIGHTY SIX FROM EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. TOTAL FUNDING ACROSS
ALL SOURCES IS JUST OVER THIRTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS. THE
LATEST REPORTING COVERS TWENTY
SIX POINT FIVE BILLION IN
FUNDING FROM THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC TO THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. MORNING SHOWS AS THE
ELLIE GAYS HAVE SPENT NINETY
NINE POINT 8% OF THE NEARLY FIVE
BILLION FUNDS. THAT EXPIRED LAST
MAY AND JUNE. IN 91% OF THE
NEARLY TWO BILLION THAT EXPIRES
NEXT IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. JUST A FEW DAYS LESS THAN
A YEAR FROM NOW. ELEAZAR EVEN
SPENT 41% OR TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION OF ESTHER TO FUNDING
WHICH DOES NOT EXPIRE UNTIL
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
DATA SHOWS THAT THE LARGEST USE
OF FUNDS ACROSS ALL FUNDS HAS
BEEN PURCHASING TECHNOLOGY
TOTALING TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. CD IS WORKING ON
STANDING UP REPORTING FOR THE
REMAINING FEDERAL FUNDS AND WILL
HAVE THOSE ONLINE IN SPRING OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE ARE ALSO
STANDING UP THE ANNUAL REPORTING
FOR ALL FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL AS
OTHER FEDERALLY REQUIRED REPORTS
I HAVE WITH ME JUST OF SIGNS AND
DENVER WENT. FROM THE TEAM THAT
OVERSEES FEDERAL STIMULUS
FUNDING TO ASSIST IN ANSWERING
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU. SO DO WE WANT TO HAVE YOUR
THE OTHER PERSON SPEAKER JUST TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS FOR US. OKAY
SORRY THEY'RE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK YOU. OKAY
ALL OF A FEW BUT ALL BUT OTHER
KEEP COMMITTEE MEMBERS GO FIRST
TODAY LIKE. OKAY THIS VIRUS
PRETTY. M. SO THE ONLY- INDICATE
THAT APPROXIMATELY 76% OF THE
MEDIUM AND LARGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE CURRENTLY HAVE
RESERVES EXCEEDING THE 10% CAP
THAT WULD BE TRIGGERED ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE YEAR SCHOOL YEAR
BASED ON THE PROJECTED RESERVES
OF THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT FOR TODAY
ONLY SO WOULD IT BE HELPFUL TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO TEMPORARILY
SUSPEND THAT RESERVE CAP
PROVIDING ADJUSTMENT FOR
ADJUSTMENT PERIOD FOR MANY ALLEY
A STRUGGLING ON HOW TO
TRANSITION FROM ONE TIME STATE
AND FEDERAL FUNDS. I THINK YOU
SO WE'VE ASKED DISTRICTS AND OF
THEIR THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW THEY
PLAN TO ADDRESS- THERE IS THERE
CALIFORNIA STANDING IS THAT MANY
OF THEM. MANY OF THEM INTEND TO
GOVERNING BOARD ACTION TO SET
THOSE RESERVE THE SITE FOR
SPECIFIC PURPOSES. I THINK- I
THINK IT IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
CHALLENGE FOR THEM BECAUSE- THE
STATE HAS IN. THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS I THINK TRIED TO ENCOURAGE
LARGER RESERVES AT 10% RESERVE
FOR JUST GENERAL PURPOSES ISN'T
ALL THAT MUCH TO GET THROUGH-
SOME KIND OF ECONOMICS. COMING
DOWN TURN. US WITHOUT A VERY
LARGE QUESTION GIVEN THE AMOUNT
OF UNCERTAINTY THAT. DISTRICTS
MIGHT FACE- STORE EXPECTATIONS
ISN'T TAT DISTRICTS ARE GOING
TO SPEND DOWN QUITE A BIT OF THE
RESERVES BUT THIS IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT ADDS A LITTLE
BIT. MORE COMPLEXITY- A LOT MORE
PRESSURE ON THEM KIND OF AS PART
OF. THIS PART OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS SO- OF POTENTIALLY COULD
BE HELPFUL FOR THEM ALTHOUGH
THEY'RE FACING. THIS IS JUST ONE
OF MANY AND HAVE UNIQUE- BUDGET
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE FACING
NEXT YEAR. SO CAN YOU TELL US
HOW PROPOSITION TO DIRECT THE
STATE TO SPEND OR SAVE. FUTURE
FORMULA DRIVEN DEPOSIT AMOUNTS
THAT EXCEED THE 10% YES SO ONCE
THE PROPOSITION TO RESERVE THE
STATE RESERVE WE JUST 10% OF THE
GUARANTEED ADDITIONAL DEPOSITS
ON A LONGER REQUIRED. WHEN IT'S
TIME TO TAKE THOSE DEPOSITS OUT
OF THE RESERVE ALLOCATE THEM TO
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE SOMETIMES THE CONSTITUTION
REQUIRES THE THRALLS THE
LEGISLATURE CAN ALSO DO IT ON A
DISCRETIONARY BASIS. BUT THERE
WAS NO SPECIFIC FORMULA IN THERE
THAT EXPLAINS HOW THAT'S GOING
TO BE ALLOCATED TO INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICTS. ONE OF B. AS THE
HESITATION MAY BE CONCERNED THAT
HER CONTEST FIX OF THAT IT'S
HARD TO INCLUDE THE STATE
RESERVE AND I LOCAL PLANNING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
HOW THE STATE'S GOING TO USE
THAT ONE WE ACTUALLY DO GET INTO
A DOWNTURN THAT COULD BE WE
ALLOCATED BASED ON A PER PUPIL
BASIS HAS. TO BE THE STATE DOES
SOMETHING DIFFERENT SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES I THINK
DISTRICTS WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
STATE HAS A RESERVE FOR SCHOOLS
BUT IT'S HARD TO- COALESCED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE THEY
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW THAT'S
GOING TO BE YOU THE. NEXT TIME
THE STATE ENTERS A DOWNTURN.
OKAY SO THE STATE CAN SEE. THIS
CAN SAVE OR- THE FUNDS. ARE THE
RESERVE IS QUITE CLEAR THAT THE
FUNDS HAVE TO BE USED TO
SUPPLEMENT THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE USE OF
THE STATE COULDN'T USE THAT TO.
LEAVE IT FOR SOME OTHER NON
SCHOOL NOT EDUCATION PROGRAM
ELSEWHERE IN THE BUDGET- IT'S
DIFFERENT THAN SAY THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT FOR SOME
OF THE OTHER RESERVES TO MEET
CREATED FOR JOURNALISTIC. I
THOUGHT WELP WITH THE
SUPPLEMENTS WILL THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE IN SOME
FORM. THAT WILL BE DETERMINED BY
THE LEGISLATURE THE TAXI CABINS
. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF DONALD. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
OF MANY- WITHOUT A JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS HERE- EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
OPPORTUNITIES GRANT AND THE
GOVERNOR C. N. AS BUDGET
IDENTIFIES IT IS EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
AS ELABORATE I ASSUME THOSE ARE
THE SAME THING OKAY WHAT EXACTLY
IS THAT PROGRAM. FOR THE
GOVERNOR THIS YEAR WAS TO
INCREASE THE ONGOING FUNDING BY
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS. EVEN MORE THAN THE
CALL HE APPLIES TO THE BASE
ALLOCATIONS OF THIS IS A HUGE
PROGRAM THIS IS REALLY BECOMING
A BIG PROGRAM CAN YOU. CAN
SOMEONE IDENTIFY WHAT IS THIS
PROGRAM WHAT IS THIS. THE
FINANCER WHOEVER. SURE HAPPY TO
SPEAK WITH A AND AREA AGAIN FOR
ME TO FIND OUT- I COULDN'T TAKE
FIRST OUT THAT THE DANCER THERE
FOR YOU AND IF SOME KAMALA LIKE
START WITH LIKE NOT BEEN ON THAT
THAT'S FINE WITH ME- SO TO GIVE
YOU A BRIEF BACKGROUND SO THAT
PROGRAM WAS ENACTED AT THAT THE
MOST RECENT BUDGET- WITH A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR IN ONGOING
PROPAGATE INVESTMENT AND ALSO
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION. AND A ONE TIME PROBABLY
NINETY THAT REVIEWS AND- THE
PURPOSE OF THE PROGRAM IS TO
PROVIDE FOR- LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES OUTSIDE OF THE
INSTRUCTIONAL DAY OUTSIDE OF
WHAT WOULD CONSTITUTE-
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME FOR EXAMPLE
THAT COUNTS TOWARD. A COMPUTING
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE REALLY
OTHER ENRICHMENT PROGRAMS
WHETHER THEY BE BEFORE SCHOOL
AFTER SCHOOL- DURING SUMMER
SCHOOL TIME- SO THAT'S ALL LAID
OUT IN STATUTE WHEN THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AND HOW THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE PROVIDED BY THAT
IN CONCERT WITH. OTHER NON FEEL
COMMUNITY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS OR WHETHER THAT-
IT'S STAFF AND- FOLKS AT THE
EARLY AGE ARE ARE BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE THEMSELVES TO
OFFER THOSE PROGRAMS SO THEIR
STUDENTS GRADE- THAT THE
NATIONAL YOU COVERED IT IT YOU
COVERED THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO JUST JUST SOME
FOLLOW UP TO THAT. HOW IS THAT.
THAT'S OUTSIDE THE SCHOOL DAY.
SO HOW IS IN A FEW. USE OF
NINETY EIGHT MONEY. BECAUSE WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE CREE A MEGA
PROGRAM THREE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING RIGHT. I'M
SAYING THAT THAT THAT'S HIGHER
THAN THE COLA. THAT'S A BLIGHTED
BASE WHICH IS CRAZY TO ME RIGHT.
WE'RE DRIVING MONEY AWAY FROM
THE CLASSROOM NOW. SO IS THIS. I
MEAN IT HAS THERE BEEN SOME
LEGAL TEST OF THE TERM THIS IS
AN APPROPRIATE USE OF NINETY
EIGHT MONEY TO USE IT OUTSIDE
THE SCHOOL DAY. I MEAN PROP
FORTY NINE YEARS AGO GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION WE'VE ADDED TO THAT.
BECAUSE WE THOUGHT WELL. AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ARE GOOD THING
BUT THAT THIS. THIS IS SOMETHING
WELL IN ADDITION TO THAT. WHAT
IT I THINK THERE ARE SEVERAL
EXAMPLES OF FUNDING AND- WITHIN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT THAT
PASSED THAT TEST BUT PAUL YOU
KNOW OUTSIDE ABOUT THE ABOUT FOR
EXAMPLE OUTSIDE OF THE- MAIN
INSTRUCTIONAL DAY I WOULD NOTE.
AS WELL THAT- WITHIN ACT OF THIS
PROGRAM IN IN- IN JAIL. IT WAS
THE INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
THAT ENACTMENT THAT FUNDING FOR
THIS PROGRAM WOULD REACH A FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS- AND A RATE FOR
FOLKS OF TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. PER STUDENT THAT SIR
PER ADA- IN THAT PROGRAM AND
THAT THAT WAS THE INTENT OF THE
PROGRAM THAT WAS THE GREEN ALL
ALONG BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO- INCREASE
FUNDING OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS. TO THAT POINT SO THAT WE
EVEN REALLY HAVE SUPPORT IN THE
FUNDING THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD IT OUT AS- IT WAS
ENVISIONED BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE- SO IT'S PART OF
THAT AGREEMENT AND THEN. OUR
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR- GIVEN THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
BE ABLE TO FULLY COME OUT GIVE A
CALL- ANTICLINE IN ROMAN
PROPOSAL. WE FELT IT APPROPRIATE
TO BUILD OUT THIS PROGRAM-
PERHAPS A BIT FASTER MAYBE
FINISH THE ENVISIONED BUT
DEFINITELY STILL IN LINE WITH
WHAT WE UNDERSTOOD TO BE THE
AGREEMENT- MOVING FORWARD ABOUT
THIS PROGRAM. GREAT THANK YOU
AND I AGAIN I JUST QUESTION WE
DON'T NEED TO GOING TO NOW BUT I
JUST QUESTION WHETHER THAT WOULD
PASS LEGAL TASK. BECAUSE IT'S
MONEY THAT I WOULD ARGUE IS
BEING DRIVEN AWAY. FROM THE
CLASSROOM FOR DAYTIME
INSTRUCTION. AND OTHER THOSE ARE
GOOD PROGRAMS BUT ARGUABLY. THEY
COULD BE FINED WITH GENERAL FUND
MONEY AS WELL- AND YOU LOOK AT
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S WHAT. A 5% PLUS INCREASE.
TO THE BASE ALLOCATION ON TOP OF
A GOVERNOR'S ALREADY PROPOSED
FIVE POINT THREE THREE. WE COULD
REALLY HAD TOWARDS. MEETING THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE- OF STUDENT-
PEOPLE FUN. SO I ADDED TO AGAIN
A QUESTION- WITH REGARD TO
PERSON STIRS THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL. EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS PROPOSED IN THIS
YEAR'S GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS THAT
ACCURATE ON THE ON THE EMPLOYER
SIDE. THAT IS CORRECT. IT IS ONE
OF NOTE FOR MEMBERS LIKE ME THAT
PUTS A SIGNIFICANT BURDEN ON
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IT MEANS THEY
HAVE TO COME UP WITH MORE MONEY.
TO PAY THE PENSION BURDEN ON TOP
OF WHAT THEY ARE ALREADY. UP
HANG- WITH THAT- IT WITH GUARD
TO THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT- SO CAN
WALK ME THROUGH THAT SO. BURIED
IN THAT PROPOSITION WAS A
REQUIREMENT THAT ACTUALLY.
REQUIRED SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
DURING SOME YEARS TO HAVE A CAP
OF TEN PERCENT. OF RESERVES THAT
ACCURATE. SIR THAT THAT'S
ACCURATE THOUGH THE STATUTE
STATES THAT WHEN THE RESERVE
BALANCE IN THE PRIOR YEAR IS
ABOUT 3% OF THE K. TWELVE SHARE
OF THE GUARANTEED THAT IN THE
YEAR SUBSEQUENT TO THAT BALANCE
MEETING THAT THRESHOLD- THE
RESERVE CAPS THAT YOU MENTIONED
ARE ARE IN FACT. OKAY I VOTED
FOR THAT THING I WOULD I DO THAT
I DON'T LIKE THAT PART OF- OF
THAT PROPOSITION PROPOSITION TWO
IS TWENTY FOURTEEN BUT EITHER
WAY IT WAS SO COULD THE
LEGISLATURE- THROUGH STATUTE
ALTER THAT OR WE WOULD REQUIRE
GOING BACK TO THE PEOPLE. DO YOU
KNOW SO AS FAR AS THE AS FAR AS
THE DISTRICT RESERVE CAPS ARE
CONCERNED- THAT ALREADY HAS BEEN
AMENDED THE STATUTE ONE BUT
BELIEVE IT WAS. SB SEVEN FIFTY
ONE AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN RAM
THAT DID AMEND THAT THOSE ARE
THE REQUIREMENTS BESIDES OF THE
RESEARCH THAT WAS ALLOWABLE- IT
EXCLUDED- I BELIEVE BATES GAVE
DISTRICT AND SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE MOST ABOUT OF
PROVISIONS AROUND- JUST RESERVE
CAPS ARE IN STATUTES. OUR
INSPECTION OKAY THANK YOU- A PRE
THE RE BENCHING. TO- TO- TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASED
EXPENDITURES TEEKAY WHICH MR
MCCARTY HAS SO. THIS PUSH
FOREIGN FINALLY BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN GETTING US TO SOME
CONGRATULATIONS MR KULKARNI
UNDER WORK THERE AND AGAIN THE
RE BENCHING IS A BIG DEAL
BECAUSE IT JUST DOESN'T ADD
STUDENTS TO THE BUCKET BUCKET
BUT ACTUALLY MAKES THE BUCKET
BIGGER. THE BUCKET OF DOLLARS
BIGGER- AND THEN ANOTHER THING
JUST- FOR THE L. A. O. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT- THE
ONLY- COMMENT. WHETHER TO FUND
FEWER OF ONE TIME PROPOSALS-
BECAUSE AGAIN THE MORE PROGRAMS
WE THROW SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW- THE
LESS THEY CAN DO QUITE FRANKLY
ARE THERE GOING TO BENEW
PROGRAMS I'M SURE THEY WILL. DO
SOME NAY BE NEED TO BE
FORTIFIED. OF COURSE BUT AGAIN
WE NEED TO BE VERY PRUDENT- NOT
TO OVER BURDEN. OUR SCHOOLS WITH
MANDATES AND NEW PROGRAMS. AND
THEN JUST GOING BACK TO THE
COMPLEX THEORETICAL CALCULATIONS
THE U. A. O. APPARENTLY. THE WAY
THAT STATUTE IS WRITTEN OR
IMPLEMENTED IT. IT BENEFITS THE
THAT IT HAS TO DO WITH THE-
CASTERS THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
IT APPEARS YOU- AS AS WE HEAD
DOWN THE TIMELINE- IT BENEFITS
THE STATE MORE THAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN OTHER WORDS STATES
TO HAVE HAVE A LESSEN BURDEN.
WITH REGARD TO THE PENSION THE
CARD THE PENSION COSTS OF THE
BIRD OF PENSIONS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACTUALLY. HAVE AN
INCREASED BURDEN IS THAT
ACCURATE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL I CAN TAKE AND
I SHOT IT ANSWERING THAT- THE-
STATE- AS YOU KNOW WHEN IT
CREATED THE CHARACTERS FUNDING
PLAN. ASSIGN SOME OF THE
LIABILITY TO SCHOOLS EMPLOYERS
AND SOME TO THE STATE. AND WHAT
MAKES THE ASSIGNMENT IN
CALCULATION OF LIABILITY SO
COMPLICATED AS IT'S NOT BASED ON
THE ACTUAL ASSETS AND
LIABILITIES OF THE PLAN AS IT
EXISTS TODAY BUT WHAT. THE PLAN
WOULD HAVE LOOKED LIKE IF THE
STATE HAD MADE DIFFERENT
DECISIONS IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES AND EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS ABOUT BENEFITS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS- ONE OF THE- I
THINK PERHAPS UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT APPROACH IS
THAT. NEARLY ALL OF THE
VOLATILITY AND INVESTMENT
RETURNS IS ASSIGNED TO THE STATE
AND SO WHEN INVESTMENTS DO
REALLY REALLY WELL LIKE THEY GET
OVER THIS PAST YEAR- THE STATE
RECEIVED NEARLY ALL OF THE
BENEFIT FROM THAT- WHEN THEY DO
VERY POORLY THE STATE'S ON THE
HOOK- FOR MOST OF THE INCREASED
COSTS. AND SO THERE IS NOT- AND
ABOUT A SHARING OF- OF THE GAMES
AND- ASSURING OF THE UPS AND
DOWNS IN THE SYSTEMS INVESTMENT
AND FUTURE INVESTMENTS THE WAY
THAT YOU MIGHT EXPECT- THE WAY
THE- CITY CALPERS IS STRUCTURED
FOR IT THE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
IS MUCH DIFFERENT THAN THE WAY
THE CASTERS LIABILITY IS. IS SET
UP. HOW WE THINK A MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD TO SPLIT UP THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY WOULD MAKE
THE PLAN EASIER TO MONITOR IN
YOUR TO UNDERSTAND. AND WHAT A
LIMIT SOME OF THESE ON IT
UNINTUITIVE AND MAY BE
UNINTENDED OUTCOMES WHERE THERE
IS A- FOR APPLE A BIG REALLY BIG
GAME INVESTMENT RETURNS. AND
THAT DOESN'T REALLY RESULT IN
SCHOOL. CONTRIBUTION RATES GOING
DOWN AT ALL. SO BY. WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS WHEN THE- WHEN THE
FUND IS HOW. TO S. AND THE
BURDEN ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
RIGHT WHEN THE FUND DOES VERY
WELL IN THAT THE INVESTMENT
RETURNS THE COASTERS THIS PAST
YEAR BUT WAS UNPRECEDENTED AND
IT WASN'T REALLY ONLY SEVEN
POINT TWO. EXACT RIGHT IT WAS
RIGHT SOMETHING THAT NONE OF THE
SORT OF CENTER TO THE FAIRLY
CONSUMMATED THIS SYSTEM EVER
ACHIEVING SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
WE WOULD EXPECT AND WHAT CAN
WITH CALPERS THAT RETURN ALLOWED
THE STATE TO REDUCE SOME OF THE
PRESSURE ON SCHOOL EMPLOYER
RATES NEXT COUPLE YARS- WITH
CAL STAR IS IT'S JUST THE
OPPOSITE IN FACT. IT'S QUITE
POSSIBLE THAT DISTRICT RATES
WILL END UP BEING A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER. TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
THEN THE SYSTEM WAS PROJECTING
PREVIOUSLY. SO IF WE COULD MAYBE
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE COMMITTEE
AND MYSELF- THERE THERE'S A
THERE'S A RAMP. AND THE BURDEN
ON A DISTRICT INCREASES EVERY
COUPLE YEARS OR SO THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN WITH REGARD TO. TO CAL
STIRS. AND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
THAT EVEN THOUGH THE FUND HAS
DONE EXTREMELY WELL PARTICULARLY
LAST YEAR- THAT RAMP DOESN'T
EVER NOTHING READ AND NEVER
THERE'S NEVER. IT DOESN'T GO
NEVER GOES DOWN RIGHT NO YOU'RE
YOU'RE CAUGHT THE COST PER NEW
DISTRICT ALWAYS GOES UP. AT THE
RATE CAN GO DOWN- FOR EXAMPLE
CAN GO DOWN AS- PAYROLL GROWS
FASTER THAN THE STATE ASSUMES
BECAUSE- IT MEANS THAT. THOSE
CONTRIBUTION RATES GENERATE MORE
MONEY FOR THE SYSTEM BUT IT
DOESN'T GO DOWN BASED ON B. JUST
HAVING A VERY STRONG INVESTMENT
HERE WHICH IS THE HONEST WITH
OF. PART OF THIS UNIQUE OKAY I
GET IT THE RATE OF RETURN
DOESN'T NECESSARILY IMPACT THE
BURDEN TO A DISTRICT. RIGHT OR
CANADA OR IT CAN IMPACT IT IN
KIND OF THE OPPOSITE WAY THAT
YOU WOULD EXPECT IT TO BE
EXPECTED TO DO. OKAY UNDERSTOOD-
WITH THAT THANK YOU. OKAY
MEMBERS. OKAY I WANT TO FOLLOW
UP ON TO THE ISSUES THAT MISTER
O'DONNELL- TOUCHED ON IN THERE
IN THE AGENDA AS WELL- THE FIRST
IS AS FAR AS- THE BASING CREASES
TO THE LCF FORMULAR FORMULA-
BEYOND THE COLA- AND- RISING
PENSION COSTS AND HEALTHCARE
COSTS INFLATION DO WE FEEL THOSE
ARE IN MY OWN WORDS ROUGHLY
ADEQUATE TO ADDRESS WHAT IS
NEEDED I KNOW THE CALL WAY IS-
SIGNIFICAN AND BEN LARGER THAN
HISTORICAL US BUT DO WE FEEL
THAT THAT IS ADEQUATE TO COVER
ALL THE INCREASES IN THE FIXED
COSTS. AREA PUBLIC FINANCE AGAIN
I'LL ANSWER THAT QUESTION SO FOR
THE MINISTRATIONS PERSPECTIVE
WEEK WE CERTAINLY- RECOGNIZE AND
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFICULTIES THAT
WE ARE FACING- I THINK EVEN
WITHOUT THE PANDEMIC THERE WAS
AN UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY DO
FACE- YOU KNOW RIGHT THINK THAT
CALL THEM- ALL KINDS OF OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
SERVING OUR- OUR CHILDREN OUR
STUDENTS IN THE STATE. I'M
CERTAIN WITH PANDEMIC OF THE
BAND- EXACERBATED. MADE MORE
DIFFICULT SEVERAL- I THINK I
WOULD TO- BOTH THANK YOU LARGE
KOLAR THAN HISTORIC BUT- ALSO.
ARE PROPOSAL FOR DECLINING
ENROLLMENT WHICH I WON'T REALLY
TELL HERE UNLESS YOU LIKE ME TO
COME I KNOW WE'RE COMING ON
COMING IN ON THE NEXT PANEL BUT-
THAT WAS REALLY DEVELOPED-
REALLY A LOT. AS A RESULT A LOT
OF- CONVERSATIONS WITH PARTNERS-
LIKE MY CLIENT AND HIS HIS STAFF
WITH THICK MAT. REALLY TRYING TO
GET A REPORT ON WHAT DISTRICTS
NEED. IN THIS TIME- FINANCIALLY
YOU KNOW THE STATE THAT THEY'RE
IN- OUR STUDENTS HAVE BEEN AND
AS YOU'LL HEAR FROM I DON'T
RECALL IT. MIGHT TAKE MATTER
PRESENTED TODAY OR IN THE FUTURE
HEARING BUT- YOU KNOW YOU'LL
HEAR FROM HIM AS- OFTEN RECENT
YEARS. IT SAID THAT- FOR THE
MOST PART MANY DISTRICTS ARE ARE
NOT ENOUGH A TOUGH PLACE- ON ON
A CASH BASIS- SO MUCH OF MAYBE
PERHAPS THERE SINCE MANAGEMENT
IN IN A SMALL. OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ATTORNEY ONE OF THE
BUS CARE. WITHOUT MIGHT MY
INTENT WITH THAT COMMENT BUT-
THAT FOR THE MOST PART- THE
REVENUE IS THERE- IT'S JUST
HELPING THEM IN IN THIS CASE THE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT PROPOSAL-
CHART A PATH BUT THE BIT MORE
SMOOTH- WITHOUT. YOU KNOW THOSE
THOSE YEAR TO YEAR- BOMB SWORD
OR SIGNIFICANT DECREASES I
SHOULD SAY. IN THINGS LIKE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE- AND
REALLY HELPING THEM ADJUST TO
THAT- AND ADJUST TO THE LONGER
TERM- ENROLLMENT THE KIND THAT-IS. CONTINUING AND EXPECT TO
CONTINUE EVEN WITH THE INFLUX OF
PK EXPANSION- WE ARE EXPECTING A
BIRTH RATE TO CONTINUE TO BE I'M
REALLY START. LOW AND THAT'S
GOING TO OF COURSE HAVE A
NATURAL IMPACT ON THE P. TWELVE
POPULATION THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
BE SERVED- AND SO FOR US WE FEEL
LIKE IN LIGHT OF ALL OF THOSE-
CONSIDERATIONS AND PARTIES ARE.
ARE OUT PROPOSAL DO YOU REALLY
HELP PREPARE ELEAZAR IN THE BEST
WAY. POSSIBLE ALSO ALSO
PRIORITIZING FUNDS FOR A HOST OF
OTHER PARTIES AND PROGRAMS- WITH
THAT PROPOSITION NINETY AS WELL.
OKAY THANK YOU. OUR TO. TURN OUT
- THE UNIVERSAL T. K. RI BATCHES
MISTER O'DONNELL NOTED- THAT WAS
CERTAINLY PART OF THE AGREEMENT
LAST YEAR- MAKE SURE THAT WE-
EXPAND EARLY EDUCATION PROVIDED
UNIVERSAL THAT REALIZE THAT WE
DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE A WHACK OUT
OF EXISTING PROP NINETY EIGHT
FUND FUNDING SO I THINK IT WAS A
WIN WIN- WITH THIS RE BENCH SO
JUST WANT TO HAVE A TECHNICAL
QUESTION ON THE ON THE RE BENCH-
SO WE'RE ADDING A NEW GREAT OF
COURSE TO OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM- WHAT TYPE OF FLEXIBILITY
SO WE HAVE AS FAR AS- RICKY
RESPONDING TO ACTUAL ADA. TWENTY
K. OR HAVING IT BE A
PREDICTABLE- AMOUNT SO WE CAN
FOCUS ON THE EARLY
IMPLEMENTATION. SURE SO- THE WAY
THAT THE REVENGE WILL WORK.
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THE LTO
BAPTISTS CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED SO THERE'S A BASE
GRANT RATE RIGHT ALTHEA BAPHOMET
AN LED WOULD RECEIVE A WHATEVER
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION GRANT
FUNDING ON TOP OF THAT THAT
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO- AND ALL OF
ME THE WAY THAT THE REBATE COULD
BE CALCULATED AS ONCE WE HAVE
ACTUALS- WE WOULD ADJUST AS
NEEDED FOR WHATEVER THAT
INCREASED CALL. IS ELEAZAR WON'T
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE EITHER WAY
IN TERMS OF IMPACTING OUR
FUNDING IF THEY'RE SERVING MORE
KIDS AND HE K. IF THEY'RE YOU
KNOW THEY'RE GONNA GET FUNDED ON
THEIR ETA RIGHT AS THEY WOULDN'T
IN IN ANY OTHER YEAR OR EVEN IF
WE DIDN'T DO TO. EXPANSION THAT
LIFTING EXPENSE WILL JUST KIND
OF BE ROLLED IN WITH HOW WE
TREAT- ON KIND OF AN ACCOUNTING
RECONCILIATION BAKER THE REST OF
THE ALTHEA SO ONCE PROP NINETY
EIGHT IS- PRIOR YEAR FOR EXAMPLE
THE ONE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
IN THE REAR VIEW MIRROR AND
WE'RE WORKING ON THE- THE WHAT
WOULD THEN BE THE TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX BUDGET. ARGUES ME THE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE BUDGET
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE WILL BE
A NUMBER ARE YOUR THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TO CERTIFY PERCENT
STATUTE AND IT'S AT THAT POINT
THAT WOULD MAKE THE FINALS SAY
BASED ON ACTUAL DATA THAT WE
WOULD HAVE AVAILABLE BY THAT
POINT. TO SAY WHAT WAS THE TRUE
COST- ASSOCIATED WITH WITH FIFTY
K. EXPANSION IN OUR FIRST YEAR
AND THEN WE WOULD BE BUNCHED
THAT GUARANTEE- BY THAT AMOUNT
AND THAT PERCENTAGE INCREASE
WHAT WOULD CARRY OUT MOVING
FORWARD- BUT AGAIN IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION FOR ELLIE AS
PREDICTABILITY THERE- BETTER. WE
HAVE AN IMPACT FOR THEM BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY JUST MORE OF US- HOW
DO YOU THINK ON THE AGGREGATE AT
THE STATE WHAT WERE YOU KNOW
THAT THE NEW COSTS WORKS BOTH IN
THE STATE TO OR THE NEW COSTS
THAT THAT THE GUARANTEE IS
INCREASING BY. ABOUT IT SHOULD
HAVE BUT LIKE I SAID I READ
READY GOT IT SHOULD HAVE
PRACTICAL IMPACT RALLY I THINK
THEY CAN MOVE FORWARD KNOWING
THAT THAT THAT EIGHTY EIGHT- IS
FUNDED- WITHIN THE GUARANTEED
AMOUNT YOU OUT. THANK YOU CAN I
ASK YOU. THE LAST MISTER COUPON
WITH THE L. A. FOR YOUR THOUGHTS
. ON HOW SHOULD COUNT. THIS
THERE WERE. A PROPER EIGHT.
REGARD TO K. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SO THAT. JUSTIN
BRING THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND WAS THE MOST- THE ESTIMATED
IN IN EIGHT FIVE THE ARBOR. LCSO
RATE FOR A- TICKET TO STUDENTS.
THAT'S LIKE A BASICALLY MY- TO
US WE DO HAVE A LOT IT IS A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTY RIGHT NOW ABOUT.
HOW MANY STUDENTS WILL
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
ESPECIALLY IN THE FIRST COUPLE
YEARS- G. K. IN CANADA THAT WAS
THE GRADE LEVEL THAT'S BEEN MOST
HEAVILY IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC
SO WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY. WHEN
AND BY HOW MUCH THAT'S GOING TO
REBOUND IN COMING YEARS. AND WE
THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO HAVE A
METHODOLOGY THAT'S FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH TO ACCOUNT FOR- THE
ACTUAL NUMBER OF. ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS WHO ARE ATTENDING
DISTRICTS BECAUSE OF THE
EXPANSION. I ONE ISSUE STILL NOT
THAT BUT I THINK WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT ONE IS HOW THE STATE'S
GOING TO COLLECT INFORMATION
FROM DISTRICTS ABOUT. HOW MUCH
ADDITIONAL TICKET TENANTS THERE
GENERATING RIGHT NOW THE STATE
DOES NOT. COLLECT- ATTENDANCE
INFORMATION THAT'S SPECIFIC TO
THE T. K. GRADE LEVEL WE JUST
COLLECTED IN A BROADER CATEGORY
OF- U. K. THROUGH THIRD GRADE-
SO WE'D SUGGEST ARE- IT
MONITORING THAT ISSUE IT MAY BE
ASKING. EDUCATION PRINT UPDATES
ABOUT THEIR PLANS FOR COLLECTING
THAT INFORMATION IS THAT THE
STATE HAS WHAT IT NEEDS IN ORDER
TO CALCULATE THAT ADJUSTMENT
CORRECTLY. OKAY THANK YOU-
FURTHER QUESTIONS RELATED THIS
PANEL. SEEING NONE WE'LL GO TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. WHEN THE-
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSALS.
FISKERTON DOUBLE YEAH THE-
GOTCHA THIS I'M SORRY THESE ARE
NOT THE BUDGET YEARS THIS IS
THIS OF THE CURRENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL YES THANK YOU SEE
NUMBER TWO D. O. F. L. A. L. AND
CD AGAIN. AGAIN OUR MEMBERS AN
IDEA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
ALL GO OUT JUST FOR A BRIEF VERY
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF SOME OF THE
MAJOR HEALTH SPENDING PROPOSAL
THOUGHT SEVERAL OF THEM I DID
MENTION IN MY- EARLIER
PRESENTATION OF THEY'LL GIVE UP
LIKE I MENTIONED DOES RECEIVE A
PROPOSED FIVE POINT 33% BILLION
DOLLAR CALL ADJUSTMENT THIS YEAR
SO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS WILL BE RECEIVING MORE
THAN SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS
NOW- THE OF THE ALTHEA. THE NOT
CONCLUDING ARE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT PROPOSAL- THE
ESTIMATED- REGIONAL FUNDS WE
MAKE FROM THAT- AND SPEAKING
ABOUT THE NUTRITION DOG ALSO
PROPOSED A PERMANENT CHANGE TO
HOW. WHAT WE CALL FUNDED EIGHTY
EIGHT WILL BE CALCULATED FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THE GENERATING LTFS AND GIVEN
YEAR. TO CIVICALLY SCHOOL
DISTRICT WOULD HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF BEING ON THE TOP OF THE
CURRENT YEAR. OUR PRIOR YEAR FOR
THE AVERAGE OF THE THREE MOST
RECENT PRIOR YEARS WHICHEVER OF
THOSE THREE VARIABLES IS
GREATER. AS I MENTIONED IN MY
EARLIER COMMENT THIS IS REALLY
IN RECOGNITION OF THE STEEP
DECLINE IN THE ROLE THAT.
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN FACING AFTER
SEVERAL YEARS EVEN PART OF THE
PANDEMIC- AND- WE BELIEVE WILL
GO A LONG WAY TO HELPING
INSULATE DOWN PROBLEM- SO MANY.
OF THE LRGE YEAR TO YEAR A
SWING HERE TO YOUR DECLINE. THAT
MANY L. EIGHT MANY DISTRICTS ARE
ARE ANTICIPATING SPECIFICALLY IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ANY
MINUTE IN FUTURE YEARS- IF NO
ACTION WOULD BE TAKEN AND JUST
THE GREATER CURRENT OR PRIOR
YEAR AS AN EXISTING LAW. WORK TO
REMAIN- THE MINISTRY. ALSO
PROPOSES CHANGES TO ANNA AND
STUDY TO HELP. THIS CLARA. AND
FLEXIBILITY BURKE. THE
COMPUTATION OF INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME THAT COUNTS TOWARDS
TENANTS- AND ALSO- CHANGES
REGARDING. THE ENROLLMENT OF
STUDENTS INTO INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAMS OF PROVIDING SOME.
BILLION CLARITY THERE MOVING
FORWARD. IN ADDITION TO THE COST
INCREASE ASSOCIATED WITH
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
EXPANSION THAT WE CAN DISCUSS
WEBER RETENTION FOR THE
ESTIMATED SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE MILLION- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO DOES PROPOSE TO A
SEPARATE- THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE BILLION FOR TRANSITION NO
KINDERGARTEN EXPANSION TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. TO HELP-
ELEAZAR REDUCE THOSE ADULT
STUDENT RATIO COUNTER ONCE
TWELVE OPPORTUNITY STATUTE- AS
WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON A
UNIVERSITY K. EXPANSION. THE
VERY LAST I DID WANT TO MAKE A-
VERY BRIEFLY I WANT TO MAKE A
TECHNICAL NOTE- WE WERE IT WAS
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION THERE
WAS A SLIGHT ERROR IN OUR
BASELINE PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENT
THAT WE USE TO CALCULATE THE L.
GIVE UP CALL- AND WHERE THOSE
ARE COMING FROM- NOT. TOTALED
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ACROSS THE THREE YEARS
AND I PLAYED ONE YEAR THAT WERE
INADVERTENTLY NOT REFLECTED
CORRECTLY AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WON'T RESULT IN ANY
PRACTICAL IMPACT THE L. E. A.
ANYTHING LIKE THAT BUT AND IT
DOESN'T HE ALSO DIDN'T IMPACT
THE OVERALL CALCULATION OF THE
PROPAGATE GUARANTEE- SO WE WERE
ADVISED THAT AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION BUT I DID JUST WANT TO.
HIGHLIGHT THAT HERE- IN IN
TRANSPARENCY BUT- WITHOUT I'LL
KEEP MY COMMENTS ON ON THIS VERY
BRIEF AND ALLOW THE L. O. CHAIR
AND HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY I THINK YOU L. L. GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
MICHAEL PHELPS WITH THE L. A. O.
I HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME. YES
GREAT- WE PUBLISHED A POST ON A
WEBSITE COVERING LVF COLA AS
WELL THE PROPOSAL TENANTS
ADJUSTMENT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
FOR YOUR REFERENCE I'LL KEEP OUR
COMMENTS HERE AT A HIGH LEVEL.
BOB ALL WE UPDATED OUR ESTIMATE
USING RELEASED FEDERAL DATA USED
TO CALCULATE THE RATE WE
ESTIMATE THAT THE CALL THE RATE
WILL BE CLOSER TO SIX POINT 17%
WHICH IS ALMOST 1% HIGHER THAN
THE KOLIBRI ESTIMATED IN THE
BUDGET- GOOD HIGHER COLO WITH ME
WOULD INCREASE HEALTH IF OF
COSTS BY ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. AND THE COST FOR GET
FULL CREDIBLE PROGRAMS WOULD
INCREASE BY ABOUT FIFTY SIX
MILLION- FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
RELEASE THE FINAL DATA USED TO
CALCULATE THE TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE COLIN APRIL AND WILL
APPEAR IN COURT IN THE-
REGARDING THE FULL PROPOSALS.
ADJUSTMENT WE'RE WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SAFE FOR ME
TO CHANGE. THE POOL OF STUFF IN
THE IMPACT OF THE ROMAN DECLINES
ON SCHOOL DISTRICT FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS. WITHIN THE PROPOSAL
WOULD ADDRESS BOTH A SHORT TERM
DROPS IN FUNDING TO THE PANDEMIC
AS WELL AS MORE LONG TERM. THE
PROPOSAL COULD PROMOTE FISCAL
STABILITY FOR DISTRICTS WEAPONS
BEEN EXPERIENCING SUSTAINED WITH
DECLINES IN ENROLLMENT. NOT AND
ALLOW THEM MORE TIME TO AND IT
JUST THEIR EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING FOR THE REMAINING
STUDENTS. ON SOME OF THE THINGS
AT THEM MORE TIME FOR PLANNING
ISRAEL SIX HALF. OF
CONSOLIDATING PROGRAMS CLOSING
SCHOOLS AND REORGANIZING
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS.
ADDITIONALLY AS THE DECLINE
DISTRICTS WILL HAVE A SOFTER THE
FUNDING. DISTRICTS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY GROWING WILL CONTINUE
TO RECEIVE HEALTH EFFECT
INCREASES IN THEIR HOUSE WITH A
FUNDING. FOR THE NEW STUDENTS.
ON THE GOVERNOR DOES NOT PROPOSE
ANY SPECIFIC OFFICE OF CHANGES
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT
INDICATES THAT MINISTRATION
WILL. EXPLORE OPTIONS FOR THE
SPRING DROUGHT THIS SPRING FOR
EXTENDING A DECLINING
ENROLLMENTS- SORRY TO CUT YOU
TEND. TO SUGGEST THAT THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS. YOU THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S CAN TO STUDY.
ATTENDEES AT THE THAT'S JUST NOT
FOR TERM READ. OF THE- DISK
COULD AND THEN VERY OPTIONS
LET'S JUST TO. HOWEVER FOR THE
CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR UNLIKE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOLS
FIFTH PROSPECT THAT IMMEDIATE
FUNDING REDUCTIONS BASED ON
ATTENDANCE DECLINES. DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER PROVIDING SOME TYPE OF
TEMPORARY JUST MEANT TO OFFSET
SOME FUNDING DECLINES IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. ONE OPTION COULD
BE TO ALLOW CHARTER SCHOOLS
RECEIVE FUNDING BASED ON THE
PREPEND EMIGRATE TENDONS FOR
ANOTHER YEAR. THIS WILL PROVIDE
THELEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION MORE TIME SIX AM
AND LONGER TERM ALTERNATIVES. OF
THIS CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE PROTECT. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I'M SORRY
CITY. A VERY NICELY ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION- AS THE S. P.
I. SHARED IN HIS OVER HERE IN
HIS OVERVIEW THE PANDEMIC
CONTINUES TO CREATE
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES FOR OUR
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS
ARE DISTRICTS ARE FACED WITH
SOME SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
DURING THESE VERY DIFFICULT
TIMES WE HAVE GENERALLY HEARD
CONCERNS ABOUT GROWING PENSION
COSTS STAFFING ALSO REMAINS A
HUGE CHALLENGE IN THE FIELD AND
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS WHILE TRYING TO TRACK
QUALIFIED STAFF. AND OF COURSE
THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT
ENROLLMENT AND EIGHTY IN LIGHT
OF THEIR PREVALENCE UPON THE
CRIME WE'RE THANKFUL FOR THE
PROPOSAL THE ADMINISTRATION AS
WELL AS OTHERS HAVE PUT FORWARD
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND
THERE ARE OTHER INTERCONNECTED
ISSUES TO ADDRESS TO SUCH AS THE
SUPPLY OF STAFF. AS WE WORK
THROUGH THESE PROPOSALS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE DO NOT
PENALIZE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO
ARE TRYING TO KEEP CLASSROOMS
WANTING WHILE KEEPING THEIR
STUDENTS HEALTHY AND SAFE AND WE
WOULD ASK THAT THAT LENDS THIS
KEPT IN MIND AS WE DISCUSS HOW
BEST TO HELP ELEAZAR GET THROUGH
THE THIRTY YEAR OF THE PANDEMIC.
WITH THIS IN MIND THE DEPARTMENT
HAS ASKED THAT WAS ASKED TO PULL
PRELIMINARY DATA COLLECTED IN
THE STATE'S STUDENT LEVEL DATA
SYSTEM CAL PADS OVERALL AS OF
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE K.
TWELVE ENROLLMENT COUNTS ARE
DOWN. ONE POINT 9% FROM LAST
YEAR. AND TWENTY WE SAW THE LAW.
GRAY LEVEL DECREASE IN
KINDERGARTEN ELEVEN POINT SIX
PERCENT. FROM THE PRIOR YEAR
WHICH INCLUDED TWENTY TWO POINT
7% INCREASE. IN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND A NINE POINT
FOUR DECREASE IN REGULAR
KINDERGARTEN. IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE PRELIMINARY DATA SHOWS A
TOTAL INCREASE OF ONE POINT 7%
IN KINDERGARTEN. AND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
ENROLLMENT. FROM THE PRIOR YEAR.
WHICH INCLUDES A NINE POINT 7%
INCREASE IN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND EIGHT POINT 3%
INCREASE IN REGULAR KINDERGARTEN
. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT
PRELIMINARY DATA SHOWED VARIABLE
DECREASES IN GRADES ONE THROUGH
ELEVEN FROM THE PRIOR YEAR WITH
THE LARGEST INCREASE IN GRADES
ONE THROUGH FIVE GRADES THROUGH
THESE SEVEN THROUGH NINE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
PRELIMINARY DATA SHOWS SMALL
INCREASES IN GRADE TWELVE AND
GRADE SIX GRADE TEN AND GRADE
LEVEL LEVEN. DECREASING SLIGHTLY
BUT REMAINING RELATIVELY FLAT
FROM THE PRIOR YEAR. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE PRELIMINARY DATA
ALSO SHOWS THAT THE DECREASE IN
KINDERGARTEN ENROLLMENT OBSERVED
IN TWENTY TWENTY HAS SHIFTED TO
GRADE ONE WITH A DECREASE OF
PORT FOUR POINT 3% FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR. BASED ON HISTORICAL
MOMENT TRANS WE EXPECTED THAT
THESE PRELIMINARY ENROLLMENT
NUMBERS WITH INCREASED BY THE
FINAL DATA. SUBMISSION DEADLINE
FOR CAL PATS IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWO. HOWEVER THIS DOES NOT
APPEAR TO HAVE OCCURRED FINALLY
MOMENT NUMBERS BASED ON FIRST
WEDNESDAY IN OCTOBER WILL BE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE IN EARLY
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. I
HAVE WITH ME ELIZABETH DEAR
STEIN DIRECTOR FOR THE SCHOOLS
FISCAL SERVICES DIVISION RANDY
BANAL FROM OUR ANALYSIS
MEASUREMENT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORTING DIVISION TO ASSAULT
ASSIST IN ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
KNOW- THIS- EIGHTY A ISSUE IS
JUST A MICROCOSM OF WHERE WE'RE
AT WITH CALIFORNIA HAVING.
DECLINING ENROLLMENT AS WELL AS
GOING THROUGH THE PANDEMIC WITH
KOBE NINETEEN AS WELL SO THERE
ARE LOTS OF IDEAS ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THIS BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE OF WHAT WE DO IS IN THE
BEST. LONG TERM- PERSPECTIVE
CALIFORNIA KNOWING THAT WE WILL
GET PAST THIS- THIS PANDEMIC IN
THE IMPACT HERE AND WE WILL HAVE
AS MR O'DONNELL NOTED-
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL SO WE'RE
NOT DEBATING BILLS HERE HERE
TODAY. BILLS THAT ARE NOT EVEN
IN THIS HOUSE BUT I DID WANT TO
ASK ABOUT THIS OVERALL EIGHTY
EIGHT ISSUE AND SO YOU KNOW WE
HEARD ABOUT THIS LAST FALL WE
HAD A HEARING. WE ASKED L. A. L.
AND FINANCE TO COME UP WITH SOME
IDEAS AND SO. THE- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- CAME UP WITH THAT KIND
OF A I'M I GUESS THE MIDDLE
GROUND APPROACH. SO DETERMINE
FIRST OF ALL DEPARTMENT FRIENDS
CAN YOU GET MORE INTO DETAIL ON
HOW YOU THINK THAT THIS. ADDRESS
IS- THE ISSUES THAT THAT
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
ARTICULATING AND GRANTED WE WANT
TO DO SOMETHING THAT HELPS THE
MOST AMOUNT OF SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS NOT JUST FOR ONE SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE BIGGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SO- WALK US THROUGH
WHY WE THINK THIS IS. THE- THE
MOST SOUND APPROACH. CERTAINLY
AREA FORMA FINANCE AGAIN. SO I
THINK I WOULD NOTE SEVERAL
THINGS- IN TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT
ABILITY- IT THE MOST SIMILAR TO
OUR- CURRENT STRUCTURE BOTH IN
THE SENSE OF. OUR WORK BUT IT
STATE LEVEL BUT ALSO BURDEN ON
ON ON THAT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
RIGHT- THEY ALREADY REPORT THEIR
CURRENT AND PRIOR YEAR EIGHTY
EIGHT AND THIS WILL JUST BE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THAT DATA
ABOUT PER- MULTIPLE PRIOR YEARS.
WRITES ABOUT BUT ONE THING I
THINK THE IMMEDIATE EMPLOYMENT-ABILITY AS- IN OUR FAVOR. ON THE
OTHER. IS THAT IF WE WERE YOU
KNOW WHAT. THE CONSIDERATION OF-
MOVING TO OTHER KINDS OF FUNDING
MODELS ASIDE FROM EIGHTY EIGHT-
WOULD REQUIRE A LOTOF WORK
AGAIN- REALLY SPEAK TO THE-
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION PIECE.
ANNOUNCED WITH REGARD TO THINGS
LIKE ACCOUNTABILITY RIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT AT THE EXISTING STRUCTURE
WHEN IT COMES TO CALCULATING OUR
ATTENDANCE INSTRUCTION TIME-
WHAT WHAT THAT IS MADE UP BY-
THERE'S A WHOLE YOU KNOW BACK IN
ACCOUNTABILITY AS WELL WITHIN
THE AUDIT STRUCTURE- SO I WOULD.
SPEAK TO THAT IN TERMS OF THIS
NOT NEEDING REALLY TAKE ANY
OVERHAUL IN THAT REGARD IT WOULD
BE AGAIN. IMPLEMENTABLE IN THAT
REGARD REALLY KEEPING THE FOCUS
ON MAKING SURE THAT OUR KIDS ARE
IN SCHOOL KIDS ARE ATTENDING THE
ARE BEING SERVED- VERSUS PERHAPS
JUST BEING ENROLLED. SO THAT'S
ONE THING- THE OTHER I WOULD
KNOW IS THAT. WHEN IT COMES TO
YOU KNOW THE TRENDS THAT WERE
OBSERVING BUT I MENTIONED
ACCEPTED EVEN PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AND CERTAINLY IT DOES
SEEM LIKE- WE HAD PERHAPS MORE
FAMILIES WITH THE STATE OR MORE
FAMILIES THE DIFFERENT AREAS.
STATE MOVED WITHIN THE STATE
THEN PERHAPS IT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED ABSENT THE PANDEMIC BUT
OVERALL THE TRENDS ARE STILL THE
SAME- THE K. TWELVE POPULATION
TO KEEP ABOUT THE POPULATION. IS
DECLINING AND IT BUT WITH BIRTH
RATES BEING WHAT THEY ARE THINGS
LIKE THAT IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE THE CASE FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE. EVEN WITH-
TO TAKE SPANISH AND IT DOES SEEM
LIKE ON A STATEWIDE BASIS-
OVERALL THAT ENROLLMENT IN K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DECLINE. ON THE LONG
TERM SO I DO THINK OUR PROPOSAL-
RECOGNIZES THE DIFFICULTIES BUT
ALSO RECOGNIZES THE REALITY THAT
MANY LEDS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
FACE WHEN IT COMES TO- RIGHT
TIGHTENING THEIR PROGRAM
OFFERINGS RIGHT FIGHTING THEIR-
THEIR SCHOOLS AND- YOU DON'T
PERSONALLY WE RECOGNIZE THESE
ARE. THESE ARE DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION I'M CERTAINLY- BUT
CLOSING DOWN THE SCHOOL AND
DECISIONS OF THAT NATURE- ARE.
RARELY MET WITH YOU KNOW
POSITIVE RECEPTIVITY BUT- IS
CERTAINLY IN SOME AREAS OF THE
STATE THOSE ARE THE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS. THAT NEED THAT IN
SOME CASES ARE GOING TO NEED TO
BE HOT WEATHER. THIS YEAR AREN'T
YEARS- THAT'S JUST HOW OF THE
PUMP. THAT THAT. OF THE BEAST
SERVICE TO THAT X. AND START THE
OUR PEOPLE REALLY. THAT RIGHT AS
WELL SO IT'S ALLOW. US LANDING
TO SPEAK HE GOT OUT. ON THE WHEN
WE DO IT HAS A THESE ARE ALL
DECLINE. TO GIVE L. MORE. TO AND
LOOK AHEAD AND POINT. FOR WHAT
THE MOTHER COME. WHAT SOME OF
THOSE. IN CHOICES. NAY GONNA
NEED TO BE. MAKING OUR- WE FEEL
THAT OUR PROPOSAL KIND OF WALKS
LINE- BY BYE PROVIDING THEM
SUPPORT THEY NEED. AND IN A THEM
TO THOSE THE DECISIONS SO I'LL
BE BUYING. ANSWER THAT OKAY.
JUST ONE FOLLOW UP. SO THE WE
HAD OUR HEARING ON THIS AND FALL
AND FROM THE FINANCES THERE AND
THAT TIME LAST YEAR. THE THE
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES AND YOU
KNOW IT LARGE EDUCATION
ORGANIZATION. APPROACHED US THE
LEGISLATURE AND YOU WITH A
DIFFERENT APPROACH AND WHAT WAS
YOUR- TAKE ON THAT AS FAR AS THE
ADA VERSUS ACTUAL ATTENDANCE.
RIGHT I THINK AT THIS POINT WE
STAND BEHIND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND YOU KNOW I
KNOW THERE ARE SOME- I'LL KEEP
MY COMMENTS. NO I GET THAT BUT
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE- THE-
ENROLLMENT VERSUS ACTUAL
ATTENDANCE THAT IDEA WAS
APPROACH TO US IN THE FALL
REGARDLESS OF THE BILL. SO DID
WAS THAT EVALUATED AND WAS THAT
CONSIDERED AS AN APPROACH AND
YOU JUST THOUGHT THAT THIS WAS
THE BETTER APPROACH. BUT
CERTAINLY SORRY I THINK I MAY
HAVE MISUNDERSTOOD YOUR
QUESTION- SO YEAH WE DEFINITELY.
CONSIDERED SEVERAL OPTIONS AND
AGAIN I THINK ALL THE REASONS I
LAID OUT A PREVIOUSLY ARE ARE
WHY WE REALLY LANDED ON ON OUR
PROPOSAL WHICH WILL BE HELD TO
BE THE BEST. OPERABLE THE MOVING
FORWARD. OKAY FAIR ENOUGH AND
WILL HAVE PLENTY OF TIME TO
WEIGH INTO THIS- OKAY THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S IT FOR NOW- MISTER
DONNA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I JUST BOB- UNDER THREE
HIGHLIGHT WHAT I SAID USING
DIFFERENT WORDS- THE FIVE POINT
33% COAL IS JUST WAY TOO LOW. TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS- GIVEN THE INFLATIONARY
ENVIRONMENT THE NEED TO ADDRESS
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH. A READING
COMPREHENSION LEARNING LOS SIX
ADDRESS SO IT NEEDS TO BE MUCH
HIGHER THAN THAT. AND SOMETHING
A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK ABOUT CLASS
SIZE. I SUB OVER THE FALLS I
MENTIONED EARLIER AND WHAT IT
WHAT KIDS WERE ABSENT. RIGHT
WHILE THE KIDS ONE WAY THAT I
KNOW WHERE THEY WENT- BUT THE
CLASS SIZES WERE MUCH SMALLER IN
THIS WAS MIDDLE SCHOOL- IN YOU
KNOW IT'S WHEN YOU HAVE THIRTY
FIVE MIDDLE SCHOOLERS IN A
CLASSROOM ESPECIALLY AS A
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER PARTICULAR
RIGHT. IT CAN BE A LITTLE BIT OF
A ROCKY EXPERIENCE FOR THOSE
CLASS SIZES OR ABOUT TWENTY TWO
ISHE. AND I TELL YOU WHAT IT
CHANGED THE TONE OF THE SCHOOL
DAY. HAVING THAT MANY FEWER KIDS
IN THE CLASSROOM YOU GET TO KNOW
THEM. AND IT'S A MUCH MORE
RELAXING ENVIRONMENT. THERE'S
MANY QUALITATIVE. THOSE PEOPLE
THAT YOU KNOW WORK IN THE IVORY
TOWERS INTO THEIR STUDIES THAT
HAVE NEVER TAUGHT SCHOOL WILL
TELL YOU ALL WE DON'T THINK IT
IMPACTS STUDENTS. ACHIEVEMENT I
CAN TELL YOU WHAT ABSOLUTELY.
IMPACTS STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AND
ALSO STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH BUT
FRANKLY. BECAUSE GET BETTER
CONNECTIONS WITH THEIR FELLOW
STUDENTS AND THEIR TEACHERS. SO
AGAIN THAT COLIN NEEDS TO BE
MUCH HIGHER. AND WHEN PEOPLE
SITE IN DECLINING ENROLLMENT AS
A CALL REALLY AT THAT THAT'S TO
ADDRESS DECLINING ENROLLMENT
THAT'S NOT JUST A CALL- SO THAT
THAT THAT'S- WHAT ONE POINT. AND
I APPRECIATE THE SOMEONE
BROACHED IT FURTHER PATCHING
THIS YEAR'S. DECLINING
ATTENDANCE- PROBABLY WITH WITH
ONE TIME MONEY THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO LOOK INTO-
90% OF SCHOOLS ARE. AFFILIATES
ARE EXPERIENCING DECLINING
ATTENDANCE- AND WITH REGARD TO
IT WHETHER I KNOW WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT BILL BE SENT WITH
CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT I DON'T
THINK THERE SHOULD BE ANY EFFORT
TO HOLD HARMLESS THOSE ONLINE
CHARTER SCHOOLS THEY SHOULD NOT
BE HELD HARMLESS- AND THEN WITH
REGARD INDEPENDENT STUDY- THE
BRODRICK PROPOSES TO CLARIFY HOW
SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION IS
TRACED FOR INDEPENDENT STUDY AND
EXTEND THE TIME FOR OBTAINING
AGREEMENT SIGNATURES I WOULD
ARGUE THAT WE NEED TO DO THAT IN
THIS CURRENT YEAR ACTUALLY- WE
NEED TO MOVE UP THAT TIMELINE TO
GET THAT ADDRESSED. SO THAT
SCHOOLS CAN GET THEIR MONEY-
WITH THAT I WILL- DIRECTOR
MISTER. THANK YOU. THE QUESTION
SOMEONE MEMBER BY IT AS- THANK
FOR SHARED JUST- ADDITIONAL JUST
INFORMATION. AROUND THE
ATTENDANCE CRISIS THE ATTENDANCE
DATA REFLECTED IN THE AGENDA
APPEARS TO SHOW AN IMPROVED RATE
OF ATTENDANCE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FOR THOSE IN THE- QUOTE
EXCELLENT AND SATISFACTORY
CATEGORIES BUT A SHARP DECREASE.
ACROSS MULTIPLE TENDONS
CATEGORIES AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE WHOSE ATTENDANCE WAS
PREVIOUSLY CATEGORIZED AS
EXCELLENT SO OR OR CHRONIC- SO.
THIS SUGGESTS THAT THE CRISIS IS
HITTING BOTH ENDS OF THE STUDENT
SPECTRUM EXTREMELY HARD TO DO
WOULD DO WE HAVE ANY INDICATION
OF WHAT ENGAGEMENT STRATEGIES WE
NEED TO USE- IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL DATA ON. YOU KNOW ON
WHO IT IS NOT SHOWING UP TO
CLASS I KNOW- THE CITY- REPORTED
THAT ARE BLACK AND LATINO
STUDENTS- THIS PAST YEAR- WERE
SOMEWHERE IN THE RANGE OF 80% OF
THEM WEREN'T PASSING THEIR THEIR
THEIR MATH. AT GRADE LEVEL SO
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO IS ACTUALLY BEING IMPACTED
AND WHAT STRATEGIES WE NEED TO
BE DISCUSSING. SO THIS TO THE
CITY. CITY YOUR QUESTION. YEAH I
HEARD THE QUESTION THANK YOU- I
THINK WE AS THE SUPERINTENDENT
MENTIONED IN HIS EARLIER-
REMARKS WE AREN'T WORKING ON
SOME PILOT PROGRAMS TO DELVE A
SPECIFIC SCHOOL DISTRICTS US AS-
OAKLAND YOU WEST CONTRA COSTA
UNIFIED BIT YOU'RE RIGHT IT IS
HITTING A VARIETY OF AREAS- WE
KNOW IT'S OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS ARE OFTEN NOT- THE
SHOWING UP IN SCHOOLS- BUT WE
ALSO HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
THAT IS IMPACTING PUBLIC ACROSS
THE- THE SPECTRUM. OF OUR
STUDENTS SO WE ARE LOOKING AT A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT TO- THAT
TACTICS- AND I THINK THESE AND
NEW INVESTMENTS IN OUR OF FROM
THE STATE- ARE REALLY GOING TO
HELP AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
LOOKING AT COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND
LOOKING AT OUR EXPANDED LEARNING
OPTIONS- TO BE ABLE TO SEE-
THESE STUDENTS IN A WAY THAT
THAT IS- OFFERING NEW. SERVICES
AT TO UNDERSTAND WHY ME WHY ME
THEY MAY NOT BE SHOWING UP AT
SCHOOL SO- THERE ARE A YEAR THIS
IS AN ONGOING ISSUE THIS IS BEEN
SOMETHING THE SUPERINTENDENT IS
FOCUSED ON I EVEN BEFORE HE
ARRIVED- IF THIS- THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION- IN THE- PROGRAMS THAT
HE PASSED THAT ARE BEING RIGHT
NOW SINCE I'M TWENTY FOURTEEN I
TO REALLY LOOK INTO THE IMPACTS
OF CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM AND HOW
BEST TO GET MORE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND TO UNDERSTAND- WHY OUR
STUDENTS ARE NOT SHOWING UP SO
WE ARE WORKING ON SOME PILOTS
THAT SHOULD BE STARTING ACTUALLY
MAY HAVE ALREADY STARTED- JUST
THIS NEW YEAR. I WITH THE NUMBER
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUT WE ARE
VERY HANDS ON IN OUR APPROACH TO
UNDERSTANDING WHERE STUDENTS ARE
NOT SHOWING UP- I'M NOT SURE
RANDY BUT NOW IF YOU'RE THERE IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO BRING IN DISCUSS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ACTUAL- DATA THAT
WE'RE SEEING FOR CHRONIC.
ABSENCE MY NAME'S READY MONEY
WORKING NELSON MEDINA COUNTY
BILITY RIP TO BE IT'S- IS MADE
OF YOU ARE. A THE DEPARTMENT
RELEASED A CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
DATED THIS YEAR AFTER A PAUSE
LAST YEAR. AND SO YOU KNOW AS AS
WAS JUST MENTIONED THE- THE
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM RATES
INCREASED FOR THE LAW AND THAT
THE LACK YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
YOU KNOW MOST NOTABLY AND- ARE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND SO
I THINK THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT CAN WE TRY TO MAKE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE AND- OBVIOUSLY- IN THE
AREA OF CONCERN THAT. ANOTHER
APARTMENT IS. IS REALLY TRYING
TO WORK ON- AND YOU KNOW. PLEASE
PAY ATTENTION TO THE DATA THAT
WE MAKE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND I
HOPE I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS. THAT DOES THE. DATA REFLECTED. LOCAL GIVING
FEEDBACK THERE LOWER IN REAL
TRYING. PEOPLE'S BALLS ONE
HUNDRED AND EARLY- EIGHTEEN WE
MAY SEE VALUE WITH X. OF ONCE
YOU REACH A SIX YOU KNOW- IS IT
JUST BEFORE IMPACT HI GROW SO
HIRED RATE BUT WHAT THE I KNOW
THAT WE DON'T HAVE SEE THAT. I
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY ANY DAY ON ON
INCREASE DROP OUT RATE BUT THIS
MAKES THAT SO- IF YOU HAVE THAT
IF YOU CAN SEND IT. I WOULD IT.
IT IS A LOT ME RESET WHAT I
THINK YOU'RE ASKING FOR YOU'RE
ASKING FOR INFORMATION ABOUT
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM- CONDEMNED
BY GREAT SPAM. CORRECT GRADE
SPAN ALL AND YOU TO PUT AND
POPULATION V. IS YES SIR NOW
HE'S YEAH THAT THAT IN- MAKE
AVAILABLE ARE DATAQUEST SITE BUT
HAPPY TO PUT TOGETHER- SOME TIME
TALKING POINTS- SUMMARIZING WHAT
YOU ASK FOR AND SEND IT OVER.
THANK YOU. YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I JUST WANT TO ADD IN THERE-
DURING THE WINTER OF LAST YEAR
WE ACTUALLY HAD OUR ENTIRE
EXECUTIVE TEAM MAKING PHONE TO
DIRECTLY TO OF LISTS OF STUDENTS
THAT WERE CHRONIC ABSENT AND
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT WE FOUND
WAS THAT IT HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE ACTUAL SCHOOL- MANY OF
THE STUDENTS- WE'RE TAKING CARE
OF FAMILY MEMBERS- THEY HAD TO
WORK- THEIR PARENTS WERE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS SO IT WAS VERY
COMPLEX AND I KNOW THAT OUR
SCHOOLS- REACHING OUT TO US
BECAUSE THERE WAS REALLY A THEY
HAD TRIED ALL THEIR INTERVENTION
SO WE'RE HOPING THAT. WE CAN
TURN THESE TRENDS AROUND- AS WE
COME OUT OF THE PANDEMIC AND
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES I WILL BE ABLE TO YOU-
GET BACK TO SOME LEVEL OF
NORMALCY AND- AND IN THE- OF
THESE. THESE IS. THEY MAY HAVE
NOTHING TO DO THE ACT SCHOOLS-
CAN BE DEALT WITH AND ADDRESSED
. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REST. THANK YOU
MISTER. HELLO MY SPECIAL
EDUCATION- COMMUTE COMMUNITY HAS
CONTINUE TO. COMPLAIN ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF THE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND TO THE BIGGEST
CONCERN THEY'VE HAD TO IS THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT IS SPENT.
ON ATTORNEYS. ON LEGAL FEES IN
DEFENDING A SCHOOL DISTRICT-
AGAINST A FAMILY OR PARENT-
ASKING FOR- FOR ACCOMMODATIONS
FOR THEIR STUDENTS IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT IS BEING ADDRESSED
SPECIFICALLY IN THE BUDGET TO
ENSURE THAT THE MONEY IS GOING
MORE FOR THE THESE PLANS FOR THE
STUDENTS AND FOR THE ASSISTANCE
OF THE STUDENT. AS OPPOSED TO
LEGAL FEES IS THERE A CAP ON
LEGAL FEES. ARE THERE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THAT REGARD.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
AMBER ALEXANDER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I CAN GO AHEAD AND START
AND- AND OTHERS ARE WELCOME TO
CHIME IN IF THEY HAPPEN.
INFORMATION BUT IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WILL HEAR TE SPECIAL
EDUCATION I BELIEVE THAT PANEL
FOR AND THERE'S NOTHING'S. TO
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION LEGAL FEES
I WOULDN'T KNOW- LAST YEAR THERE
WAS A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT OF
A HUNDRED MILLION- BUT HAVE
PREPOSITION EIGHT FOCUSED. ON
ALTERNATE DISPUTE RESOLUTION-
ALL. PERMITTING TEAM- BUT FROM
RISING TO BE- A LEVEL WHERE YOU
KNOW AT SIX SIX AMOUNT OF
FUNDING WOULD HAVE TO BE PUT
TOWARDS LEGAL FEES- IT'S AGAIN
IT AND AT ONE COMING BACK.
BECAUSE OF OVER MULTIPLE YEARS
THAT I IS VERY STILL- IN AN
ADDITIONAL YOUR LATER IN THIS
PANEL WE DO HAVE. I'M A GENERAL
BUT IT WILL IF YOU FUNDING GOING
INTO THIS EDUCATION- BASEBALL
THAT COULD NOT BE USED FOR THESE
PURPOSES TO THE EXTENT THAT IT'S
UNNECESSARY. USE I'M COURSE I
WANT TO BECAUSE- THAT MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING
ACTUAL. SERVICE AND- EDUCATION.
THE BIGGEST COMPLAINT I HEAR
FROM FAMILIES HAS TO DO WITH
LEGAL FEES. MIGHT MIGHT NEXT. IT
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THIS
CHRONIC ACT ABSENTEEISM. THE
LACK OF DATA- AND I. THAT YOU
KNOW THE COMMENTS. GIVEN IN
RESPONSE. TO INDICATE THAT THERE
ARE SOME DATA THAT HAS BEEN
COLLECTED. R. R. ELLIE AS
ALREADY- SEPARATING THE
INFORMATION THE DATA THAT
THEY'RE TAKING ON ATTENDANCE. TO
MAKE IT EASIER HAD THEY BEEN
ELSE TO SEPARATE THAT
INFORMATION. TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR YOU TO DETERMINE THE REASON
FOR THE ABSENTEEISM. FOR THE
ABSENCES AND THEN IF SO HOW IS
THIS IN FOR BE YOU HER OF THE TO
BE USED. REALLY COULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT. YES DO WE
COLLECT INFORMATION ABOUT SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE REASONS
WHY STUDENTS ARE ABSENT CARAVANS
INCLUDES- EXCUSED ABSENCES
UNEXCUSED ABSENCE AND INCOMPLETE
INDEPENDENT STUDY AND ALSO SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT STUDENTS WHO
WERE ABSENT DUE TO SUSPENSION
I'M I THINK THE WAY YOU'RE
ASKING FOR PROBABLY HAS TO DO
WITH- YOU KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
STUDENTS WERE ABSENT DUE TO.
REASONS RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC
AND OUR COLLECTION RIGHT NOW
DOESN'T GO TO THAT GRANULAR OF A
LEVEL SILICON WE COLLECT
INFORMATION ON EXCUSED UNEXCUSED
ABSENCES DUE TO SUSPENSION AND
INCOMPLETE INDEPENDENT STUDY. WE
ALSO MAKE THAT INFORMATION
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON OUR
DATAQUEST WEBSITE- IN A REPORT
CALLED ABSENTEEISM BY REASON
WHERE YOU CAN SEE THAT
INFORMATION DISAGGREGATED BY
VARIOUS STUDENT GROUPS- SCHOOLS
AND DISTRICTS AS WELL. THANK YOU
FOR MAY MISTER YES. I CAN FIND
TO THE BUT- IT WAS ALSO
DISCUSSED BY ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT LEAST ONE. THAT
ABSENTEEISM HAS INCREASED IN 90%
OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND IF
THIS IS TRUE THEN IT IS MUCH
MORE A MUCH MORE SERIOUS ISSUE
THAT IT HAS BEEN IN THE PAST.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT REQUIRES
MUCH MORE ATTENTION THAN IT HAS
RECEIVED IN THE PAST. THAT THAT
IS MY BIGGEST CONCERN ESPECIALLY
SINCE WE DO KNOW THAT DO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ABSENTEEISM THEM
TALKING ABOUT LOSS OF.
DAVIDOVICH OCCASION OF FOR MANY
OF THE STUDENTS AND USUALLY THE
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND THE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THAT ARE MOST
AFFECTED BY THIS. AND IF WE
DON'T HAVE WE PUT ALL COLLECTED
. TO SEE WHERE THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM IS THAT WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE WE NEED TO INVEST THE
MONEY. MORE MONEY TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE AND HELP TO ALLEVIATE HELP
TO ALLEVIATE THE PROBLEM OF FOR
THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS OF WE
GIVE EVERYBODY THE SAME AMOUNT
OF MONEY. IT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
RESOLVE THIS WE HAVE IT IF YOU
PUT THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT 10% AS YOU DO IN HAT 90%
OF THE 10% CLEARLY DOESN'T NEED
THAT BUT THAT 90% DOES AND I
JUST I WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE
ARE. MAKING GREATER EFFORTS TO
COLLECT THE DATA AND I WANT TO
KNOW I APPRECIATE YOUR REPORT
APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING IT ON THE
WEBSITE- BUT I'M JUST CONCERNED
THAT WE'RE NOT. GIVING IT THE
ATTENTION THAT WE SHOULD AT THIS
TIME AS WERE COMING OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
COME OUT OF IT. BUT SOME OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE SUFFERING A
WHOLE LOT MORE THAN OTHERS AND I
WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE GIVE
THEM THE ATTENTION AND THE
FINANCES THE RESOURCES THEY'RE
GOING TO NEED. TO ADDRESS THIS
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM THAT IS
AFFECTING THEM TO A DEGREE MUCH
GREATER THAN SOME OF THE OTHER
SCHOOLS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER TOM GO BACK YOU IF YOU
WANT TO RAISE ISSUE ENOUGH. THE
WELL I JUST ONE OF THE HIGHER
THEIR A QUESTION ABOUT WITH A
GROUP WITH WITH REGARD TO
LAWYERS FEES A COMMENT MADE
ABOUT LAWYERS FEES. IN THE
SPECIAL ED ARENA LAST YEAR. WE
DID SET ASIDE SOME MONEY FOR
FAMILY. EMPOWERMENT CENTERS IN
THE BUDGET. AND UNDER THAT
UMBRELLA IS DISPUTE. THERE SOME
ONE. MONEY SET UP TO BUILD AN
FOR. IS THIS ACROSS THE STATE.
TO A- DISPUTE. I JUST WANTED. TO
SHARE THAT. OKAY THANK YOU HAN
WHICH WE'RE NOT PROUD TO TAKE
THE ROLE SO LET'S DO THAT REAL
QUICK HERE FOR PEOPLE HERE.
MCCARTY YOUR- GALLAGHER LEE
MEDINA O'DONNELL. RAYOS HERE BY
THE A. OKAY NEXT ISSUE PLEASE.
BERMAN A FINANCE. WELL YES GO
AHEAD BUT. GOOD MORNING HEARING
MEMBERS JENNIFER COFFEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HOPEFULLY
IT BACKED BY FOR LOW EDUCATE AGE
FOR YOUR WILL BE SO THESE
TECHNICAL CONSTRUCTION
MODERNIZATION AND EMERGING
REPAIR. THIS PROGRAM IS THE
BETTER BY THE- FOR WHICH BY THE
OF. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
OUTLOOK THERE MAY REMAINING
PROPERTY FIFTY ONE BONTA
APPROXIMATELY ONE WORKED DOLLARS
TO FOR WILL CONSTRUCTION. THIS
IS THAT YOU YOUR MUSIC BACK TO.
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE BUT
PROPOSAL ONE TWO BILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME FUND INTO TWO TWENTY
THREE AND NOT HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND AND THREE TWENTY FOUR IS
THE YOU CAN IN MODERN. PROJECT.
THE PROGRAM. I'M AND MY FROM
YEAH THE PUBLIC SCHOOL. ARE HERE. THANK YOU L. L. MORNING MR
MEMBERS IN THE LEAD ALLEGED AND
OFFICE SO DO NOT HAVE SO
RECOMMEND ON GOVERNOR'S ON THE
SCHOOL PROGRAM BUT WE DID WANT
TO NOTE SEVERAL THINGS IN
ADDITION TO THE POINTS THAT
FINANCE JUST SHARED SO- PSC HAS
A WAIT LIST OF NEW CONSTRUCTION
AND MODERNIZATION PROJECTS THAT
TOTAL AROUND THREE BILLION
DOLLARS BEYOND FIND A THREE ON
THE PROPOSED FUNDING FOR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR WHAT FIND
AROUND TWO THREE FOURTHS OF THE
WAITLISTED PROJECTS. BUT THIS IS
JUST A POINT IN TIME ESTIMATE-
WE ALSO NOTE THAT FINDING SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROJECTS USING
GENERAL FUND WILL LIKELY BE LESS
COSTLY THAN USING G. O. BONDS
DUE TO STEEP SEATING ON INTEREST
COSTS AND THEN LASTLY AS
MENTIONED IN YOUR AGENDA AND
EARLIER IN THE HEARING THAT
STATE IS ABOVE ITS STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. THE POST FUNDING FOR THE
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM WOULD
BE CONSIDERED EXCLUDABLE FROM
THE CORPORATIONS LIMIT SO IF THE
LEGISLATURE WORSHIPPED FUNDING
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
YOU NOT EXEMPTS PRIORITIES THE
STATE WOULD EXCEED THE LIMIT BY
A LARGER AMOUNT BUT THAT-
INCLUDING COMMENTS AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTION AT THE APPROPRIATE. TIME THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
. OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL CAN.
HI I'M GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
THAT MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M LISA SILVERMAN AND EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION AND COUNTY
THE SCHOOL FACILITIES FUNDS AND
WE HAVE A FORTY TWO BILLION
DOLLAR. IN BROWNISH- KERRY THIS
PURPOSE AS YOU THE IS A- IT'S A
LOCAL MATTER- BECAUSE- WITH
SCHOOL THIS SO THEY THEY CAN
LEAD TO THE DESIGN. AND THEY CAN
MODERNIZE ANY SCHOOL FACILITY
THAT'S ELIGIBLE. MEN TO THIS
POINT WE WANT TO SHARE THAT WE
HAD OVER FORTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN PRIOR PUNISHMENT. AND
WE HAVE ALSO EXPANDED OVER.
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS AND BACK
BONTA NATION IS THE PRIOR
UNDERSTOOD AS WELL- JUST GIVE
YOU A GLIMPSE OF WHAT THE
PROGRAM HAS PROVIDED. OVER
TWENTY POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN AWARDED TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THAT
REPRESENT OVER FORTY THREE
HUNDRED. PROJECTS AND OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND CLASSROOMS SO ENORMOUS
AMOUNT RESPONSE OVER THE YEARS
OVER GLAD OF THOSE JUDGES. AND
FOR THE MODERNIZATION. OVER
THIRTEEN POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN AWARDED. AND
THAT REPRESENTS OVER SEVENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED PROJECTS- AWARDED
AND OVER HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND CLASSROOMS- RENOVATED A
REHAB. AND GENETICS WE ALSO
WANTED TO SHARE THAT FOR THE
CAREER TECH EDUCATION PROGRAM
THERE IS OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE PROGRAM GRANTS AWARDED FOR
NEARLY NINE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION. AND FOR THE TURNER
SCHOOL PROGRAM OVER AT CHIU
PROGRAM GRANTS AWARDED. FOR
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS- AND YOU KNOW-
JUST TO TOUCH ON A LITTLE BIT OF
THE PROGRAM WE HAVE EXPANDED OUR
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE FULL DAY
GINGER. WE'RE HAPPY ABOUT THIS
NEW TRANSITION AND WE HAVE
AWARDED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- FORTY SOME PROJECTS
DURING. MAY IN OCTOBER TWO
NINETEEN. AND DEFINITELY EXPAND
THE- WITH THE FOR HOW NINETY
NINE DOLLARS A PART OF. CURRENT
BUDGET. AND WE HAVE A NOW
WEDNESDAY. BOARD AND FOR ROUND
FOR THAT HUNDRED MILLION. SO
THAT WE TO FINALLY. ONE APRIL.
TWENTY TWENTY FOR TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION. AND A
SUBSCRIBER. THAT OPEN IN APRIL
TWENTY THREE. FOR THE REMAINING
FUNDS ARE TO FIFTY POINT MILLION
DOLLARS. I'M TO GIVE YOU OVER OF
SOME OF THE PER THAT WE DO- HAVE
IS NEW CAN. AND MODERNIZATION.
AND THE FACILITY HARDSHIPS. IS
ALSO A COMPONENT THAT STILL
HURTS YOU PROGRAM IT COVERS SIDE
SEISMIC MITIGATION- WE HAVE
CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND THEN WE
ALSO HAVE A CAREER EDUCATION
PROGRAM. I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE MENTIONED- SOME OF OUR
LIST. WE WANT TO COVER THAT-
WHAT THE LIST MEANS THAT WE HAVE
TO LISTEN MAINTAINED AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THE
DISTINCTION OF THOSE LAST. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AN UNFUNDED LIST
WHICH IS REPRESENTS PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED. AND ON
THE LACK OF AB FIFTY FIVE LOANS
SO THEY RIGHT. A PRODUCT
APPROVAL BY SILICON BOARD WITHIN
THEIR WAITING. PROGRAM CASH AS A
RESULT OF BOND SALES. AND THAT
HELPS MANAGE THANK CASH FLOW PUT
A PER. SO THIS A HIGH SIXTY TWO
PROJECTS TO FOUR SIXTY THREE
SEVEN MILLION WAITING FOR CASH
FOR BOND SALE. AND THAT'S AGAIN
THE CURRENT UNFUNDED LIST THAT
WE HAVE. WE ALSO HAVE AN
APPLICATION RECEIVED BEYOND
BONTA THIRTY- AND THAT IS A
PROBLEM LISTED. BECAUSE THERE'S
OVER- IF A- MENTIONED POINT
BILLION DOLLARS. A PROJECTS THAT
ARE WAITING FOR FUNDING THESE
PROJECTS ARE ACCEPTED- WHETHER
OFFICE BUT AGAIN WE'RE NOT
PROCESSING THESE APPLICATIONS-
SO IS OVER NINE HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR. PROJECTS THAT REPRESENT
OVER THREE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS AND AGAIN THEY HAVE
EVERY COMPONENT OF THE PROJECT
APPROVAL MEANING THEY HAVE A
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION- APPROVAL.
THE REGISTER ARCHITECT PLAN
APPROVAL BUT WE'RE NOT
PROCESSING THE APPLICATIONS WERE
JUST ACCEPTING THEM SO WITH THAT
IS OUR INFORMATION LIST. AND
AGAIN I'LL JUST QUICKLY
HIGHLIGHT THE FUNDING PROCESS
AGAIN. IT DISTRICT MUST COME AND
WITH A DEPART OF EDUCATION
APPROVAL. AND ALSO DSA-
DIVISIONS THAT ARCHITECT
APPROVAL BEFORE COMING INTO
PROGRAM TO APPLY FOR FUNDS. AND
AGAIN THAT'S THE FIRST STEP OF
THE PROCESS- WE ALSO ESTABLISH
WHETHER NOT THE APPLICANT IS-
MEETS ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
AND THIS CAN BE DONE IN ADVANCE
OR TO YOU THANK. AND THE SECOND
STEP OF THAT PROCESS IS ALSO
SUBMITTED AN APPLICATION WITH
OUR OFFICE. AND THEN THE STARS
IS OUR PROGRAM REVIEWS IT IN
AGAIN. DISCOUNT ACCRETION MORE
FOR. AND THE NEXT STEP IS
BASICALLY TO WAIT FOR. PROGRAM
CASH AS A RESULT THE BOND. SALES
SO WITH THAT- I WOULD TRAVEL.
SHARE MY AND- BY MICHAEL OUR
PROGRAM BACKGROUND WITH MICHAEL
BARBECUE. HOW THEY YOU. MR
O'DONNELL BUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST I JUST WANTED TO
HIGH THE SCHOOL FIRST A THE
STATE CALIFORNIA- THEY ARE A-
AND THERE WAS AN AUDITOR REPORT
JUST A ON THE SCHOOL PROGRAM.
THAT COMPLIMENTED THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAM ALSO
COMPLIMENTED THAT HELPS
DISTRICTS OUT OF HARDSHIP THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT KEPT UP CAN'T
CAN'T TO SECURE THEIR LIVES
CAN'T SECURE LOCAL BONDS OF
LOCAL LEVEL FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS- THE REPORT CITED THAT
THERE WELL OVER SEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS SEVEN POINT
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN IN
IN IN IN SKIN SCHOOL NEEDS ON
THE MODERNIZATION FRONT. AND
THERE IS ALSO- NEED ON THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION FRONT AND- SCHOOL
SCHOOL FACILITIES ACTUALLY
IMPACT THE HOUSE THE COST OF
HOUSING AS WELL BECAUSE IF
THEY'RE NOT SCHOOL BONDS THE
FEES ASSOCIATED WITH NEW SCHOOLS
ARE PUT ON- EVERY INDIVIDUAL
HOUSE THAT IS BUILT AND THAT IS
A LOT OF MONEY SO THEY DO IMPACT
THE- THE COST OF HOUSING AS
WELL. SO WHAT I LOOK FORWARD TO
IS MORE CONVERSATION- WHETHER IT
BE THROUGH BOND OR AN ALLOCATION
OF WHAT WE HAVE A LOT OF THIS
YEAR- ONE TIME MONEY OUTSIDE OF
NINETY EIGHT FOR SCHOOL
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THAT BACK TO
YOU MISTER CHAIR OKAY. THANK YOU
I JUST WANNA KNOW THE I THINK-
OUR A REALLY- GOOD YOU OF WANT
MONIES. WITH THE WITH THE
SITUATION WE HAVE- WE SHOULD BE
MAKING ADJUSTMENTS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET- OFF OF
CONVERSATIONS ON. THANK YOU
BEGAN- ISSUE AND- WHAT THE
STATE- CANDY CAN'T DO AND SO.
USING ONE TIME MONIES FOR
APPROPRIATE THINGS LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK ARE KEY
AND CERTAINLY SCHOOL FACILITIES
ARE AT THE TOP A LIST I ALSO
HAVE A IMPORTANT PROPOSAL ON THE
HIGHER EDUCATION SIDE FOR
STUDENT HOUSING. WHICH OUR TO
ARE THERE ARE TWO ISSUES THAT WE
PUT IN OUR ASSEMBLY. BLUEPRINT
IN DECEMBER AND THOSE ARE STE
HIGH ON OUR PRIORITY LIST THEY
WERE INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- THAT HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
AND AGAIN THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET SO ARE TURNED UP. BUT OUR
FINGERPRINTS ON THIS WE ALSO
NOTE THAT WE THINK THERE-
BECAUSE OF THE REVENUE ESTIMATES
FROM THE L. A. L. THAT THEY WORK
PROPERLY- THE CALIFORNIA JANUARY
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL AS WELL AS
INCREASES COMING IN SINCE THEN
SO WE THINK WE'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. WITH ONE TIME MONEY
TO ADDRESS BOTH THESE ISSUES-
BUT I CAN KERN WE NEED TO
ADDRESS BOTH NEW CONSTRUCTION
AND- MODERNIZATION ESPECIALLY AS
WE- LOOK AT CHANGING LANDSCAPE
OF OUR SCHOOLS AND THE
ATTENDANCE WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER. THIS IS. BECAUSE OR
COMMENTS SAYING NINE FIFTY
NUMBER. SPECIAL EDUCATION
FINANCE. HI GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS- CAN YOU ALRIGHT. YEAH.
BUT THE FINANCE. YES MANY HERE
YOU GO AHEAD THANKS FOR YOUR- AS
MANY IN THE FIELD HAVE BEEN
SAYING FOR YEARS THAT I CAN
SENSE OUR GENERAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS FIRST. AND THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION INVESTMENT IN THIS
YEAR'S- BUDGET CONTINUES THE
ADMINISTRATION AND EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR SYSTEMS ARE
INTEGRATED IN THE ALLEYS
APPROACH PLANNING FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND GREATER
ALIGNMENT WHAT THEY'RE PLANNING
FOR ALL OF THEIR STUDENTS. AND
THIS YEAR'S PROPOSALS WERE
DEVELOPED BOTH AND ATTENTION TO
THE CHALLENGES THAT ELLIE IS
CONTINUE TO NAVIGATE AND COPE
IT. AND TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
THE SYSTEM. SERVING STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES. SO THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACTING NO
INCREASES IN RESOURCES AND
SUPPORTED PROGRAMMATIC
IMPROVEMENTS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. SO TO BUILD UPON
BECAUSE INVESTMENTS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PREVENT
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. A PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION BASE FUNDING
AND IN ADDITION TO THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
INCLUDED FOR GROWTH IN COLOR.
AND JUST FOR REFERENCE THAT.
INCREASE WOULD. HOW TO. TWENTY
DOLLARS PER EIGHTY AT. IN
ADDITION TO FUNDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUSINESS TO
CALCULATE SPECIAL EDUCATION BASE
FUNDING- ALLOCATE AT THE ALLEY
IT LEVEL RATHER THAN ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION LOCAL PLAN AREA OR
SELF LEVEL AND- THIS WOULD
PROVIDE TRAINS IMPROVE LED IS
ABILITY TO PROTECT THEIR FUNDING
. AND SUPPORT LEN EFFORTS AND
COPPER PROGRAM PLANNING
ADDITIONALLY IT BEST BETTER
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE EIGHTY
EIGHT FOUR OF EARLY EIGHTIES
WHEN CALCULATING THE BASE
FUNDING AND FUNDING WILL STILL
CONTINUE TO FLOW TO SELF AS- THE
- ALSO. TO CONSOLIDATE TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION EXTRAORDINARY
COPS PULLS INTO A SINGLE COST
POOL TO STREAMLINE THE CURRENT
FUNDING STRUCTURE. THIS IS
INTENDED TO PURELY BE A
TECHNICAL CHANGE SO NO
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES ARE BEING
PROPOSED. AND THE BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES TO ALLOCATE THE
EDUCATIONALLY RELATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OR ARMS FUNDING
DIRECTLY TO ELLIE IS RATHER THAN
TO SOUTH AS- SO ALL OTHER FRONT.
ENTRANCE IT'S FOR DIRECTLY TO.
AS WAS FLEX IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
BENEFIT ALL STUDENTS SO THIS IS
CLEAN UP TO ALIGN YOUR
PREPARATION TO HOW ALL OTHER
UNRESTRICTED. TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL FUNDS DOESN'T
PROHIBIT THE POOLING OF
RESOURCES INTO REGIONAL SERVICES
AND SMALL ONLY A IS ALREADY WORK
WITH THEIR COUNTY IS TO OBTAIN
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS SO THE
SHIP DOES NOT DISRUPT THOSE PRE
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS. I DON'T
RESPONSIBILITY COMES FROM THE
FIELD FOR MORE COORDINATION
BETWEEN SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
GENERAL EDUCATION PLANNING THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
DEVELOP A SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
UP TO THE L. CAP THAT WOULD
SUPPORT INCLUSIVE PLANNING AND
PROMOTE COHESION BY LINKING
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND GENERAL
EDUCATION OKAY PLANNING. THE
DESIGN AND DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
AGENDA IS INTENDED TO MERE THE
PROCESS THAT CD IN S. B. E. HAS
USED IN THE PAST SUCH AS FOR
BUDGET AS FOR THE BUDGET
OVERVIEW FOR PARENTS- THE BUDGET
ALSO PROPOSES TO MODIFY EXISTING
ALCOTT PARENT ADVISORY GROUP
REQUIREMENTS TO EXPLICITLY
INCLUDE PARENTS OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. THE BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES TO REFOCUS AND EXIST
SPECIAL EDUCATION RESOURCE LEAD
ON A. P. BEST PRACTICES IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND ESTABLISH AN EXPERT PANEL
USING TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND- ID A
FUNDS TO CONTINUE REFINING THE
MODEL A. P. TEMPLATE THAT WAS
DEVELOPED AS PART OF THE RECENT
WORKGROUP CONVENED BY. THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. THE BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES TO BUILD UPON THE
ALTERNATE PATHWAYS TO DIPLOMA
WORK GROUP'S EFFORT BY.
EXPLORING ALTERNATIVE COURSE
WORK OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES TO DEMONSTRATE
COMPLETION OF THE STATE
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS. IN THIS
WOULD USE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
IDA FUNDS AND- SALAS SHE GAVE.
PALATABLE FOR STUDENTS TO TAKE
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATE
ASSESSMENT. AND THOUGHT I
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT
THE TIME OKAY THANK YOU WE'RE
HERE FROM ELIA. IN THE LEAD WITH
ALLIE- AGAIN- SINCE THERE ARE
MULTIPLE PROPOSALS UNDER THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION ITEM I WILL
JUST WALK THROUGH THE ALEJO
COMMENTS FOR EACH OF THESE
PROPOSAL STARTING ON PAGE TWENTY
FIVE OF YOUR AGENDA. SO FIRST WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED THE PROPOSED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR BASE
AUGMENTATION WE THINK THIS IS A
PRUDENT WAY DISPENSED TO
INCREASE POP NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING AND ADDRESS THE LOCAL
COST PRESSURES- THAT HAVE BEEN.
RELATED TO SPECIAL GROWING
SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS. NOW
TURNING TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO MODIFY THE BASE RATE
FORMULA SO IN THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD CALCULATE ATTENDANCE AT
THE ALLEY A LEVEL RATHER THAN
THE TOP LEVEL JUST AS A REMINDER
SELFIES OR SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLAN AREAS ARE REGIONAL
CONSORTIA OF LEDS THAT
COORDINATES SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES. AND FUNDING WHAT'S
TYPICALLY A LARGE DISTRICTS
ACTING AS THEIR OWN SELF THAT WE
THINK THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
QUESTION TO THE SOUTHWEST AT ALL
HAVE A GOOD MIX OF BOTH GROWING
AND DECLINING. LIAISE SO JUST
WALK A LITTLE BIT MORE UNDER
CURRENT LAW A MEMBER DISTRICT
WITH GROWING ATTENDANCE COULD
HAVE THEIR GAINS OFFSET BY
ANOTHER MEMBER DISTRICTS WITH
DECLINING ATTENDANCE IN CONTRAST
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ALLOWS
ANY ALLEY ATTENDANCE GROWTH TO
ESSENTIALLY BE LOCKED IN AT THE
ALLEY A LEVEL. AND THAT GROWTH
WOULD GENERATE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING EVEN IF THE SOFTWARE IS
OVERALL DECLINING ENROLLMENTS-
SO NEXT WE MOVE ON TO THE
PROPOSED ACTIVITIES RELATED TO
THE I. E. P. TEMPLATE THAT
ALTERNATE PATHWAY TO A TO
COMMENT- WE FIND THAT THESE
PROPOSALS LACKS SPECIFIC
TIMELINES AND EXPECTATIONS. FOR
INSTANCE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
DOESN'T SPECIFY A DATE BY WHICH
THE ALTERNATE COURSE WORK OR
ACTIVITIES MUST BE FINALIZED OR
BE MADE AVAILABLE TO TEACHERS.
SINCE OUR SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE
BE INTERESTED IN FINDING THESE
ACTIVITIES WE RECOMMEND IT
SPECIFY CLEAR DEADLINES AS WELL
AS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO
HELP THE LEGISLATURE MONITORING
OUTCOMES OF THESE ACTIVITIES.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO.
CONSIDER SETTING X. WAS IT
DEADLINES THE STATE TO ADOPT. A
STATEWIDE I TEN OR A PATHWAYS IF
THE- LIGHTLY. IS IN EMPLOYMENT
THESE POWER. MOVING ON NEXT TO
THE POOL TO ALLOCATE A MAN
HEALTH TO. RATHER THAN SOME AS-
WE JUST LET LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
IN OF THE PROPOSAL EXPRESSED HOW
IT MAY AFFECT REGIONALLY
COORDINATED PROGRAMS AND SCHOOL
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
PARTNERSHIPS ALTHOUGH SOME
SELFIES ALLOCATE MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDS DIRECTLY TO THE MEMBER AND
- SOME SUPPLIES. ESPECIALLY
THOSE WITH SMALLER LEDS ROUTINE
AND THIS FINDING OUT THE SAMPLE
LEVEL AND PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ON BEHALF OF ALL OF THE
ALLEGATIONS IN THESE CASES THE
MEMBER ELOISE MIGHT TYPICALLY
JUST BE TOO SMALL AND WOULD NOT
RECEIVE SIGNIFICANT FUNDING TO
HIRE THEIR OWN MENTAL HEALTH
STAFF AND PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ON THEIR OWN. THIS
HOLES COULD ALSO IMPACT SCHOOL
MEANT HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS WHICH
THE STATE HAS BEEN ENCOURAGING
IN THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS
UNDER THESE PARTNERSHIPS IZAPA
FOR EXAMPLE COULD DIRECT MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDING DIRECTLY TO THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
WHICH THEN PROVIDES MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO SCHOOL IN
SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY
THIS PROPOSAL COULD POSE SOME
CHALLENGES FOR THESE
PARTNERSHIPS MAKING THESE
PROGRAMS MORE ADMINISTRATIVELY
BURDENSOME SINCE COUNTIES WITH
ANY TO ARRANGE SEPARATE
AGREEMENTS WITH EACH ALLOCATE TO
PARTICIPATE OR POTENTIALLY
REDUCE TOTAL FUNDING AVAILABLE.
IF AN ALLEY GATE DECIDES TO PULL
FUNDING FROM THE PARTNERSHIP IF
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN INSTANCE
ADMINISTRATIVE CAPACITY TO
CONTINUE THESE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE COUNTY THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO EXPLORE THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH THE-
PROPOSAL AND I DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THESE BENEFITS OUTWEIGH
THE POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO THESE
REGIONAL PROGRAMS AND PARTNERS.
NOW IT'S TURNING OUT TO EXTRA
COST POOL- AS FINANCING I THINK
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SEEMS
KIND OF CONSISTENT WITH HOW
CURRENT LAW OPERATES- LAST THREE
WE WANT EXTRAS THAT WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSALS TO
DEVELOP THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
ATTENDANT TO THE OIL CAP OR
ESTABLISHED IP BEST PRACTICES WE
SOURCE WE- I'M A LOT OF PROPOSAL
WE DO KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ME. JUST WANT TO REQUIRE IF THEY
NEED RESOURCE REPEAT IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE STATE WHY IP
TEMPLATE TO ENSURE THAT. ANY
STATEWIDE NICHOLAS TO THE STATE
ON I PIECE IS GOING TO WITH THAT
FOR IP TEMPLATE. I'M THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT HAPPY
ANSWER ANY AT THE- TIME THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. VERY NICE.
IN BEHALF OF THE STATE SUPER- WE
APPRECIATE THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE RELEASE OF THE TRAILER BILL
AND FURTHER DETAILS OF THE
PROPOSALS THIS YEAR'S PROPOSALS
ALLOW FOR INCREASED
COLLABORATION AND TRANSPARENCY
AT ALL LEVELS OF OUR SYSTEM
ESPECIALLY BETWEEN CVD SILVA AND
ALLEGHENY THE PROPOSED FUNDING
PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK FOR
ENSURING THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS AND AT THE CENTER ARE
AT THE CENTER OF OUR WORK.
SPECIFICALLY WELL THE PROPOSED
CHANGE TO CALCULATE FUNDING AT
THE ONLY A LEVEL RATHER THAN
SELF LEVEL WITH FOSTER INCREASED
COLLABORATION AND TRANSPARENCY
BETWEEN SILVA AND THEIR MEMBER
ELLIE ACE THE LEDS THIS
INCREASED LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY
CREATES A GREATER LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH WE WILL
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
ITS CITY. IF THE MENTAL HEALTH
WILL THE L. A. WITH THE MY
DIRECTLY. THIS DOES NOT RESIST
ELEAZAR TO ENTER INTO A REGIONAL
AGREEMENTS TO PROVIDE SERVICES
AND IT ALSO ALLOWS THEM THE
FLEXIBILITY TO MEET THEIR OWN
NEEDS AND COORDINATE ACROSS
STUDENT POPULATIONS- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON THESE PROPOSALS
MOVING FORWARD AND I HAVE WITH
ME HAVE A CALUMNIES THE DIRECTOR
OF THE SPECIAL EDUCATION AT THE
DEPARTMENT- TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY NO QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU FOR THE-
PRESENTATION. OKAY. I KNOW YOU
ASKED EARLIER ABOUT THE- ABOUT
SPECIAL ED SO THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT WE WILL TAKE A LOOK AT AND
SEE WHAT'S BEEN THAT MAY REVISED
AND POTENTIALLY LOOK FOR ANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR. ASSEMBLY
ACTION AS WELL. YES MR BY
ADDRESS. SO THE STATE KERN
PROVIDE A TOTAL SIX MILLION TO
REMEMBER SELFLESS FOR HIGH COST
STUDENT SERVICES AND PLACEMENTS
- AND THE CURRENT ALLOCATION IS
ESTIMATED TO COVER ONLY ABOUT
TWENTY ONE CENTS ON THE DOLLAR
FOR ELIGIBLE COST IS THE
MINISTRATION OF OPEN TO
INCREASING THE FUNDING PROVIDED
TO COVER THESE EXTORT
EXTRAORDINARY SPECIAL EDUCATION
COSTS INVESTING IN A TWENTY FIVE
TO THIRTY MILLION WOULD REALLY
GO A LONG WAY I THINK TO THREE
SMOOTHING OUT THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING FOR SELFLESS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BECAUSE
OPEN TO THE- SO- IN THE PAST
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE BEEN CONCERNED
ABOUT ENSURING PLACEMENTS INTO
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. SO AT THIS TIME WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT PUTTING MORE
MONEY INTO THIS COST POOL WOULD
INCENTIVIZE PLACEMENTS INTO MORE
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENTS HOWEVER
AT LAST YEAR'S BUDGET DID
INCLUDE A STEP HE- ON THE
PLACEMENT AND- PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND AGENCIES SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE
OUTCOMES OF OUR STUDENTS IN
THOSE PLACEMENTS. WHEN THE
REPORT COMES OUT IN TWENTY
THREE. OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS. CAN LET ISSUED NO TO
PAY CM. WE HAVE TRAFFIC MATH
AND ART- IN YOUR PRESENTATION
FOR MR FINE. IN ORDER TO FIRST
LEADER- MICHAEL CHIEF JUSTICE
OFFICER OF THE STATE STREET
CRISIS MANAGED ASSISTANCE TEAM I
NOT FOR ME AND I WILL CALL THIS
LAW IT SHOULD. HOPE WE SHOULD BE
SHUT RAPIDLY. FIRST LIGHTING
PRODUCT ARE YOU CAN TO THE
SLIGHT MORE ARE STORED. IN
NINETY CATIONS. OUR PORTLAND
KEEP IT MIND WITH THE LAST THREE
SO A BAR. TWENTY TWENTY ONE. YES
WHICH WOULD BE FROM. A YEAR AGO
DECISION ARE BUT. TWO YOU CAN
SHIP IT FIFTY TWO YOU QUALIFY
JUST WOULD NAKED. FOR CLASS
TWENTY ONE ONE DASH THAT COULD.
ALL JUST INTO NEEDED THAT.
DECREASE ONCE IT RESULT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S FOR PROPOSAL A YEAR
IN JANUARY OF. TWO ONE. IT BACK
TO THE START OF THE ANNUAL CYCLE
REMEMBER THAT DISTRICT'S THE
BUDGET TO THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT SORTED WITH CVD-
ON JULY ONE IS YOUR BAG GREETED-
BODY. MID SEPTEMBER AND
ACCOUNTING SUPERINTENDENT MAKES
AN- TO UP. ALL APPROVAL CAN. OR
WITH BUDGET. THIS PAST SEPTEMBER
WE HAD JUST FOR LAWSON COUNTY-
THAT THE PLUMBING. APPROVE
SUBSEQUENT TO WELL BUDGETS WERE
APPROVED AFTER CORRECT ACTION
WAS TAKEN. THE REPORT ON FIVE
WOULD BE A LOOK AT THIS. RECENT
DECEMBERS ARE FIRST ENORMOUS IN
THE ARE DISTRICTS ANOTHER MOMENT
AGO. YOU THREE DISTRICT- TWENTY.
I'M SORRY EIGHTEEN OF THE TWENTY
THIS BE THEIR- QUALITY. REPORT
BOB WITH WHAT IT CAN- IT WE CAN
SERVING IT MAY HAVE QUALIFIED
FOR IN THE PAST. BUT IT IS NOT A
COULD SECOND QUALIFIED. IN YOUR
COUNTY AND ONE WITH THE BUCKLEY
THAT COULD BE QUALIFIED REPORTS
THIS WILL BE ALL CLEANED ON
FINDING OUT WE WERE TALKING.
ABOUT THE MAJORITY OF THE
QUALIFIED- DISTRICTS ARE WHICH
IS THEIR FIRST LOOK WE WILL TALK
ABOUT THE COMMON TRENDS. AMONG
THOSE IN JUST A MOMENT. WHICH
YOU DO NOT THE SIDE SIX AND
LOOKING NEGATIVE IN OUR REPORTS
ARE. WOULD NOT THREE NAY SELF.
NEGATIVE. ALL THE CERTIFICATIONS
THIS DECEMBER. BUT EAST ARE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE CHAU THEIR
SONG OF STRESS. USE ALL HAVE A
DISTRICT SHOP ON THE WAY FOR
RADARS FOR THE FIRST AS THANK.
BURKE JUST WEST COSTA. BOB AND
BEEN IN WITH MY WORK WITH THAT
AND THEN MAKE BREAK PROGRESS.
TOWARDS TWENTY THE CORNER. BACK
POLICY STAFF. YEAH TO LOOK. FOR
OUR SMALL DISTRICTS ONE SMALL
LEADER THE MAIN ELEMENT JUST OF
HUNDRED. STREAM COUNTY BEGINNING
WITH THE SINCE THE END OF OUR-
WE HAD AFTER OCTOBER PAYROLL-
THEY HAVE BEEN SUFFICIENT CASH.
GEN THAT'S TEMPORARY LONG ARE
BEEN ABLE TO PUT THAT OFF AND WE
WORK WITH WITH. AND THE COUNTY
IS THAT PARK AND YOU WORKING
WITH THE DISTRICT. CHIEF YOU ARE
I JUST THOUGHT FOR. BUT IT JUST
THERE ARE. GOING WE DO HAVE-
THAT ONE THAT PROGRESS SHOULD-
DEPARTURE BEING MADE BOB ALONG
WITH. SCOREBOARD HE IS- IN
CHESAPEAKE TICKET ACTION ON
RECOVERY PLAN ON WORD- AND IT
WILL REQUIRE MEDIA.
IMPLEMENTATION ONE OF. NEGATIVE-
INCIDENTS HAPPEN CA SMALL
DISTRICT ALBERTA- ELEMENTARY
JUST. ISSUED THERE ARE WE HAVE
YET. IN- BUT WOULD BE SURE- THAT
RESIDE THERE SOME. IS THE BIG OF
A DEPENDENT CHARTERS OPEN AT THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS THANK YOU. IN
THEIR HAS WHAT THE DISTRICT HERE
. BOB BECAUSE ITS OWN. DISTRICTS
OFTEN ALSO DE SPENDING WITHOUT
RESERVE YEAH SPENDING- OBVIOUSLY
PUT AND END UP CARRIAGES TO THIS
- WHICH IS WHY THEY ARE. TO
DECEMBER WILL BE ENGAGING AS
CHART. IT IS INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY THREE QUALIFY. BOB
DISPATCHES WITH CALAVERAS.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CALAVERAS COUNTY- THEY TOOK
ACTION AFTER THE ADOPTION OF THE
WHICH THE NUMBER OF PORTS IN. A
PREVIOUS COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
THE RAIN THAT- THAT HAD NOT BEEN
INCLUDED IN THE FIRST ECONOMIC
AND COST MORE THAN THEIR
ORIGINAL COST TO MUCH WORK BUT-
WE HAVE EVERY. REASON TO GLOAT
IT WILL TAKE CORRECTIVE ACTION-
IN THE SHORT TERM. SLIDE EIGHT.
THIS IS NOT OPTION FOR COUNTIES
WILL BE HALF WAIT UNTIL FIRST
NUMBER SECOND REPORT AT ANY TIME
THE SCHOOL YEAR DATE COULD
DESCRIPTIVE COMPLETE SIR. AWAY
IS STOPPING ABOUT ISSUE IT'S NOT
FALL- BASICALLY UP THROUGH-
EARLY DECEMBER WE A LOT BEEN
JUST. DESIGNATED A LOT QUICKER
COULD SEE. ABOUT IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE YOU CAN SEE HONEST THERE
ARE TWO- GET THAT ACTIVITY GOOD
NIGHT TO. DIMINISH DOUBLE OVER
THE WHOLE COURSE A FULL FISCAL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- BUT IN TWENTY
ONE TO TWO WE ELEVEN WORLD
HALFWAY THROUGH THE SCHOOL YEAR.
OTHERS A PRIVATE BUDGET AND NOT
BUDGETARY REASONS FOR THE SOCCER
PRACTICE. AN EXAMPLE A NON
BUDGETARY WOULD BE- JOURNAL
CONTROL ISSUE- GRADING OF COURSE
. A LACK OF WITH AND DATA WITH
THE TONGUES. OF THE COUNTY'S.
GOT DARK- OUT OF HER WAY TO
DISPUTE STANDS FIRST OF. EXAMPLE
ARE IN SOME CASES WHAT COULD
CONCERN. IS THAT ALTER TO THE
DISTRICT BY TO PROVIDE DISTRICT
ADDITIONAL TO A DOCTOR ACTION.
NOW TO SPEAK ON SLIDE NINE OF
OUTLINED SOME OF THE KEY TRENDS
THAT WE SEE ACROSS W. IS OUT
RIGHT NOW- MULTI YEAR
PROJECTIONS ARE DUE TO SHELVE
DEFICIT TRANS REMIND YOU ALL DID
A DISTRICT- WHEN IT DROPS ITS
CURRENT BUDGET MUST ALSO LOOK AT
NOT FOR TWO YEARS ACTUALLY REAR
WINDOW. UNLESS THE DOCTOR A
MULTI YEAR FINANCIAL PROJECTIONS
FOR THE SUBSEQUENT TO COMMUTERS
THE GOVERNOR STANTON BUDGET
PROPOSALS FOR CHEAPER ABOUT THIS
MORNING. PREVIOUSLY WERE FIRST
THIS TRAINING FOR AT LEAST HALF
OF THE QUALIFY DISTRICTS IN ONE
BIG ISSUE BUT AS AN EXAMPLE IN
WEST CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED BOB
YOU GET A PERSONAL REPORT IT
MADE SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS. ON
THEIR- BEING CLOSING THAT GAP
BUDGET CORRECTIVE ACTION AND
PLANNING FOR DIGITAL CORRECTIVE
ACTION THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
FALL WITH WITH RESPECT TO COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT SPECIAL
THAT THE AND THE GOVERNOR'S.
EIGHTY PROPOSAL- ALL POSITIVELY
IMPACT THIS JUST TO THE POINT IT
WILL CLOSE THE REMAIN GAP.
POSSIBLE POLICY- EQUITATION
SEVEN HALF GOING SOME DEEP. AS
UPLOAD TO THE PROPOSED IF YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS EARLIER AND- IT
WILL TO SOME THE IMPORTANT. S.
ABOUT EIGHT POSSIBLE. THE MOST
FREQUENT OF CALL IS ENROLLMENT.
AND I WOULD HAVE TO THAT.
ATTENDANCE RATES THE GO TO BE
WITH THE PART OF THAT SPOKE AT
THE ONLY HELP SPOKE TO THE-
DECLINING RAW IS NOT A NEW CAR
WOULD BE DEALING WITH PROBLEM
TWO DECADES. SPORTS TO GROW NOW
TO WITH THE FOR THE NOT TO AND A
HALF TO THREE PACKAGE. OF
SEARCHING NEW- BUT IT IS CLEAR
US DURING THE- WE HAVE X. THE
RATE UP TO. SAID OF THE GRAY.
DECLINE IT SOME. AND WE'VE ALL
HEARD. OF THAT ARE WE- UP
SCHOOLS REPORTS WITH REGARD TO
DECREASE THE TEN RATES ARE SPACE
THIS YEAR SPECIFIC. RELATED YOU
I'M APPS. WE ALSO SEE OUT YOU'RE
- AROUND EXPIRED ONE TIME FUNDS
WHICH SPECTER SITUATION BE
TEMPORARY ONLY IT SHOULD BE
DISTRICTS YOU- HAVE HIRED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES OR SOMEHOW
REPORT TO SHOW RESOURCES- TO
ADDRESS LONG LOSS MITIGATION AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
SUPPORTS AS THE- AS THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED THEM TO DO.
WITH HOME RUN YOU ONE TIME
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDS- BUT WE
HAVE BOUGHT YEAH THEY'RE SHOWING
THE EXPIRATION OF THOSE FUNDS IN
THERE OUT YOUR PROJECTIONS. NOT
YET SHOWING THE DECREASING COSTS
FIVE- ALTERNATELY- ARE SHUTTING
THOSE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. THAT
BROUGHT ON BOARD- AND SO OUR
COURAGE MEANT TO GAMBIANS TO THE
DOCTOR XCEPT WHEN AND HOW MANY
GOING TO ULTIMATELY A JOB THEIR
OPERATIONS. WOULD. BE A
RECURRING. THAT WOULD BE ONE
ISSUE AND BEING A LEADER UNION
ELEMENTARY DISTRICT RECALL
HUMBOLDT- WHERE DID Y'ALL NEED
TO. REDUCE THE ADDITIONAL STAFF
ALMOST TWELVE YEARS SB SIX STAFF
MEMBERS. BOB THIS YEAR- WITH
RESPONSE TIME RESOURCES THE ONLY
EXPECTED WE WILL AT ALL EXTENDED. FROM ONE YEAR. THE NEW YORK
ANSWER PEOPLE THIS ISSUE UP
ALREADY- COMMENTS THE MORNING
ABOUT AN HE CHRIS GET COCKAPOO
RATE POSSIBLE SHOULD POP- THIS
IS CLEARLY A ISSUE THAT- ARE
FACED WITH THE IN. INCLUDING
NETWORKING. THE RATE- RETURNING
THE TWO YEAR RATE CALLED RIGHT
IN QUALITY ROLL BACK BUT WE'VE
SEEN THE PLAN. IN STYLE STYLE
STIRS TO BE EXPECTED OUR O. 2%
INCREASE- GOING EACH YEAR TO THE
NEXT YEAR. WE ALL ARE EXPERIENCE
YOU CAN NEVER DO A ARE PUSH
LIVES AND SCHOOL DISTRICT NOT
SECTION BECAUSE- RECEDING
INFLATIONARY PRESSURES ON COSTS
. YOU HIDING. OUR FOOD IS- SO
COSTS REQUIRED- GOOD SHOULD
SERVICES THAT SCHOOL BY ARE. YOU
COSTS. FOR MANY OTHER
RECEIVERSHIP- IT WAS A GRADUATE
DECLINING SCALE- ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AND
WORK IN THE LAST YEAR ABOUT
FUNDING RIGHT NOW YOU COULD SEE
WHAT SCREEN FUNDING HAS BEEN.
EAGLE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
DID NOT REQUIRED I'LL BE FOR THE
NATION- IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO SCHOOL. YEAR- YEAH AND- IT'S
A BASKET. AS THANK YOU DON'T
MEDINA EMPHASIZED THIS SPECIAL
PROPERTY. EXPIRES THIS YEAR- FOR
OF WHICH TO. WE DONT YOU AB ONE
NINE X. AUDITS- ACT FOR US TO
READ IS DOWN DOOR. HOWEVER WE
HAVE ONE LONG AUDIT BECAUSE
COULD WORKING STARTED TO YOU'RE
GONNA AND THAT WOULD BE A USED
CHOCOLATE NETWORK OF THIS IS ALL
A BALL- CHARTERS WITH THIS. OUT
OF DISK. ABOUT HALF OF OUR STATE
THAT ARE TOUCHING. IN SOME
ACTION OR ANOTHER. PROBABLY
SINGLE OUT A SHORT COMMENT WOULD
BE NAPA VALLEY. VERY MUCH LIKE
LOLITA SCHOOL DISTRICT AT THE
END OF OCTOBER AFTER PROCESSING
THE PAYROLL WE HAVE NEGATIVE
CASH YOU HAVE INSUFFICIENT
PASSED TO BE. TO PROCESS PAYROLL
AND OTHER BILLS WE HAD A TV EACH
THAT RAPID HEALTH IT ARE SINCE
THE- AND BIG ARE- YEAH WE COULD
BE PROGRESS- CHIEF. OFFICER THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN RIVER- EIGHT
HUNDRED THANK YOU IN ADDITIONAL
LEADERSHIP. STRUCTURE BUT WE ARE. OUR SYSTEM YEAH BOB BIGGS
CELLS BACK. EIGHT SALAS I GET.
FINANCIALLY VIABLE- YOU KNOW I
TALKED TO YOU EXTENSIVELY LAST
FEARS ABOUT MY OWN SCHOOL
DISTRICT HERE IN SACRAMENTO SAC
CITY AND THEY'RE STILL- ON YOUR
HOW TO WATCH LIST AND THAT OF
COURSE WE KNOW THAT WHEN TIMES
ARE TOUGH FOR- THE NEW THE
NUMBER. OF DISTRICTS ON THIS-
INCREASE THE SHOCKING THAT YOU
KNOW AND TWENTY NOT SHOCKING BUT
YOU KNOW I POPPING THEN IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN ASH. THERE ARE A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
DISTRICTS ON OUR WATCH LIST SO
THAT'S YOU KNOW ALMOST. 35% OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA- BUT JUST IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE HAD FIFTY TWO WHICH IS
NOT INSIGNIFICANT AS WELL AS I
GUESS 5% OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. SO NOW THE LIST IS
CUT IN HALF AND I WOULD THINK
IT'S EVEN MORE SO BECAUSE THIS
IS BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO NUMBERS.
NOW WITH THAT. TWENTY TWO-
TWENTY THREE BUDGET THAT WERE
THAT WERE LOOKING AT- VERY VERY
DIFFERENT AS FAR AS WE SPENT
LAST TWO HOURS TALKING ABOUT.
HISTORIC REP MONIES FOR SCHOOL
THEY SIX GRAND THEY HAVE- COSTS
GOING UP THE MISTER DOMINATED
WITH YOU KNOW. INFLATION AND
HEALTH CARE COSTS RETIREMENT SO
FORTH SO WHERE DO WE THINK
ROUGHLY KIND OF BACK OF THE
ENVELOPE WE'RE AT NOW. WITH YOUR
NUMBER YOU HAVE HERE AND WHERE
WE'RE AT WITH MONEY WITH THIS
YEAR'S PROPOSED BUDGET. WELL AS
I NOTED AT LEAST HALF OF THE
QUALIFY DISTRICTS IN DECEMBER
WILL BE POSITIVE ALL THE NEXT
REPORTS IN MARCH IN ONE OF THE
THREE NEGATIVE DISTRICTS WON'T
LIKELY BE. OSSETT MAYBE QUALIFY
BUT A GOOD CHANCE OF BEING
POSSIBLY BY MARCH AND THAT'S IT-
RESULT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. SPECIFICALLY AROUND HI
COLA AND EIGHTY A- PROTECTION-
AND OBVIOUSLY RICHARD SPECIAL.
THANK OKAY EXCELLENT THANK YOU
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE. YES WAS
THE QUESTION. YES YEAH AND SO ON
THE- ARE EIGHTEEN FORTY PROCESS
WHICH WE UPDATE A COUPLE YEARS
AGO YOU HAVE HERE IN YOUR CHART-
OAKLAND AND THIS POTENTIAL SOME
. WHAT DO WE ANTICIPATE THAT
WILL BE IN LIGHT OF WHERE WE'RE
AT WITH THE STATE BUDGET-
EIGHTEEN THIS IS THE LAST YEAR
ABOUT FUNDING AND SO FORTH WITH
REGARD TO THE- STATE BUDGET
THERE WOULD BE NO. EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE ARE
APPROPRIATE OR EVEN DISTRICT.
OKAY THANK YOU. YEAH MISTER
O'DONNELL I JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT
SOMETHING THAT MISTER MISTER
FIND IT- BUT I JUST WANT TO AND
I THINK I'VE DONE A COUPLE TIMES
TODAY BUT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A
PROPOSED FIVE POINT 3% CALL ON
TO THE BASE. CHINA HAS BEEN
MENTIONED- TO INCREASE IN
HEALTHCARE COSTS. INFLATION AT
4% PLUS. OTHER THAN THE INCREASE
COUNT- CAL STIRS IN PERS. COSTS
TO DISTRICTS- THAT PRETTY MUCH.
ELIMINATES THAT FIVE POINT THREE
PERCENT- A. N. N. D. N. THAT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME. BECAUSE
WE REALLY NEED TO DO HERE IS
ADDED TO THE PACE. NOT ONLY TO
COVER THESE INCREASED COSTS. BUT
ALSO TO COVER THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL CHILDREN- SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
CONVERSATIONS AS WE HEAD THROUGH
THE COMMITTEE PROCESS MISTER
CHAIR. AND AGAIN THANK YOU
MISTER FINE FOR. FOR SHARING
INFORMATION TODAY YES. THANK
YOU. BEFORE WE GET TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT. WELL WE HAVE OUR
MEMBERS HERE I WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- OUR STAFF MEMBER
HERE. FROM THE- REPUBLICAN SIDE
THIS IS HER LAST DAY. AND
CAROLINE. YES RETIRING SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
HONESTLY. YOU ARE THE REPUBLICAN
CONSULTANT BUT YOUR CONSULTANT
TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE. AND
YEAH I THINK IS OUR FIFTH YEAR
WORKING TOGETHER. AND I REALLY
ENJOYED WORKING WITH YOU AND
WE'VE- BEEN COLLABORATIVE IN
THIS BUDGET PROCESS- THAT THEY
JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- SERVICE ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I KNOW
SOMEONE MEMBER BY DORIS WOULD
LIKE TO. JOIN IN AS WELL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CAROLINE FIGURE
SERVICE THIRSTY AND EDUCATION.
MY I HOPE WE'RE NOT LEAVING
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING. I SAID
EVERYTHING. IT'S BEEN YOU KNOW
THIS IS ONE OF MY PRIORITY CAN
YOU KNOW COMING TO THE- ONE. TO
ENSURE THE ALL STATE A COUPLE.
HAVE ACCESS TO FIVE THAT YOU.
I'M FROM CHILD CARE TO TKA
THROUGH TWELVE- AND OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN YOU HAVE BEEN SO
INFLUENTIAL. AND I THINK JUST
REALLY REYES. REP REALLY REYES-
THE BAR IN TERMS OF NOT JUST
GIVING YOUR OR YOUR REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS THE INFORMATION IN THE
QUESTIONS IN THE THOUGHTFULNESS
AS TO WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING-
BUT ALSO WORKING ACROSS THE
AISLE AND ON THIS COMMITTEE AND
YOU'VE JUST DONE GREAT WORK IT'S
GOING TO BE A BIG LOSS THERE ARE
BIG SHOES TO FILL. BUT I JUST
CONGRATULATE YOU IN YOUR
RETIREMENT AND I KNOW YOU YOU
HAVE SOME FUN FOR PLANS TO SPEND
WITH FAMILY. BIG CONGRATULATIONS. CAROLINE THE MIKE IS YOURS
TODAY'S YOUR DAY. I WOULD HEAR
FROM THESE FOLKS ALL THE TIME
FOR YOUR IS THAT WHAT TO HEAR
FROM YOU ON YOUR LAST DAY. THANK
THE PERFORMED WORKING ON. YEAH
OKAY FOR THOSE THAT HE SHOULDN'T
PRESS HER BUTTON OF COURSE BUT
SHE THANKED ALL OF US IN SAID
THIS HAS BEEN AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY AND THAT. AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OKAY SO WITH THAT
LET'S PROCEED WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT. DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
THE AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
YES WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE. YEAH
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MATT
PATTON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE VERY THANKFUL
FOR THE PROPOSED AUGMENTATION OF
THE AG INCENTIVE GRANT SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE THAT I CAN
SEND A GRANT HAS BEEN THE MODEL
FOR CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
INCENTIVE FUNDING THE C. T. I.
G. GRANT IS BASED ON THAT MODEL
WE ARE EXTREMELY APPRECIATIVE OF
THIS THE FIRST PROPOSED
AUGMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM IN
OVER A DECADE AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND STAFF TO INCREASE
THIS AUGMENTATION TO MEET THE
INCREASE AN AGITATION STUDENTS
AND INFLATION OVER THE LAST TEN
PLUS YEARS. THANK YOU. BY
TALKING. GOOD MORNING OUR MARKET
STEAM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL TECHNOLOGY
EDUCATION AT WORK ANALYSTS AT
YOUR NOVEMBER THIRTIETH HEARING
AND A LOT OF AND THEN TODAY AND
ONE OF THE THINGS WITH THE
CHALLENGES CREATED BY DISTANCE
LEARNING THAT I HAVE NOT HEARD
COME UP FOR DISCUSSION IS HOW
MUCH DISTANCE LEARNING HAD
EXPOSED THE DIGITAL SKILLS
DEFICIENCY OF OUR TEACHERS IN
THIS STATE AS WELL AS ACROSS THE
NATION AND TO SOME EXTENT- THE
STUDENTS. FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS
SINCE SERVING AND NASA TASK
FORCE IN ONE AREA TO DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGY I HAVE OBSERVE
SEVERAL STATES THAT ARE PRO
ACTIVE IN WORKING WITH HIM BRING
TO THEIR TEACHERS AND MERGING
DIGITAL SKILL SETS- AND HAVING
THOSE BEING A DE EMBRACE AND
ADOPTED BY SCHOOLS. AND THIS GAP
THAT IS BEGINNING THE GROUT IS
ALSO EVOLVING INTO A WORK FORCE
COMPETITIVE. NEXT ISSUE. PART OF
THE PROBLEM ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN NOTED LATELY IS
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE LEFT
IS BEING SUPERINTENDENT
TRANSFERRING OVER TO TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS. IS THAT
THE EXPECTATIONS FOR DIGITAL
SKILLSETS BOTH FOR TEACHERS AND
ALSO IN A LOT OF THE DISTRICTS
AS FAR AS IF THEY DEAL LOCAL
STANDARDS HAVE NOT REALLY
CHANGED IN TWENTY YEARS. I MEAN
IT'S STILL FOCUSED ON INTERNET
SEARCHES WORD PROCESSING AND
PRESENTATIONS. IN THIS GAP HAS
ITS GREATEST IMPACT ON OUR MOST.
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS MATHIS
ALLEGEDLY HAPPENED WRAP IT UP SO
THANK YOU YEAH IF THIS
LEGISLATURE SPENT AS MUCH
ANATOMIC ENERGY AND EFFORT AS IT
HAD WITH ADOPTING THE ETHNIC
STUDIES- REQUIREMENT WE WOULD
CLOSE THE GAP NOW IF THE CHAIR
WOULD IN BELGIUM MAY I WOULD
LIKE BETH DISCUSSION ON STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT ON A LIKE AYE AYE AYE
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE HERE. SO I
GIVE YOU DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF
TIME OKAY OKAY FIRST HEARING OF
THE EAR BUT YOU COULD ALWAYS
COME BACK- RIGHTIST EMAIL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. OKAY WITH
THAT WE WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE- MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY HERE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE
WE DO HAVE A FEW CUED UP ALREADY
KNOW GET THE INSTRUCTION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TAKE- BOTH FOR AND
AGAINST PUBLIC. YET RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TO PUT EVERYBODY IN THE
SAME LOT AND SO- REMINDER. I
PUBLIC COMMENT- IS ONE MINUTE SO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE
OR LESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AS A
REMINDER ON TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
pGOING TO QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE AND IN PLACE YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WE'LL BEGIN WITH WIDE.
EYED NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS CARE MEMBERS THANK YOU
MADE IT BACK TO BE LOCKED FROM
C. S. T. A. UNION OF EDUCATORS
AND CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS. I
WANT TO THANK. ALL THE MEMBERS
IN THAT CHAIR IN THE FABRIC
THESE- HIGHLIGHTING THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES WE WANT TO ECHO
THE STAFF COMMENT IN THE
NARRATIVES REGARDING BASE
INCREASES. THAT WOULD BE
POSSIBLY NECESSARY TO. ADDRESS
L. A. FUNDING PRESSURES AND ADD
TO THE LIST THAT THIS. IS THE
ISSUE VIEW THAT IT WOULD. ALSO
HELP ADDRESS EDUCATOR AND
CLASSIFIED SHORTAGE. WE THANK
MEMBERS TOOK ECHOED. THE NEED
FOR THIS DISCUSSION AND FOR
INCREASED. FUNDING WE ALSO JUST
WANT TO SAY SIX. I HOPE THAT
INVESTING IN SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION. WE CAN ENSURE THAT
WE ARE USING THE MOST ENERGY
EFFICIENT AND SUSTAINABLE.
EQUIPMENT SO THAT WE CAN CREATE
HEALTHY SAFE ENVIRONMENT. TO
INCREASE THE ACADEMIC GAINS FOR
ALL STUDENTS. THANK. YOU SO MUCH
. THEY YOU LINE TWENTY ONE THE-
THANK SKEWS ME CHAIR I LAW
TWENTY ONE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CAL CHARTER ASSOCIATION-
PREACHING THE DISCUSS TODAY A
LOT OF OUR CHARTERS THAT TO GET
CHALLENGES THAT YEAR THE- MAKRAN
. WHICH IS RESULT IN IN YOU
HAPPEN TO AND LOCKED IN A FUND.
WE GREATLY THE CONVERSATION WE
HAVE HAD WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE ON
INCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOLS IN THE
EXISTING ONGOING HOLD HARMLESS
PROTECTIONS FOR DISTRICTS WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE L. A. AS
RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR PROTECTING
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR WHILE WE CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS A LONGER TERM SOLUTION.
WHEN THE BUDGET WAS NEGOTIATED
LAST YEAR WE DID NOT EXPECT THE
OMICRON SEARCH IN THE IMPACT IT
WOULD HAVE ON CURRENT YEAR
EIGHTY EIGHT. THEREFORE WE
BELIEVE IS CRITICAL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION ADOPT
TEMPORARY JUDGMENT FOR PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS. TO PROTECT
AGAINST THE SIGNIFICANT CURRENT
YEAR EIGHTY A LOT THERE. FINALLY
WHAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN- THE
TRAILER BILL WE BELIEVE PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS NEED TO BE
INCLUDED EQUITABLY AND ANY DO
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION FOR
SCHOOL FACILITY CONSTRUCTION.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN NEW DEMANDS FOR
TKO PENSION IN FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT BAKER PLEASE FILL THE
LITTLE. THANK YOU ONE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SERRA BATCHES OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BUSINESS
PROFESSIONALS APPRECIATE TODAY'S
DISCUSSION AS WE LOOK BEYOND THE
PANDEMIC THE TIME IS RIGHT TO
PROVIDE SUSTAINABILITY AND
STABILITY TO ENSURE THAT OUR
EDUCATIONAL STAFF. CAN BUILD UP
AND RETAIN THE CURRENT PIPELINE
THAT WE COULD REALLY HONE IN ON
BUILDING OUT P. K. COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS ARE TYPICALLY
TRADITIONAL SERVICES FOR THE
ENTIRE ACADEMIC CAREER OF OUR
STUDENTS WE ENCOURAGE CONTINUED
DISCUSSIONS TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE THE CRITICAL BASED GRANT
SUPPORT TO MEET THESE AFTER.
ENTERING SHOW THAT WE CAN A
DRAFT ON GOING RISING COSTS AND
TO SUPPORT OR STOP THE A
COMPENSATION RETENTION POLICIES
TO ENSURE. HEALTHY WORKING
ENVIRONMENTS THANK YOU. BY A
THIRTY FOUR CALL. HI KATIE
HARDIN AT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND EPA
PREDATE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ON DECLINING ENROLLMENT HOWEVER
AND IT DOESN'T ADDRESS AT
INCREASE ABSENCES DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION. TO ENSURE
SCHOOLS AREN'T PENALIZED FOR
BEING INFECTED WITH WHAT AT KOBE
WE ALSO APPRECIATE MANY OF THE
COMMENTERS THE LEGISLATURE TO
PRIORITIZE I'M GOING FUNDING FOR
THE LPS FAST AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND TO BUY
DOWN SO THAT YOU CAN GENERATE.
THE REPORT TO WORKING. WITH YOU
ALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU LIKE
THE FOR YOUR OPEN. THANK YOU
ASSURE FORTY FOUR PLEASE CALL-
YEAH MORNING HI NAME AQI RICH
CHECK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING ASSOCIATION
I WANTED TO- REGISTER TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE JANUARY BUDGET
THAT AUTHORIZES THE ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION AND THE REMAINING
PROP FIFTY ONE TAKEN TWELVE.
SCHOOL BOND FUND ALLOCATION AND
THE ADDITIONAL TWO POINT ONE
SEVEN FIVE BILLION IN THE ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND MONEY FOR
SCHOOL THE FILM. SCHOOL
FACILITIES HOWEVER WERE ALSO
REQUESTING THAT THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES FUNDING BE INCREASED
GIVEN THE GREAT NEED AND GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY PERSIAN-
THAT INCLUDED THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS
BAKER PLEASE. THANK YOU I FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHEN ACCORDION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FIFTY HOW I'LL ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
CALLING TO SUPPORT THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION. WELL WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED INVESTMENT WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT SOME DISTRICTS
OVER CPR SPECIAL EDUCATION
DOLLARS NEXT YEAR AT THIS YEAR'S
ONE TIME COULD REALLY FIND THE
RUMOR. THE LEGISLATURE BUT THEN
THAT NO ALL THE AGES SIXTY
SPECIALTY DOLLARS TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE WITH A MODEST
INCREASE FROM EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY PER ADA WORKBOOK
PORTABLE CATCH ON. THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU. THANKS BAKER. Q. ONE
FOURTEEN GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS DR PETRUS WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR USE I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A ONE TIME
BUDGET AUGMENTATION OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO BETTER SERVE
PUBLIC STUDENTS BY ADOPTING THE
HOMELESS EDUCATION ACCESS
RESOURCES AND TRAINING OR HEART
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION RAMOS HOME
WITH STUDENTS FOR MINOR CHILDREN
LIVING WITH THEIR PARENTS NEARLY
EIGHT THOUSAND ARE UNACCOMPANIED
HOMELESS YOUTH AND THE GRAVITY
OF THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES DEMANDS
ADDITIONAL STATE INVESTMENT WE
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE AN ONGOING FUNDING
AUGMENTATION OF SIXTY MILLION
FOR MODIFY THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA TO BETTER SERVE
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS STUDENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. MY TWENTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PANEL AGAINST
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION A
DIFFICULT QUICK ITEMS- BUT I'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS TODAY AND THEN
FOLLOW UP WITH OUR BUDGET MATTER
. FIRST OF ALL ON THE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTIONS UNDER
ISSUE NUMBER ONE WE APPRECIATE
THE PREVIOUS FUNDING TO REDUCE
THAT PALLISTER'S EMPLOYER RATE
EIGHTEEN POINT 41% APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN POINT 15% AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THE
SUBSEQUENT- CHANGES IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
WELL WE KNOW THERE ARE TECHNICAL
MECHANISMS OF THE UNFUNDED
ACTUARIAL OBLIGATIONS WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL'S QUESTIONS AND-
INPUT. ON THE SAME ISSUE OF
POLICY ANALYSIS ON PAGE NINE- OF
YOUR AGENDA TODAY TO THAT END
WHICH PROBABLY ORIGINATED
MINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO REDUCE THE
CAL STAR THAN PLAYER RATE IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
STATE BUDGET. ACTION WOULD HELP
ALL L. E. A. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN RETURN OBLIGATION AS
MOMENTUM. THROUGHOUT AT THE
PANDEMIC IN ADDITION. PREACHING
A BIT MINUTES AND LEGISLATE
SUPPORT ACCOUNT MAKE VERY EARLY
TO EDUCATION. AND LOST BUDGET
PROVIDE THAT OTHER ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES MAY CONTINUE TO ACCESS
. HEADS TO PROGRAM IN STATE
PROGRAMS TO THAT END AND THIS
WAS ON IT SHOULD NOT TWO. WE
JUST FOR MILLION DOLLARS. IN THE
TO TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE STATES
THAT PROGRAM. TO ENSURE A
VEHICLE PROGRAM COMPLETE TO BE
MORE. AND- EARLY HEADS HEAD
START MY- AND HEAD AND AMERICAN
AGAIN BUT PROGRAM- WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF OTHER AYE WE WANT TO
WITH YOU WILL FOLLOW UP IN ARMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS FOR
YOUR WORK. LOOK FOR TO WORKING
YOU IN THE COMING. THANK YOU
BAKER PLEASE. WHY FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT GOOD
MORNING- CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS BACHOCO IN A BEHALF OF
CHILDREN I WOULD LIKE TO THE
LATEST THAT- TO AND IN YOU TO
ADDRESS TWO ISSUES RELATIVE TO
DECLINING ENROLLMENT THAT HAD
YET RECEIVED ADEQUATE ATTENTION-
IN THE CONVERSATION TO DATE THE
FIRST OF WHICH IS THE- DYNAMIC-
AND POTENTIAL DISINCENTIVE FOR
DISTRICTS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
DECLINING ENROLLMENT TO. BEGIN
IMPLEMENTATION OF TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN THERE MAY BE A
FISCAL DISINCENTIVE FOR THEM TO-
PROCEED WITH THAT AT THIS TIME
AND WE HAVE SUBMITTED A LETTER
TO COMMITTEE STAFF THAT OUTLINES
THE POTENTIAL SCENARIOS AND ARE
CONCERNED AND WE RECOMMENDED
THAT THERE BE A HOLD HARMLESS
AGAINST YOU CAN ROMANCE- IN
TERMS OF ALLOWING PEOPLE FUNDING
FOR T. K. IN ADDITION- RELATIVE
TO DECLINING ENROLLMENT AND THE
IMPACT ON STAFFING. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WITH DECLINING ENROLLMENT
WE ARE TO SEE LAYOFFS TAKING
PLACE WE KNOW FROM HISTORY THAT
THESE LAYOFFS HAVE A TENDENCY TO
IMPACT THE HIGHEST CONCENTRATION. SCHOOL THE MOST. THE SCHOOLS
THAT THEIR THE MOST. HERE AND WE
- THE ALLEGED TO FIND WAY
PROTECT STAFFING AT THE HEIGHT.
SCHOOL SO THAT THOSE TWO WHO
ATTEND A SCHOOL ARE NOT DAYS
BEFORE. IMPACTED BY DECLINING
ENROLLMENT THANK YOU. ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING A DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS
THIS IS ERIN BENSON FROM THE
BUTTE COUNTY SULFA AND I'M
CALLING TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES ADEQUATELY
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION IS
PARAMOUNT FOR ELLIE EIGHT TO
MEET THEIR OBLIGATIONS TO
STUDENTS UNDER THE I. D. E. A.
AND THIS WILL GO A LONG WAY TO
HELP THE LIAISON ABSENT
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
CONTRIBUTIONS. WE BELIEVE THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL MUST INCLUDE
EXPANDED INVESTMENTS IN THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR ALL
STUDENTS AND PARTICULARLY THOSE
WITH DISABILITIES AND THAT
ADDITIONAL TARGETED FUNDING FOR
THIS PURPOSE SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED FINALLY THE PROPOSAL
TO SHIP EDUCATIONALLY RELATED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUNDING
FROM SELFLESS TO LGAS RUNS
COUNTER TO THE LOCAL CONTROL AND
ECONOMIES OF SCALE THAT SELFLESS
PROVIDE IT WOULD INTERFERE WITH
STUDENT PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
UNLIKELY VIOLATE EDUCATION CODE
FIFTY SIX TWO OH SEVEN PROGRAM
TRANSFER. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK AND FOR YOUR TIME.
RIGHT FORTY TWO PLEASE AHEAD.
FORTY TWO YOUR LORD. A GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS HARPREET JOHN
PRINCIPLE HERE AT CAPITOL
HEIGHTS ACADEMY CHARTER SCHOOL
OKAY. OKAY ARE. SACRAMENTO
AROUND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
STUDENTS- WE ARE FACING
SIGNIFICANT LOSS OF FUNDING
ABSENCES RELATED TO CALL THE
CLOSURES IN ISOLATION. AND IN
OUR COMMUNITY THAT COULD RESULT
IN APPALACHIA LAYOFFS. OKAY CUTS
AND LOTS FAMILY PEOPLE THAT
WHICH WOULD TO BUY THE IN ACCRA
THAT WE ARE ALL WORK TO GET.
LIKE ALL L. U. EIGHTEEN MERRICK
TO PASS PROVIDE STUDENTS OF
FAMILIES INDEPENDENT STUDY OP
WHICH WE KNOW THAT NOT ALL
CHILDREN. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
AROUND EIGHT. OF ON INDEPENDENT
STUDY- AND THAT IMPACT NOT COLD
. OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE- GIVE IT
THAT OUR FAMILY AND GET WHO ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS IN THE WAITING
TO. SO IF WE GOT AND DO THINK
THERE RIGHT NOW- GET WE REALLY
NEED YOUR SUPPORT AND ENSURE
THAT OUR ARE CHARTER SCHOOLS
JUST MICHAEL DISTRICT WITH THE
PART FOR EIGHTY A LOT. AND THAT
WE HEAR THE THAT ACTION TO
PROVIDE PROTECTION FOR EIGHTY
LOT THIS ALL OUT. A. IN THE YEAR
AT UPON. AT IN CHARTER TO
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR PROPOSAL TO ON
CALL CARMEL PROTECT. BUT
DISTRICTS I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME IN YOUR- TO SUPPORT. ALL OF
OUR CALLERS ARE. AND TEAMMATES.
WE WILL GO TO. Q. MY TWENTY
EIGHT CALL A- GOOD AFTERNOON
MONEY IS APRIL THE I ONE COULD
NOT DOLLARS FOR THE WHOLE
EDUCATION ACT NISSAN THREE
ENSURING PROBE FOR ALL. I'M
CURRENTLY A STUDENT UC AND I
HOMELESSNESS AND ON THE- I
BELIEVE BOTH YOU DON'T THINK.
HOMELESSNESS. BIGELOW HIRED YOU
CAN THAT MOVED OUT IN SCHOOL
BECAUSE MANY TIMES THIS IS THE
OVERLOOKED COMMUNITY. BUT
REQUIRE WITH. AND SUPPORT- THAT
WILL BE PROVIDING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU PINE FORTY SIX.
YOU ARE ALL FORTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MICHELLE MCKAY UNDER
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CATTLE
SCHOOL FUNDING FOR. ON TO WHAT
WE ASK STATE TROOPER AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
AND THE B. L. AT A THE SAME COLA
FOCUS ON THE NEEDS TO THAT AND
RIVER CALL TO CREATE QUESTION
EXPAND PROGRAM. ALSO WITH THE
STATE'S FUNDING CIRCLE WE ASK
FOR ADDITIONAL READ. THE AND
HELPFUL ON THE OF EMPLOYEES WE
REALLY WANT TO YOU FROM MEMBER
OF FOR HIGHLY THE COMMONSENSE
TODAY. FINALLY ON ISSUE FOR
REPORTED FIVE AND MILLION DOLLAR
FIRST EDUCATION PROGRAM ABOUT
THE COST OF LIVING ADDRESS.
SEVEN THREE LEFT OF TO WITH THIS
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER PANEL. THANK YOU FOR
CAROLINE THIRTY PLEASE AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME NATIONAL REVIEW
BOTTOM CALL TO THE COURT WANT
BUDGET MAKE UP TO KIND MILLION
TO BETTER SERVE INSIDE THE
EDUCATION ACT. RESOURCES AND
TRAINING OUR PROGRAM. I THINK.
FACE SIGNIFICANT. IS THAT MORE
THAN POINT THREE MILLION
CHILDREN IN U. S. PUBLIC SCHOOLS
ARE HOMELESS. TO HISTORIC
HEIGHTS. IN CALIFORNIA AT FOR
APPROXIMATELY ONE FIFTH OF ON
THE- DIDN'T AND U. S. AND HAS
BRING FORTY EIGHT. OF OFF STATES
AND PERFORM ON ISSUE THE CHILD
HOME. BEING DIFFERENT BASE IN
NEW MORE TO IN. THANK GREATER
VOLATILITY THANK FACE CHALLENGES
WITH APLOMB- AND THEY OCT FAIL
REPEAT PROPER FOR KERR
COURSEWORK. WE BELIEVE IN THE TO
ME AN IMPACT. IN THE ROLE THAT
FEEL YOU PASS TO IMPROVE SERVICE
FOR YOU ATACANTE LEVEL THANK YOU. THANKS BAKER PLEASE. AND WILL
I THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS CHAMBERS
I'M A PROUD PARENT AND THE
EIGHTH GRADE AT ALEX TWYLA
TAKING ACADEMY I ACCESS FOR
SHORT. WHICH IS A PUB CHARTER
SCHOOL RAN ON PUBLIC FUNDS IN
FACT CA. AND I WANTED TO TAKE A
MINUTE TO ABOUT THE NAY IN EIGHT
ONE SAID WILL HAVE ON OUR IN
COMMUNITY WITHOUT YEARS OF. AND
OF CONCERN FOR OUR CHILDREN'S
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND TO ABIDE
BY SCHOOL IN CDC CODING
GUIDELINES LIKE ME ARE OFTEN
FORCED TO KEEP OUR CHILDREN AT
HOME IN ORDER TO PROTECT THEM AS
WELL AS OUR FAMILY.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN PARENTS ACT
RESPONSIBLY AND SAFELY BY
KEEPING OUR CHILDREN HOME OUR
SCHOOL IS PUNISHED BY AB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN WHICH WHICH HOLDS
ESSENTIAL FUNDING TO PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS WHEN OUR
STUDENTS QUARANTINED. THE IMPACT
OF KOBE ABOUT MADE EDUCATION A
CHALLENGE AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD
OUR STUDENTS ARE GOING TO NEED
ALL THE REINFORCEMENT AND
SUPPORT WE CAN OFFER WE NEED
LEARNING MATERIALS AND SUPPLIES
WE NEED A CLEAN AND SAFE CAMPUS
THAT WE CAN BE PROUD OF AND MOST
OF ALL WE NEED STAFF AND
TEACHERS PRESENT. ALL OF WHICH
ARE ALREADY SUFFERING- AND THE
MODEL AND MY SCHOOL IS COLLEGE
FOR CERTAIN AND WITHOUT THESE
ESSENTIAL RESOURCES ME AND MY
PARENTS PEERS WORRY ABOUT OUR
CHILDREN'S ABILITY TO REACH THAT
GOAL SO TODAY I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU LOG PLEASE TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION. TO MAKE THE CHANGES
NECESSARY TO PREVENT FURTHER
NEGATIVE IMPACTS TO OUR PUBLIC
CHARTER. SCHOOLS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. TWENTY THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SPEAKING TO THE TECHNICAL
CHART COMING TO BE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM.
THOSE FOR MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
EXPANSION PORTS SO WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE ONE
YEAR DELAY THIS YEAR GIVEN
DESCRIPTION OPPORTUNITY CLINICAL
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTING THIS
TRULY MAGNIFICENT VISION.
UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH WHAT MOST.
OR AT LEAST MANY DISCOVERED IS
THE PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
DESIGNED IS ESSENTIALLY FROM
WORKABLE. BUT WHAT THE MODEL IS
ARBITRARY AND EQUITABLE AND
WORST OF ALL ON CERTAIN REPLETE
WITH UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THE
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS DON'T
REFLECT THE REALITY OF WHAT
DISTRICTS ARE BASIC REGARDING
STAFFING ATTENDANCE IN
OPERATIONAL BANDWIDTH. WHICH IS
PROBABLY NOT SURPRISING GIVEN
THE VIRTUAL ABSENCE OF ANY
CONFLICT DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
DURING DEFERRED PROGRAM DESIGNED
LAST SPRING. WE ABSOLUTELY WOULD
CORRECT WHICH IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS WE KNOW THE
DOESN'T THE DISTRICT EAGER TO
SHARE THE EXPECTED. IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE FIXED BY
MY TWEAKS OR QUALITY CAN OFFERED
BY. SOME ARTS. TO IT MEAGER
TOTAL DOWN AND REBUILD SO DO
WILL HAVE A FIGHTING THE
COMPLEMENT WE CAN BROUGHT
PROVIDING DETAILS YOU LIKE THANK
YOU. SIX A LINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER THIS IS
DIANA SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
HIGHLAND CHARTER INTACT
TECHNICAL SCHOOLS WHERE I SERVE
A JUROR OF THE SERVICES. WE HAVE
HIGH WOULD LIKE TO THE LEAD FOR
THEIR FOR IN INCLUDE CHARTER AND
WHOLE TERM PROVISION EXPENSE FOR
THE KERN YEAR. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR INCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOL IN
YOUR CAN. FOR FUNDING EDUCATION
AT THAT DURING THIS CHALLENGING
TIME THANKS AGAIN. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. FIND TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME A CURRENT AND I AM
REPRESENTING SAME ACCOUNT OF
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT COUNTY AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT THE FIGHT
HUNDRED NINE AND FIRST WITH THE
- DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE ARE
CAN. THAT SOME DISTRICTS WILL
RECEIVE FEWER EDUCATION DOLLARS
NEXT YEAR I THINK YOU'RE ONE
TIME BECAUSE RELATED FUNDS ARE
MINUTE THE LEGISLATURE MESSENGER
THAT NO A FIFTY WORKS. DOLLAR
INTO FUTURE THREE. I WOULD ALL-
LIKE TO WITH THE WITH MY CALL
FROM YOU CAN AND THAT WE'RE
COULD ABOUT THE REDIRECT OF BAD
. RELATED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDING FROM PUBLIC TO
ALLEGHENY'S THE NEED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THAT GREAT IN
THE COMING PANDEMIC UNDER
COOKBOOKS DISRUPT CRITICS
IMPORTANT SERVICES THAT ARE WILL
AREA. FINALLY THE COMBINATION
SHE WOULD COP THE LEGISLATURE
MARKS SURE THAT NECESSARY SMALL
THAT CAN ACCESS THEIR EXISTING
OF MEMBERS. THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS AMY JOHNSON I'M A HE AND
IT'S COACH AT A BY CHOI SCHOOL
ARE SCHOOLS ARE LOCATED LAWNDALE
GUARDINO HARBOUR NO AND- WE
SERVE MORE THAN HUNDRED STUDENTS
GIPSON THE BURKE ASSEMBLY.
OTHERS AND GELATIN A JASON
DISTRICT AND MANY MY COLLEAGUES
OF THEIR. TO THERE ARE STILL
SPACES THAT NEVER GOT LOCKED IN
FOR DO TO THE ERRATIC AND- I'M
CAN'T STUDENT. FROM COVETED
BECAUSE INCOME BUT ACTUALLY. I'M
LIKE THIS DISTRICTS THIS YEAR
SCHOOL RECEIVE NO PER. FOR ADA
LOCKED DUE TO THE PHANTOM. I'M
WORRIED THAT I SHOULD IN THE
PROGRAM LIKE AT THEM SUPPORT
LEARNING LAW AFTER EDUCATION.
ARE EXPIRING OF ACTIVE AND I
MENTAL HEALTH. CUTTING PROGRAMS
BEING ALSO CUT THE JOBS SUCH
STAFF AND SHE- THEREFORE WE STEP
. SUBCOMMITTEE AT TO PARITY IN
FOR EIGHTY EIGHT FOR OF THE AIDS
AND CURRENT YEAR. ADDING SCHOOLS
ABOUT ABOUT TO REVISE ON TO.
HOLD HARM PROTECTION. DISTRICT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. WE
WILL THIRTY NINE YOUR OWN- NEAR
SUB MEMBERS TO MCCARTY HELLO MY
NAME IS SERGEY TERM OFTEN HERE
ON THE OF WE CAN TO. WELCOME
NINE CHARTERS IN THE GREATER SO
ON A WITH A FIVE THOUSAND ABUSE
YEAR. SCHOOLS ARE PRETTY THE LAW
FROM FINE DUE TO THE READING
PLAN DO ABSENCE OF THE OF
RELATED GOAL ON MY. AND ALLOW
WELL SCHOOL BE- BIG YEAR CHAU
SCHOOL RECEIVE PREPARE- YOU GUYS
WILL GROW I'M EIGHTY EIGHT- HOLD
ALMOST PER PERFECT- IF THE ABOUT
- FOR. THAT WILL NOT DOWN WE-
GIVE ALL SIX OF OUR TEACHERS
STAFF MAY FREE FOR YOU POTENTIAL
LAYOFFS. SO GOOD. WHICH UP
ACTION TO PROVIDE POWER PER DAY
FOR DEAL FOR. DALY OF THE
CURRENT- WILL SUPPORT ADDING
SCHOOL TO THE- PROPOSAL WEAVE.
ONE GOAL IN I'M GOING WORD HOW
THE WHOLE POMALYST. FOR DUTROUX
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. I AM CURRENTLY FEELING I
ALEXANDER I KNOW SOME YOU BUT AS
VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE IN EVERY
SCHOOL BUILDING UNDER HOW MUCH.
YOU RIGHT BECAUSE THAT IS THAT
YOU ARE PROPERLY AT THE IN THEIR
YOUR AND AB FOR TWENTY THEY HAVE
ACCESS THE REPORT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. THANK YOU LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY SEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. SHE THIRTY SEVEN
ONE MORE TRY. ARE MOVING ALONG
WITH A LINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M PATRICIA
GILLIAN ALEX WILL HAVE
CONNECTION I WANTED TO SUPPORT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE HOMEWORK EDUCATION ACCESS
RESOURCES AND TRAINING PROGAM
OR THE HEART PROGRAM IS LIKE
SEAT BECAUSE- I WORK WITH TO
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN THE COUNTRY AND
NOW MORE THAN EVER. HOMELESS
STUDENTS NEED SUPPORT NOT
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL IS
THE NUMBER ONE RISK FACTORS FOR
YOUNG ADULT HOMELESSNESS.
HOMELESSNESS WE MUST PROMOTE
EDUCATION AND HEART WOULD DO GET
BACK THROUGH TARGETED OUTREACH
SERVICES AND MAKING SURE THAT AT
LEAST ONE PERSON AT EVERY SCHOOL
UNDERSTAND STATE AND FEDERAL
LAWS AND STUDENT HOMELESSNESS
AND RELATED EDUCATION STRATEGIES
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. ONE FIFTY
YOU'RE OPEN. GOOD THIS IS BECKY
BOARD PRESS FOR THE POOR VALLEY
THIS AND LIKE MANY MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE AND ALSO OF SCHOOL
STUDENTS- I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
RESIST TO PUT THE BOOK OF
ADDITIONAL SPENDING A SPECIAL
PRO AND K. FUNDING WE ASK FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR BILLION IN THE
BASE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA. REKOLA TO THE DISTRICT
CAN. ON THE CORE FIRST. ALL THE
EIGHTY EIGHT FUNDING CLIFF THE
VERY REAL THREAT AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU TAKE
ACTION TO LESSEN ITS IMPACT AND
SEEK AN ALTERNATIVE TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FUNDING. I'M ENCOURAGED TO
HEAR U. DISCUSSED THIS IN THE
HEARING TODAY. WITH THE STATE'S
FUNDING SURPLUS WE ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES INTO CAL
THIRDS THE CALPERS. ON BEHALF OF
SCHOOL EMPLOYERS. AND EASE THAT
RISING LIABILITY ON SCHOOL
DISTRICT BUDGET. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION ON
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES. COME
NINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
BERGERE PRIMACK WITH THE CHARTER
SCHOOL CENTER OKAY- WITH THAT
MANY- PRIOR SPEAKERS REGARDING
THE NEEDS FOR COMING PROTECTION
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS TYPICALLY
STARTING IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
ALSO CONGRATULATE CAROLINE ON-
RETIREMENT AND OFFER HER WELL
WISHES OF NOTE A RARE ITEM
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE CHARTER
COMMUNITY A NUMBER OF DONALD
REGARDING THE NEED TO AUGMENT
THE BASE- BUT CRITICALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROLIFERATION OF HIGHLY
RESTRICTIVE CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS. UNDERMINING THE YEARS
OF PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE ON
LOCAL CONTROL FINALLY I SHARE
THE CONCERNS OF- THE PRIOR
SPEAKER REGARDING THE
PRACTICALITY OF THE EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAM AND AS IT GETS
REFORMULATED WE BELIEVE IT
SHOULD ALSO INCLUDE. ALL CHARTER
SCHOOL STUDENTS INCLUDING THOSE
AND NONTRADITIONAL CHARTER%
SCHOOLS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED FROM THE PROGRAM MANY
OF WHOM ALL NOTE THAT RESIDE IN
CHAIR. MCCARTY STIFF STRICT
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY SIX YOUR-
I GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ALEX KESSLER CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CELL BUT MINISTRY
YEARS WITH THE VISION OF
CALIFORNIA- WANTED TO COMMENT ON
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION- PROPOSAL-
WE CERTAINLY APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
THE BASE RATE. WOULD CAN KERR
WITH OF OUR COLLEAGUE WHO CALLED
IN ABOUT- TAKING A CLOSE LOOK AT
HOW THAT WILL WORK IN ENSURING
PARITY ALSO WANTED TO FLAG- THE
PROPOSAL RELATED TO
EDUCATIONALLY RELATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES- THAT IS ONE
THAT WE FEEL WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT YOUNGER
WE'RE HEARING FROM STAKEHOLDERS
ON THAT. AND WE EXPECT TO GET IN
TOUCH WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
MEMBERS ARE GOING FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSS THESE LENGTHY
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU. WHY THIRTY
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- GINGER GRASS DIRECTOR
OF BY CHARTER SCHOOL AND BEACH-
ARMY IS OF THE ABA HARMLESS-
PERHAPS I SHOULD JUST SHARE OUR
EXPERIENCE- THROUGH COVERED- AND
HOPEFULLY THAT HELPS IT'S THE
COMMITTEE DECISION ON WHAT TO DO
WITH OLD ARMOR BURKE WE'RE
LOOKING IN A AND NEIGHBORHOOD-
HARD HIT BY CO. RETEST WE'VE
SEEN THAT THIRTY FIVE PER DROP
IN ATTENDANCE RENDERS. YEAH
ABOUT WHAT OTHER SCHOOLS HAVE
IT'S- HERE JANUARY AND THAT'S IN
AT THE TO ITS PERCENT DROP SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR
BECAUSE WITH THE- LEARNING- AND
WE ARE READY SERVE. VULNERABLE
POPULATION WITH A TWO TIMES.
NEEDS ARE AND WE'RE IN A NEVER
THAT'S ABOUT YOUR 5% THAN THE
STATE OF POVERTY. SOMEWHERE TALK
ABOUT A DROP IN EIGHTY EIGHT X.
WITH THESE PARTICULAR
POPULATIONS OF THE- VERY HARD-
ON OUR BUDGET AND WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT WHY WE NEED TO DO IT
SO. LAYOFFS SO HOPE IS THAT- WE
CONTINUE TO SEE THE HOLD
HARMLESS BILL BEING A FIVE
EQUITABLY ACROSS- ALL SCHOOLS-
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR. WINDS
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURNER AND THE OF EACH
GABRIEL VALLEY SO BUTTON KERR
RECORD TO THE STUFF THAT MEASURE
THE COW. WE ARE OF THE SPECIALTY
PROPOSAL AND SUPPORT THE
INCREASE OF FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE BASE FUNDING WE
CONCUR WITH THE EARLIER COMMENT
TO THE COALITION OF ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
INCLUDES TWO OF THE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT NO ELEAZAR THE YOU
WERE SPECIAL EDUCATION DOLLARS
NEXT YEAR AT THIS YEAR ONE TIME
CODE RELATED FUNDS ARE REMOVED.
WE'RE ALSO APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS AND CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE LA- IN REGARD TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S NO IMPACT TO THE
REGIONAL IT'S MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THAT ARE
OFFERED SOME STUFF BUT TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS HAVE ACTIVELY
VITAL SERVICES DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED. ATTENTION TO
THESE STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
. AND- LADY JOSH ARE FINE. OUR
FINAL- PUBLIC. TODAY WILL BE
FIFTY NINE. GO AHEAD. YEAH HI
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN I
WOULD NEVER CORNER I HAVE A
GETTING INTO GREAT. GREAT GREAT
WITHIN THE FIRE HEIGHTS BUT AT
THE- MUCH AND WHEN I HEARD MADE
A THAT THE POPE SCHOOLS WERE
LOSING FOR EVERY TIME THEY HAVE
THE CURRENT OUTSIDE AND APPALLED
- I HAVE A- EDUCATION STILL WHO
WHO. AND IF YOU. FROM EVERY
THERE ARE IN PROPOSED- BUT ONE
OF OTHER STUDENTS TO IF WE CAN'T
WE IF THEY DON'T HAVE FINDINGS-
I'M ASKING EACH AND ONE OF- IN
THE PAST MEET EACH HUNDRED OUT-
ACCOUNTABLE THE TICKET. FOR WHAT
RIGHT I AM ASKING TO THINK I IF
THEY BY HEIGHTS AND ALL OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL PAN. ARE KEEP THE
OUR PEOPLE TREATED AND FIND
BEING- OUR FOR YOU TO MAKE THE
NEXT IN NAME IF THE COURT EIGHT
BY I THINK FOR MY- AND EVERY
OTHER TRIAL- BENEFIT PAID ALSO.
SCHOOL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THAT WE WILL ADJOURN TODAY'S
HEARING. FOR ONE. RESEARCH DR
OKAY- I THINK THAT WOULD A
COMMENT MY PROBLEM I WANTED TO
DO IT WITHOUT A CONTRACT.